WELCOME TO OUR A WEEKLY MEETING --
FOR A SUBCOMMITTEE.
THREE WE'RE GOING TO BEGIN --
BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE A QUORUM
THAT WILL BEGIN AS A SUB
COMMITTEE.
WELL WE'RE ALREADY SUBCOMMITTEE
WILL BEGIN AS A SUBCOMMITTEE OF
THE SUBCOMMITTEE -- AND I THINK
THIS MAY BE THE FIRST TIME --
THAT I CAN RECALL THIS EVER
HAPPENING WE DON'T HAVE A OF OUR
ONLY AGENDA -- WE WOULD BE
PASSING ON THAT TO TO WAIT FOR
QUORUM ANYWAY BUT WE WON'T BE
COMING BACK TO IT BECAUSE WE
DON'T HAVE -- ONE SO WE WILL
BEGIN WITH -- ISSUE -- ONE THE
CAP AND TRADE EXPENDITURE PLAN.
AND I WOULD TAKE NOTE I DON'T
THINK THERE'S ANY ITEM TODAY --
THAT WILL -- THAT IS NOT A
RECOMMENDATION TO HOLD OPEN THAT
CERTAINLY INCLUDES -- THE CAP
AND TRADE EXPENDITURE PLAN THE
ASSEMBLY WILL -- BE -- UNVEILING
ITS PLAN.
NEXT WEEK NEXT WEEK NEXT WEEK --
AND SO YOU'LL BE HEARING MORE
ABOUT THAT -- WE OBVIOUSLY HAVE
A A PACKED CROWD HERE TODAY WE
ALSO HAVE A PACKED AGENDA SO I
KNOW THERE'S A LOT OF YOU WHO
ARE GOING TO WANT TO ADD.
A PUBLIC COMMENT REGARDING CAP
AND TRADE.
IT'S GOING TO ASK YOU TO PLEASE
KEEP IT VERY VERY SHORT SO THAT
WE CAN.
GET THROUGH OUR ENTIRE AGENDA IN
TIMELY FASHION TODAY.
AND WITH THAT WILL -- AS FOR THE
PRESENTATION MS GORDON I
UNDERSTAND THAT -- TO AFTER
PRESENTING HERE YOU'RE GOING TO
NEED TO RUN OVER TO THE SENATE.
TO MAKE A PRESENTATION THERE
THEY'RE NOT AS IMPORTANT AS WE
ARE I KNOW THAT'S WHY WE'RE HERE
SO.
TAKE AROUND AS LONG AS YOU CAN.
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE AND
PLEASE PROCEED ABSOLUTELY --
THANK YOU SO MUCH -- IN MY
EXCUSE ME ASK EARTH WERE ABLE TO
ESTABLISH A QUORUM SO.
BEFORE YOU EVEN BEGIN WE WON'T
HAVE TO INTERRUPT YOU THIS WAY
ANY FURTHER NORTH.
LET'S TAKE ROLE.
I AM HERE FONG [inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
MULLIN [inaudible]
PATTERSON RAMOS [inaudible]
THIS YEAR.
AND THE FLOOR IS YOURS THANK YOU
SO MUCH -- BLOOM AND MEMBERS OF
THE SUBCOMMITTEE UP MY NAME IS
KATE GORDON I AM THE DIRECTOR OF
THE OFFICE OF PLANNING AND
RESEARCH IN THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE AND ALSO THE GOVERNOR
SENIOR ADVISER ON CLIMATE.
AND VERY HAPPY TO BE HERE TO
TALK ABOUT THE MAYOR VISION AND
ACTUALLY THE ENTIRE BUDGET ON A
PROPOSAL ON THE CAP AND TRADE.
EXPENDITURE PLAN JUST A COUPLE
OF OPENING KIND OF FRAMING
REMARKS ON THIS AS YOU ALL KNOW
AND HAVE BEEN PART OF THE STATE
IS MADE MAJOR PROGRESS AND
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSION
REDUCTION OVER THE PAST DECADE.
PARTICULARLY IN THE ELECTRICITY
SECTOR WE'VE SEEN JUST
INCREDIBLE GAINS IN MATTER
TARGETS EARLY I ELECTRICITY
HOWEVER.
WE'RE STILL SEEING REAL
CHALLENGES IN PARTS OF THAT OUR
SYSTEM WHERE EMISSIONS ARE
STEADY OR THEY'RE GOING UP AND I
THINK THAT.
CARDS SB ONE FIFTY REPORT LAST.
WINTER WAS VERY CLEAR THAT
PARTICULARLY THE TRANSPORTATION
SECTOR.
IS ONE WHERE BECAUSE OF
INCREASED DRIVING AND AND AGAIN
INCREASINGLY AND LIGHT DUTY
VEHICLES FORCING EMISSIONS
ACTUALLY RISE STEADILY YEAR BY
YEAR IN THE STATE -- WE'RE ALSO
SEEING EMISSIONS STAY STUDY OR
RISING BOTH THE AGRICULTURE TREE
AND TREE INDUSTRIAL SECTOR SO.
AND OF COURSE INCREASED
EMISSIONS FROM WILDFIRES.
AT THE SAME TIME AS THAT'S BEEN
HAPPENING TO THE LEGISLATURE'S
RIGHTLY FOCUS ATTENTION.
ON THE IMPACTS OF CLIMATE CHANGE
PARTICULARLY ON UNDERSERVED IN
VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES.
I THE BILLS I AB THREE NINETY
EIGHT SB SIX SEVENTEEN AND OF
COURSE SB NINE NO ONE ON THE
FIRE IMPACTS ARE ALL INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT.
CONTEXT FOR THE WAY THAT WE
SHAPED ON THIS BUDGET PROPOSAL.
SO THE BUDGET ESSENTIALLY THAT
WE PROPOSED -- A FOCUSES IN ON
THOSE AREAS WHERE WE HAVE NOT
BEEN SUCCESSFUL ON EMISSION
REDUCTION AND NEED TO DO MORE AS
WELL AS THOSE WHERE.
GREENHOUSE GAS POLLUTION
DIRECTLY MOST DIRECTLY IMPACTS
HUMANS PARTICULARLY IN
VULNERABLE AND UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES.
A KEY PRIORITY WAS.
TO PUT -- FOCUS ON THOSE
INVESTMENTS AGAIN THAT WOULDN'T
AFFECT INDIVIDUALS AND
COMMUNITIES DIRECTLY.
WITH THE INTERSECTION OF CLIMATE
IMPACT AND PEOPLE'S DAILY LIVES --
ARE REALLY SEEN AND FELT.
AND ALSO AND YOU'LL SEE THIS
WE'LL TALK MORE ABOUT IT ON YOU
KNOW LOOKING AHEAD AT AREAS
WHERE.
WE REALLY NEED TO DO MORE TO
FOCUS ON THE STATE'S LONG TERM
TRANSITION TO CARBON NEUTRALITY
BY TWENTY FORTY FIVE AND HOW TO
START PLANNING FOR THAT.
I SHOULD SAY AND I YOU KNOW I'M
NEW TO THE ADMINISTRATION BUT
I'VE BEEN INCREDIBLY PLEASED AT
THE COLLABORATIVE ENGAGEMENT
FROM THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE IN
THE AGENCIES ON THIS BUDGET AND
ALL OF MANY COLLEAGUES FROM THE
AGENCIES ARE HERE AND CAN SPEAK.
IN MUCH MORE DETAIL TO SPECIFIC
ITEMS ALL JUST GIVE AN OVERVIEW.
SO AN OVERVIEW ON ON THE FULL
BUDGET OF COURSE IN JANUARY --
YOU SAW A AND CONTINUE TO SEE IN
THE MIRROR VISION A STRONG FOCUS
ON FIRE -- RESILIENCE FOREST
MANAGEMENT AND DIE RESILIENCE
AND OF COURSE THAT'S CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT WE SAW LAST YEAR ONE
OF THE BIGGEST FIRE SEASONS.
EVER IN CALIFORNIA AND THE
CLIMATE NUMBER SHOW THAT THAT
WILL THOSE FIRES WILL CONTINUE
TO INCREASE IN SEVERTY AND
FREQUENCY SO THAT IS A STRONG
THEME THAT CONTINUES THROUGH.
THE MAYOR VISION.
THE MAJOR AREAS OF INCREASE IN
THE MAYOR VISION GO DIRECTLY TO
THAT WHAT I JUST SAID ABOUT SORT
OF FOCUSING IN ON THOSE AREAS
WHERE EMISSIONS HAVE NOT BEEN.
DROPPING AS FAST AS WE NEED TO
SEE THEM -- ALSO AGAIN WHERE I
WHERE THESE POLLUTION IMPACTS
MOST AFFECT WONDERFUL
COMMUNITIES SO I'LL GO THROUGH
THOSE AT A HIGH LEVEL.
I'M THE FIRST IS A SIGNIFICANT
INCREASE IN THE TRANSFER OF
CLIMATE COMMUNITIES PROGRAM.
I AS YOU KNOW -- THIS PROGRAM
THIS THIS INCREASE BRINGS A
PROGRAM TWO HUNDRED AND THIRTY
TWO MILLION WHICH IS CLOSE TO
ITS ORIGINAL FUNDING LEVEL NOT
QUITE THERE.
THIS PROGRAM IS IS SORT OF THE
AND IN SOME WAYS THE EPITOME OF
WHERE CLIMATE AFFECTS VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES AND WORK COMMUTE
WHERE HUMAN IMPACTS AND CLIMATE
IMPACTS INTERSECT.
THE PROGRAM FOCUSES ON COMMUNITY
SCALE PROJECTS MOST OF THEM
BRINGING TOGETHER HOUSING AND
TRANSPORTATION -- AS WELL AS
URBAN GREENING AND OTHER
IMPORTANT CLIMATE RESILIENCE
ASPECT INTO VERY SPECIFIC
COMMUNITIES WITH A FOCUS ON OUR
MOST VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES THE
PROGRAM TARGETS THE TOP 5% OF
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES IN THE
STATE.
ARE THERE IS A SPECIFIC FOCUS IN
THE PROGRAM AND MOST OF THE
PROJECTS REFLECT THIS ON THAT.
WRITTEN TO REDUCTION OF DRIVING
REDUCTION VMT THROUGH PROJECTS
THAT INCORPORATE MOBILITY
OPTIONS INCLUDING WALKING BIKING
TRANSIT BUT ALSO A FOCUS ON
AGAIN GREEN SPACES AND COMMUNITY
ENGAGEMENT ON THE PROJECTS WHICH
IS ONE OF THE THINGS THAT MAKES
IT.
UNIQUE -- THE BUDGET ALSO
INCLUDES -- AYE AYE STRONG FOCUS
ON DECREASING POLLUTION AND THIS
IS PARTICULARLY FROM I TRY AGAIN
THE TRANSPORTATION SECTOR WHERE
WE NEED TO MAKE REAL GAINS BUT
ALSO IN INDUSTRY AND AGRICULTURE.
THE BUDGET FOCUSES ON POLLUTION
DIESEL POLLUTION REDUCTION IN
THREE PLACES.
A FIFTY MILLION DOLLAR INCREASE
FOR CLEAN TRUCKS AND BUSES IN
OFF ROAD VEHICLE TRANSFORMATION
FIFTEEN MILLION INCREASE FOR THE
ENHANCED WITH THE FOREHAND SO
ENHANCE FLEET MODERNIZATION
PROGRAM SKEWS ME.
AND SIXTY FIVE MILLION INCREASE
FOR ENGINE UPGRADES A
REPLACEMENT FOR AGRICULTURAL
VEHICLES LL OF THESE PROGRAMS
REALLY GO STRAIGHT TO THE
QUESTION OF HOW DOES THIS HOW
DOES POLLUTION FROM THE SECTORS
WHERE WE ARE NOT MAKING AS AS
QUICK GAINES.
AFFECT PEOPLE WHERE THEY LIVE I
WANTED TO SAY A WORD ABOUT THE
ENHANCE WE ENHANCE FLEET
MODERNIZATION PROGRAM.
THERE'S BEEN AS YOU ALL KNOW AND
CONTINUES TO BE A STRONG FOCUS
AND STILL IS A FOCUS IN THE
BUDGET ON ON ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLES.
AND IT'S OF COURSE A HUGE
PRIORITY FOR THE STATE IN FRONT
ENHANCE FLEET MODERNIZATION
PROGRAM I THINK IS AN IMPORTANT.
STEP STONE TOWARD THAT IT'S A
PROGRAM THAT ALLOWS PARTICULARLY
ALLOWS PEOPLE TO RETIRE AND
REPLACE VEHICLES CALIFORNIA'S
TWENTY SIX MILLION LIKE TO THE
VEHICLES ON THE ROAD TO AT LEAST
TWO MILLION OF THOSE ARE OVER
TWENTY YEARS OLD.
THAT'S A HUGE CONTRIBUTOR TO OUR
SMOG PROBLEM AND MOST OF THOSE
ARE IN LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES
AND RURAL COMMUNITIES.
THIS PROGRAM SPECIFICALLY ALLOWS
AND HELPS PEOPLE REPLACE THOSE
OLDER VEHICLES WITH NEWER AND
IDEALLY THERE'S A KICKER FOR
ELECTRIC VEHICLE SO I THINK IT'S
A PARTICULAR IMPORTANT PROGRAM --
WE THINK TO SUPPORT.
THE AGRICULTURAL SECTOR I SAID
EARLIER ANOTHER ONE WHERE WE
HAVE MADE.
LIMITED GAINES GOOD GAINS BUT
THE EMISSIONS LEVELS ARE STAYING
FAIRLY FLAT IT'S A CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT SECTOR FOR CALIFORNIA
PROVIDING FIFTY BILLION DOLLARS
A YEAR TO THE ECONOMY AS YOU
KNOW AND PARTICULARLY CRITICAL
IN KEY.
AGRICULTURAL COUNTIES WE FOCUS
HERE ON PROGRAMS THAT PROVIDE
YOU WILL BENEFITS FOR THE SECTOR
ITSELF TO STRENGTHEN THE SECTOR.
AND STRENGTHEN CLIMATE SMART
AGRICULTURE AND ALSO REDUCE ON
EMISSIONS SAYS SPECIFICALLY A
TEN MILLION DOLLAR INCREASE IN
HEALTHY SOILS PROGRAM WHICH HAS
THE DOUBLE BENEFIT OF HELPING TO
SEQUESTER MORE CARBON
UNDERGROUND WHICH IS A CRITICAL
PIECE OF OUR CARBON NEUTRALITY
GOALS OVER THE LONG TERM.
AND ALSO A TEN MILLION DOLLAR
INCREASE IN THE METHANE
REDUCTION PROGRAM METHANE OF
COURSE IS ONE OF THE MOST POTENT.
GREENHOUSE GASES ON IN IN THE
NEAR TERM.
IN ADDITION TO THESE TARGETED
INCREASES IN KEY PROGRAMS THE
GOVERNOR'S PRIORITIZING
INVESTMENT IN THE OVERALL
TRANSITION OF THE STATE. TO A
CARBON NEUTRAL NEUTRAL ECONOMY
AND THESE DIRECT INVESTMENTS
INCLUDE.
A SIGNIFICANT INCREASE IN
PROVIDING WORKFORCE TRAINING AND
HIGHER TRAIN PARTNERSHIPS TO
HELP IDENTIFY AND SUPPORT HIGH
QUALITY JOBS ACROSS ALL THE
AREAS OF INVESTMENT.
I SHOULD SAY AND AND TEN RAINY
FROM THE WORK FOR STILL MEMBERS
HERE TO TALK MORE THIS BECAUSE
WE'RE SURE YOU'LL HAVE QUESTIONS
ABOUT IT.
WE SHOULD SAY THAT WE KNOW FROM
THEIR RESEARCH AN OUTSIDE
RESEARCH THAT THE MAJORITY OF
JOBS CREATED BY THE GREENHOUSE
GAS REDUCTION FUND INVESTMENTS
OVERALL ARE IN CONSTRUCTION.
AND CONSTRUCTION CAREERS ARE
CHANGING AS WERE ASKING FOR
CLEANER BUILDINGS GREENER
BUILDINGS TO CARBONIZED
BUILDINGS EFFICIENT BUILDINGS
WERE ASKING FOR NEW SKILLS AND
WE'RE ASKING FOR PEOPLE TO HAVE
THE SKILLS NECESSARY TO ACTUALLY
MAINTAIN THOSE EMISSION
REDUCTIONS.
WE KNOW FROM YEARS OF STUDY THAT
IF WORKERS IN THOSE FIELDS FIRST
OF ALL THERE'S A LIGHT LABOR
SHORTAGE IN THOSE FIELDS BECAUSE
OF A LACK OF TRAINING AND SOME
OF THESE GREEN BUILDING.
STANDARDS WE ALSO KNOW THAT
WORKERS IN THOSE FIELDS WHEN NOT
PROPERLY TRAINED AREN'T
REALIZING THOSE GAINS ENERGY
EFFICIENCY GAINS ARE LOST.
THROUGH ON INEFFECTIVE OPERATION
MAINTENANCE AND SO WE REALLY
THINK THERE'S A DIRECT
CONNECTION HERE.
BUT ALSO JUST A LONG TERM NEED
TO THINK ABOUT THE STATE'S
TRANSITION TO A CARBON NEUTRAL
ECONOMY AND YOU'LL SEE IN THE
MAY REVISION I INCREASE IN THAT
BUDGET SPECIFICALLY TARGETED. TO
THOSE COUNTIES THAT ARE
PARTICULARLY DEPENDING ON
DEPENDING ON FOSSIL FUELS THOSE
COUNTIES ARE KERN COUNTY WE
CALLED OUT IT IS THE NUMBER ONE
COUNTY -- FOR OIL AND GAS BY FAR
IN THE STATE WE CALLED IT OUT
BECAUSE KERN COUNTY IS ALREADY
SEEN JOB DECLINES THROUGH
AUTOMATION.
AND GLOBALIZATION ANOTHER MARKET
FORCES WERE OUT THERE ALSO GOING
TO SEE AND THE INDUSTRY
KNOWLEDGE IS THIS LONG TERM.
NEED FOR DIVERSIFICATION IN THAT
INDUSTRY BECAUSE OF JUST
POLICIES LIKE THESE SO WE'RE
LOOKING AHEAD TO THAT.
IN THIS PROGRAM.
IN ADDITION.
THE BUDGET INCLUDES SUPPORT FOR
HIGHER TRAINING PARTNERSHIPS AND
THOSE ARE ONE OF THE KEY.
I KEEP VEHICLES BRINGING
TOGETHER EMPLOYERS WORKERS
ECONOMIC WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
AND STAKEHOLDERS TO THE
COMMUNITY LEVEL TO RELEASE SEE
WHERE THOSE TRANSITIONS ARE
HAPPENING AND HOW WE NEED TO
BETTER TRAINED. FOR THE JOBS
THAT ARE EMERGING IN THE NEW
CARBON YOU TROLL ECONOMY.
YOU'LL ALSO SEE IN THE MIRROR
VISION SOMETHING THAT WAS NOT IN
THE JANUARY BUDGET WHICH IS A AT
ONE POINT FIVE MILLION FOR STUDY
TO PROVIDE A ROADMAP.
OF HOW TO DO THAT TRANSITION OR
CARBON NEUTRAL ECONOMY BY.
TWENTY FIFTY THAT ROAD MAP WILL
INCLUDE AND THIS IS NEW FOR I
THINK THE STATE BOTH
ENVIRONMENTAL AND ECONOMIC
FACTORS HOW DO WE LOOK AT HOW TO
SIGNIFICANTLY REDUCE OUR DEMAND
FOR FOSSIL FUELS.
AND OUR AND GET FOR CARBON
NEUTRALITY WILL ALSO CONSIDER
HOW THE STATE WILL MANAGE THAT
DECLINE THAT I JUST TALKED ABOUT
IMPOSSIBLE JOBS THAT'S ALREADY
HAPPENING TODAY.
AGAIN THROUGH AUTOMATION AND
THROUGH MARKET FORCES OTHER
STATES ARE SURPASSING US AND
WE'LL GAS PRODUCTION.
BUT ALSO JUST BECAUSE OF POLICY
CHANGES ACROSS THE GLOBE.
SO THAT'S THE HIGH LEVEL -- ON
THE MAYOR VISION THE GENDER
BUDGET IN THE MAYOR VISION AND I
WILL -- LEAVE IT TO YOU FOR
QUESTIONS AND I MAY CALL ON
COLLEAGUES FROM AGENCIES ON ON
ON SPECIFIC POINTS ARE FROM
FINANCE.
GREAT WELL WHY DON'T WE HEAR
FROM -- L. L. S. RAMP.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
ROSS BROWN WITH THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE.
BACK UP JUST A LITTLE BIT AND
PROVIDE A LITTLE BIT MORE
CONTEXT ON JUST SOME OF THE
NUMBERS AND THE NAY REVISION
AROUND REVENUE ASSUMPTIONS AND
HOW MUCH ADDITIONAL MONIES
ALLOCATED.
SO THE ADMINISTRATION ASSUMES
ROUGHLY SEVEN HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS MORE IN REVENUE
OVER FOR THE CURRENT YEAR AND
THE BUDGET YEAR AND SO -- UNDER
CURRENT LAW 60% OF THAT IS
CONTINUOUSLY APPROPRIATED A
CERTAIN PROGRAM SINCE THAT
LEAVES ROUGHLY THREE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS IN ADDITIONAL
REVENUE.
UP BEYOND WHAT THEIR ESTIMATED
IN JANUARY AND SO OF THAT THREE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS -- THE
ADMINISTRATION PROPOSES ALLOCATE
ABOUT TWO HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS MORE TO THE VARIOUS
PROGRAMS THAT.
THE DIRECTOR JUST MENTIONED
RIGHT NOW -- JUST ON THE REVENUE
ESTIMATES IN GENERAL WE THINK
THAT THEIR ESTIMATES ARE ARE
REASONABLE AND OUR ESTIMATES ARE
VERY SIMILAR TO THEIRS -- ONE
SMALL DIFFERENCE WE HAVE IS --
AN ESTIMATE ON REVENUE ON THE
NAY AUCTION WHICH ACTUALLY JUST
OCCURRED YESTERDAY WE WON'T KNOW
THE RESULTS OF THAT AUCTION OR
THE PRELIMINARY RESULTS UNTIL
NEXT WEEK SOMETIME.
BUT WE DO EXPECT THE REVENUE
WILL LIKELY BE A SOMEWHAT HIGHER
THAN THE ADMINISTRATION
ESTIMATED WE ESTIMATE ABOUT.
A HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS
HIGHER BASED ON CURRENT PRICES
FOR ALLOWANCES THAT WOULD LEAVE
AGAIN TAKING OUT THE 60%
CONTINUOUS APPROPRIATIONS ABOUT
SIXTY MILLION DOLLARS.
MORE A POTENTIALLY ONCE WE SEE
THE RESULTS ABOUT OPTION THAT
THE LEGISLATURE MIGHT WANT TO
CONSIDER ALLOCATING EITHER IN
THIS BUDGET OR IN FUTURE BUDGETS --
AND SO WHAT WILL UPDATE THE
LEGISLATURE ONCE THAT THAT
INFORMATION IS AVAILABLE.
ON THAT PARTICULAR ALLOCATIONS I
THINK AS WE'VE MENTIONED BEFORE --
REALLY IT MOSTLY COMES DOWN TO
THE ADMINISTRATION OR EXCUSE ME
THE LEGISLATURE'S PRIORITIES ON
HOW IT PRIORITIZE IS DIFFERENT
BENEFITS THAT COULD BE ACHIEVED
THROUGH THESE DIFFERENT PROGRAMS
YOU HEARD A LOT ABOUT THE
ADMINISTRATION.
PRIORITIZING TRANSPORTATION
EMISSIONS -- AND THAT MAKES A
LOT OF SENSE FOR A LOT OF
DIFFERENT REASONS BOTH ON THE
GREENHOUSE GAS SIDE.
AS WELL AS THE LOCAL AIR
POLLUTION SIDE OF THINGS BUT
THERE ARE A WIDE VARIETY OF
OTHER PROGRAMS OF COURSE THAT
THE LEGISLATURE MIGHT WANT TO
CONSIDER ALLOCATE IN THIS
ADDITIONAL FUNDING TO FUND INTO.
A DEPENDING ON WHAT IT'S
PRIORITIES PRIORITIES ARE
WHETHER THAT BE ADAPTATION --
RESEARCH SHORE OR OTHER THINGS
SO -- I'LL IN MY COMMENTS THERE.
THANK YOU A DEPARTMENT FINANCE
NO REPORT -- ANY QUESTIONS
[inaudible]
MS GARCIA.
I THANK YOU AND SO WITH THE LA --
MENTIONED LOCAL ERROR WHEN WE
DID.
CAP AND TRADE WEEK WE THIS
CONTINUES THE DISCUSS CLEAN AIR
WITH A CONTINUES TO DISCUSS
VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES -- AND WE
CAN TO LEASES BECAUSE MARRYING
THESE ISSUES AND WE AND AND THAT --
BUT THEY BE SIX SEVENTEEN ALONG
THE WAY WE HAVE THE FIRST SET OF
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE IN THE
PROCESS OF CREATING ACTION PLANS
AND WE HAVE.
DOLLARS ASIDE THEIR LATER THIS
YEAR WE ARE SUPPOSED TO BE
SELECTING A SECOND SET OF
COMMUNITIES -- BUT I SEE THAT
WE'RE NOT DOING ANY INCREASE
YOUR FOR COMMUNITY ACTION PLANS
ARE FOR THAT WORK UNTIL
WONDERING IF THAT'S SOMETHING.
THAT THE ADMINISTRATION HAS
LOOKED INTO OUR WHY THE CHOICES
NOT TO AUGMENT THAT.
THAT BUDGET.
THERE'S PROBABLY SOMEONE FROM
AIR BE HERE WHO CAN SPEAK TO
THIS AS WELL BUT OUR
UNDERSTANDING WE LOOK VERY
CLOSELY THAT AND THANK YOU FOR
THAT BUILT BY THE WAITT WE LOOK
VERY CLOSELY AT THAT PROGRAM AND
WE WERE.
GIVEN THE EIGHT WE WERE INFORMED
BY I AIR BE THAT ESSENTIALLY TWO
HUNDRED WAS WAS THE MAXIMUM THAT
THEY WOULD BE ABLE TO SPEND ON
THE PROGRAM AT THIS TIME.
GIVEN ALL KINDS OF THINGS
CAPACITY TIME LINES -- DEADLINES
ETCETERA SO WE ACTUALLY LOOKED
SPECIFICALLY AND INCREASES THEIR
AND WORK.
TALK THROUGH IT AND WERE GIVEN
TO UNDERSTAND THAT AN INCREASE
AT THIS TIME WOULDN'T ACTUALLY
CREATE ADDITIONAL BENEFITS BUT
WE SHOULD LOOK AT IT AGAIN.
THANK YOU FOR THAT ANSWER AND SO
THEN MY SECOND PART OF THE
QUESTION OR MAYBE IT'S MORE OF A
STATEMENT AT THIS POINT.
IS.
AS WE ADD MORE THINGS INTO HOW
WE SPLIT UP OUR CAP AND TRADE
DOLLARS WE SET UP CERTAIN
EXPECTATIONS WHILE IT MIGHT BE A
ONE TIME ALLOCATIONS PEOPLE
START TO BELIEVE THAT THESE
MIGHT BE CONTINUOUS.
AND IT'S HARDER TO TAKE IT AWAY
LATER ON AND TO GIVE IT INTO
KNOWING THAT MAYBE AT THIS POINT
THE AIR BE IF I CAPACITY BUT
THESE TEN COMMUNITIES ARE COMING
UP.
WE HAVE AT LEAST TEN COMMUNITY
ACTION PLANS WE DIVVY UP THE
MONEY OR LIKE IN ABOUT TWENTY
MILLION PER ACTION PLAN WHICH
THE REALITY MEANS THAT. ONE
YEAR'S NOT GONNA COMPLETE THAT
ACTION PLAN THERE WILL BE MORE
MANY NEED EFFORTLESS ACTION
PLANS PLUS THE TEN YOU
COMMUNITIES THAT COME IN LATER
IN THE YEAR AND AND SO FORTH AND
SO.
I ARE WE CONSIDERING YOU SEEN
GENERAL FUND FOR SOME OF THESE
THINGS -- WE HAVE SOME GOOD
IDEAS IN HERE RIGHT
TRANSPORTATION IS ONE OF MY
BIGGEST ISSUES IN MY BACKYARD --
TRANSFORMATIVE CAN A COMMUNITY --
IS ANOTHER VERY PREGNANT SO BOTH
HAVE WE CONSIDERED THE FACT THAT
WE HAVE ALL THESE EXTRA DOLLARS
IN OUR GENERAL FUND AND DOING
DOING SOME OF OUR CLIMATE CHANGE
WORK AND SEWER CLEANER WORK AND
PAYING FOR IT.
FROM GENERAL FUND THIS WELL I
DON'T THINK.
I DON'T THINK WE EXPECTED COMEDY
A TEACHER R. F.. TO BE THE ONLY
SOURCE FOR THESE DOLLARS IN OUR
ONLY SOLUTION AND IT'S A LOT OF
ENOUGH MONEY BE ASKED ME AND I
WILL I LIVE FINANCE ENTER IF
THEY IF THEY LIKE TO GO TO THAT
THE ONE THING I WILL SAY IS THAT
THE ADMINISTRATION.
HAS BEEN VERY FOCUSED ON EXACTLY
THIS POINT OF INTEGRATING
CLIMATE GOALS PARTICULARLY
AROUND RESILIENCE AND
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES IN TWO
OTHER PROGRAMS THAT DON'T SHOW
UP HERE IN THE JEEP CHEROKEE
IT'S NOT THE ONLY PART OF MONEY.
THAT NEEDS TO BE FOCUSED ON
THESE ISSUES SO IF YOU LOOK AT
THROUGHOUT THE BUDGET THAT THE
HOUSING PRIORITIES FOR INSTANCE
IN THE FOCUS ON INFILL
INFRASTRUCTURE -- AS A AS A AS A
STRATEGY TO BRING DOWN VEHICLE
EMISSIONS THROUGH HOUSING THERE
OTHER PROGRAMS LIKE THAT AS WELL
SO I WILL I FULLY AGREE WITH YOU
THIS IS NOT THE ONLY PLACE WHERE
WE SHOULD BE REFLECTING THESE
PRIORITIES.
THE OTHER POINT IS THAT EACH OF
THESE TO YOUR DESERVES
COMMUNITIES POINT.
EACH OF THESE OTHER PRIORITIES --
I THINK THERE IS A STRONG FOCUS
ON ON EQUITY WERE ON THE
TRANSFER OF CLIMATE COMMITTEES
PROGRAM THE ENHANCE FLEET BIT
MODERNIZATION PROGRAM AND DIESEL.
POLLUTION GENERALLY ALL HAVE A
SIGNIFICANT IMPACT ON THIS
COMMUNITY SO WE WOULD SAY THAT
THE SIX SEVENTEEN IS A BIG PIECE
OF THAT AND PARTICULARLY WHERE
THE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE COMES
IN.
BUT THAT THAT'S A THEME
THROUGHOUT THESE INCREASES.
DID YOU PRESS ONE OF AN AND AND
THEN JUST TO REITERATE THE POINT
WHETHER IT'S AB SIX SEVENTEEN OR
OTHER WAYS YOU'RE GIVING UP
MONIES.
YOU MENTIONED HOW WERE NOT
GETTING THE MISSIONS THAT WE
WOULD HOLE FOR RIGHT IN AND WE
TALKED ABOUT THE AG SECTOR AND
WE'VE BEEN PRETTY GENEROUS OVER
THE YEARS AND THE SAME QUESTION
HAS COME UP WITH AB SIX
SEVENTEEN OF WHAT ARE WE PUTTING
IN PLACE NOW. TO MAKE SURE WE
ARE TRACKING RESULT IN ARE WE
INVESTING THE MONEY THE BEST
WAYS HOW ARE IF OUR EARLY
INVESTMENTS HAVING GIVEN AS THE
VESSEL SHOULD WE KEEP PUTTING
MORE MONEY INTO THE SAME
PROGRAMS.
ARE SURELY BE YOU KNOW THINKING
ALONG THE WAY AND SO IT'S
SOMETHING THAT I HAVE CONCERNS
NOT JUST WITH -- WITH.
YOU KNOW WITH THE AG INDUSTRY
BUT ALSO WITH AND EVEN THE A. B.
SIX SEVENTEEN WORK I WAS JUST
TRYING MONEY RANDOMLY THIS ANY
ABOUT WORKING OR NOT AND WHAT
ARE WE DOING. TO MAKE SURE WE'RE
LEARNING AND ADJUSTING ALONG THE
WAY PART OF IT IS THAT A LOT IS
NEW RIGHT WE'RE HAVING TO LEARN
ALONG THE WAY BUT ARE WE MAKING
SURE THAT WE'RE STOPPING A
REFLECTING ON THOSE LESSONS ON A
REGULAR BASIS.
IT'S A GREAT QUESTION -- I THINK
THAT THE SB ONE FIFTY REPORT WAS
ACTUALLY VERY HELPFUL IN SORT OF
CALLING THE QUESTION ON SOME OF
THESE INVESTMENTS AND REALLY
POINTED TO THE TRANSPORTATION
ISSUE.
I WOULD SAY THAT I'M IN THE
AGRICULTURE SECTOR SPECIFICALLY
THERE'S A LOT OF WORK HAS BEEN
DONE TO SHOW THAT THAT YOU KNOW
THE SALT AND MAPPING PROGRAMS IN
PARTICULAR ARE VERY GOOD
INVESTMENTS IN TERMS OF GHG
REDUCTION FOR THE MONEY.
ON THESE ARE SECTORS THAT ARE
INDUSTRIAL SECTORS THAT ARE
GROWING AND SO THERE IS THAT
TENSION AND I THINK WE DO NEED
TO CONTINUE LOOKING AT THAT BUT
IT'S ONE OF THE MAJOR REASONS
WERE LOOKING AT THAT LONG TO
STUDY TO REALLY SAY WHAT WE MEAN
WHEN WE SAY.
CARBON NEUTRALITY AND HOW DO WE
ACTUALLY GET THERE WHAT'S THE
LONG VIEW.
OKAY THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THIS GOMEZ REST.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
I FIRST WANT TO APPLAUD THE
ADDITIONAL.
MONIES INCREASING MONIES IN THE
TRANSFORMATIVE -- CLIENT
COMMUNITIES.
MY QUESTION IS HOW MANY MORE
CAN BE IDENTIFIED. TO HELP --
THROUGH THIS THROUGH THIS NEW
FUNDING.
WILL WE WANNA.
LEASE BEDS WERE THROUGH RUNS A
PROGRAM IF YOU'RE GONNA HAVE TO
COME UP AND GOOD MORNING I'M
LOUISE BEDWORTH EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE STRATEGIC GROWTH
COUNCIL -- WITH ADDITIONAL
FUNDING -- WITH AT THE TCC
PROGRAM WE LOOK TO MAKE AN
INVESTMENT BETWEEN ABOUT TWENTY
FIVE AND THIRTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS.
JUST THEM OUT WE VIEW TO
NECESSARY TO MAKE TRANSFORMATIVE
INVESTMENT IN THE COMMUNITY SO
WITH THE AMOUNT IN THE PROPOSED
BUDGET WE CAN PROBABLY.
SERVE ABOUT FOUR COMMUNITIES --
WE ALSO HAVE BEEN MAKING
INVESTMENTS IN PLANNING GRANTS.
AND HAVE ABOUT FIFTEEN
COMMUNITIES WHO HAVE BEEN
WORKING ON PLANNING GRANTS -- TO
GET READY FOR ACCESSING A NUMBER
OF FUNDING PROGRAMS INCLUDING
THE TCC PROGRAM.
IS THAT LIST OF THE THE
COMMITTEES ARE WORKING WITH IS
NOT AVAILABLE.
YES I WOULD BE HAPPY TO PROVIDE
THAT FOR YOU THANK YOU
APPRECIATE THAT.
WE'RE GONNA HAVE ANOTHER
QUESTION OKAY NOT ON THIS OKAY
THANK YOU FOR YOUR RESPONSE.
THANK YOU I TIME.
OR DID YOU HAVE MORE STORY.
AND THEN WE'LL MOVE TO MS RIVAS
THE THE FIFTY FIFTY MILLION
INCREASE FOR THE CLEAN TRUCKS
BUSES AND OFF ROAD VEHICLES.
IN SOME PLACES IT WAS ZERO
EMISSION SOME PLACES I
UNDERSTAND IT'S NEAR ZERO IS
THIS ZERO EMISSION.
IT'S A GOOD QUESTION AIR BE
QUESTION.
HERE.
WE DON'T KNOW EVERYTHING ABOUT
EVERY PROGRAM IT TURNS OUT. TO
THE RIGHT PEOPLE.
HI THIS IS ANDY KANSEN WITH THE
CALIFORNIA AIR RESOURCES BOARD.
WE DO HAVE ANOTHER CHAIR OVER
HERE OKAY SOMEBODY ONCE -- THAT
WOULD ACTUALLY BROWN.
OR CLEAN TRUCK AND BUS FUNDING
DOES GO TO A NUMBER OF DIFFERENT
TECHNOLOGIES -- ZERO MISSION OF
THE BATTERY ELECTRIC IN FUEL
CELL ALSO -- LOW KNOCKS --
INTERNAL COMBUSTION ENGINES AND
HYBRID EQUIPMENT HYBRID VEHICLE
SO IT IT REALLY IS A COMBINATION
OF THOSE DIFFERENT TECHNOLOGIES
AND THE FUNDING WHICH WOULD BE
DIRECTED.
TO OUR CLEAN TALK ABOUT VOUCHER
PROGRAM WHICH FUNDS AS
TECHNOLOGIES AS WELL AS
TRANSFORM THE FREIGHT PROJECTS.
IS THIS A CHANGE IN THE WAY THE
PROGRAMS OF ALL.
NO THIS IS -- IT DID THIS SHOULD
BE ALLOWING US TO CONTAIN IT
SPEND THESE PROGRAMS TO MEET THE
DEAD.
DEMAND THAT'S THE TO COMING IN
BECAUSE IN THE END WE WANT TO BE
ZERO EMISSION.
HOW IS THAT HOW IS IT GOING TO
BE DIVIDED UP -- SO. ZERO
MISSION IS NOT -- THERE FOR ALL
OF YOU KNOW FOR ALL POLL.
OPERATIONS IN VEHICLE CLASSES SO
IT'S A COMBINATION OF HERE.
FOR WORK -- IT IS FOR FUNDING
FOR COMMERCIALLY AVAILABLE
TECHNOLOGIES IN SOME CASES IT'S
ZERO MISSION IN SOME CASES IT'S
HYBRID IN SOME CASES IT'S LOW
KNOCKS.
AND THEN WE DO A DEMONSTRATION
PROJECTS TO TRY AND BRING
CLEANER TECHNOLOGIES TAUGHT. TO
MARKET SO THAT WE CAN -- BRING
ZERO MISSION TECHNOLOGIES TO
MARKET IN AREAS WHERE IT'S NOT.
NOT CURRENTLY OTHER COMMERCIAL
STAGE.
VERY GOOD THANK YOU MY LAST
QUESTION STRUCTURE.
WHEN YOU DESCRIBE TO THE THE
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS
PROGRESS?
WHEN YOU TALKED ABOUT THE AG
INDUSTRY SAID THAT IT WAS
STAYING STUDY?
YOU TALKED ABOUT -- INDUSTRIAL
INDUSTRIAL YOU TALKED ABOUT --
TRANSPORTATION.
YOU SAID WAS GETTING WORSE.
AND YEAH OUT. FOR AG WE HAVE
SIXTY FIVE MILLION. FOR
AGRICULTURE DIESEL ENGINE
REPLACEMENT AND METHANE
REDUCTION TEN MILLION MORE.
AND I GO BACK TO WHAT MY
COLLEAGUE SAID. FOR A. B. SIX
SEVENTEEN THERE'S NO INCREASE
AND I HEAR YOUR I I HEARD YOUR
RESPONSE.
AND FOR THE CLEAN TRUCKS BUSES
AND OFF ROAD.
VEHICLES. FIFTY MILLION THERE
SEEMS TO BE.
IF WE'RE SAYING THAT ADDRESS IS
BETTER.
THEN THE OTHERS YET WE'RE
SPENDING SO MUCH MORE TIME ON AG.
I'M A LITTLE CONCERNED ABOUT
THAT WITH ALL DUE RESPECT MY AG
COLLEAGUES.
IT MAY BE THAT SOMEBODY FROM
CDFA WANTS TO SPEAK MORE TO THIS
I'LL JUST SAY THAT THE AG
VEHICLE PROGRAM DIESEL REDUCTION
PROGRAM IS AT THE INTERSECTION
OF TRANSPORTATION AND
AGRICULTURE.
SO IT'S IT'S ACTUALLY SORT OF
ALMOST AT THE INTERSECTION
TRANSPORTATION AGRICULTURE AND
INDUSTRY WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
VEHICLES THAT ARE IN IT VIEW
BEING USED IN THE AGRICULTURAL
SECTOR BUT THAT ARE CONTRIBUTING.
TO DIESEL AIR POLLUTION IN THOSE
COMMUNITIES SO IT'S A IT'S AN
INTERSECTION OF THOSE TWO THINGS
WHICH IS WHY.
IT'S SO CRITICALLY IMPORTANT
THESE ARE ALSO -- VEHICLES THAT
ARE -- ARE ARE USED EVERY DAY
THEY'RE USED A LOT OF HOT
WEATHER THERE USED IN PARTS OF
THE STATE WHERE AIR.
POLLUTION STAYS IN THE SAME
PLACE FOR A LONG TIME DOESN'T
BLOW AWAY SO THERE'S A
PARTICULAR INTEREST IN LOWERING
POLLUTION.
IN THOSE AREAS -- SO THAT'S THE
ONE KEY WAY TO DO IT.
WELCOME TO MY AREA THAT'S YOU
KNOW ONE OF THOSE AREAS WHERE
DOES STAY THERE.
BUT WE WE DON'T HAVE THE AG BUT
WE DO HAVE IS A LOT OF WE'RE
WE'RE RIGHT IN THE MIDDLE OF THE
THE THE THE TRANSPORTATION --
THAT COMES FROM THE PORTS INTO
THE WAREHOUSES -- AND IT'S ALL
THOSE DIESEL TRUCKS WERE IN A
VALLEY AND IT ALL STAYS THERE SO
WE GET EVERYTHING FROM LOS
ANGELES WITH ALL DUE RESPECT MY
LA PEOPLE -- BUT IT ALL COMES
FROM LA AND THEN ALSO THOSE
TRUCKS FOR THE PORTS AND THAT'S
AB WE WANT THE INDUSTRY BUT WE
DON'T WANT TO HAVE THAT RIGHT
HARM TO OUR PEOPLE.
THAT'S EXACTLY I MEAN I I GREW
AGREE WITH YOU THIS IS WHY THE
JANUARY BUDGET STARTED THE CLEAN
TRUCKS DIESEL NUMBER SO MUCH
HIGHER THAN THE AYE NUMBER AND
THE NUMBR STILL COMES OUT AT
ONE EIGHTY TWO VERSUS -- FINAL
NUMBER OF NINETY IN THE AG
SECTOR SO ABSOLUTELY BOTH OF
THOSE ARE CRITICALLY IMPORTANT
IN THESE PARTS OF THE DEEPLY AND
ON THEIR EMPIRE AND CENTRAL
VALLEY.
OF BOTH OF THESE INDUSTRIES ARE
GROWING.
THERE'S A LOT OF VEHICLES
THERE'S A LOT OF POLLUTION FROM
THE VEHICLE SO BOTH ARE
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT BUT YOU'LL
SEE THAT THAT IF YOU LOOK ACROSS
BOTH THE JANUARY AND THE MAY
BUDGET WHERE THAT COMES OUT.
AT NIGHT AND IT'S STILL I WANT
TO SAY THAT IT IS IT IS STILL OF
CONCERN.
THAT IN THE INLAND EMPIRE VERY
SPECIFICALLY -- THAT WE WE DO WE
DO.
WE ARE RECEIVING SO MUCH MORE.
OF WHAT WE DON'T WANT AND
FINDING WAYS TO TO TAKE CARE OF
OF THAT IS EXTREMELY IMPORTANT
TO TO THE COMMUNITY THANK YOU.
AND MS GARCIA THE JOB SOMETHING
HONEST TO GOD JUST ON THIS --
THAT THE TRUCKS START AT THE
PORT AND HAD THROUGH MY DISTRICT
AND HEAD OVER TO MISS RAY IS AND
AS WE'VE SEEN ALL IS YOUR HOUSE
POPPING UP.
A LOT OF THEM IN HER AREA -- NOT
AT ALL ANY AG IN MY AREA BUT 5%
WAS POLLUTED AIR ALSO IT'S THE
THIRD BETWEEN THE THE FREEWAYS
IN THE RAILYARDS.
AND WE'RE SEEING THIS ROTH AND
WE'RE HAPPY FOR ITS GOOD FOR THE
ECONOMY BUT IT'S IMPACTING IS
REALLY ONE OF THE COMMUNITIES
AND SO THE STRUCK ISSUES ALSO
REALLY IMPORTANT.
AS WE SEE THE CONNECTION THERE.
THANK YOU THINK [inaudible]
MS RIVAS.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR -- YOU
KNOW I WAS DISAPPOINTED -- TO
NOT SEAT FUNDING FOR GREEN
SPACES -- AND I KNOW WE'VE
DISCUSSED THIS BEFORE AND IN
OTHER HEARINGS -- THE LACK OF
FUNDING FOR THAT YOU KNOW I
THINK OUR LOW ESPECIALLY OUR LOW
INCOME COMMUNITIES NEED MORE
PARKS AND TREES -- URBAN
FORESTRY SO DOES THIS MY MISSING
SOMETHING OR DOES THIS PROPOSAL.
REINSTATE THAT FUNDING SO UGH
THROUGH MAYBE NOT IN THE LINE
YOU'RE USED TO SEEING IT -- THE
TRANSFORMATIVE CLIMATE
COMMUNITIES PROGRAM DOES HAVE A
FOCUS ON URBAN ON GREENING AS
PART OF ITS PROJECT SO THAT'S
WHERE YOU SEE THAT FOCUSES THAT
INCREASE AN INTEGRATED APPROACH.
TO COMMUNITY SKILL DEVELOPMENT
IN MOST IS ADVANCE COMMIT THE
MOST AS A BENCH COMMITTEES OF
THE STATE WITH THAT COMBINATION
OF HOUSING AND DEPENDING ON THE
PROJECT AND WHAT THE COMMUNITY
WANTS.
COMBINATION OF HOUSING
TRANSPORTATION GREEN SPACES AND
CLIMATE RESILIENCE THAT'S WHERE
YOU SEE THAT INCORPORATED.
SO AS PART OF A MORE INTEGRATED
COMPREHENSIVE PROJECT.
OKAY BUT BEFORE IT WAS MORE
AVAILABLE TO OTHER COMMUNITIES
REGARDLESS IF THEY QUALIFY THAT.
FOR THAT TRANSFORMATIVE CLIMATE
COMMUNITIES RIGHT WHICH IS.
A BIG.
PROJECT -- BIG.
SO THAT THAT'S JUST MIGHT NOT IT
MIGHT TAKE HER IN FOR SURE.
LILY I JUST.
I WOULD LIKE TO SEE MORE OF THAT
I THINK IT'S DISAPPOINTING
BECAUSE IT'LL AYE AYE IT YOU
KNOW MY COMMUNITY -- IS THE
RECIPIENT OF A T. C. C. GRANTS
AND VERY EXCITED -- AND PROCLAIM
A BUT I'M COMMUNITIES LIKE IT
THAT DON'T HAVE THE CAPACITY --
YOU KNOW TO APPLY FOR THAT BIG
GRANT -- I THINK WE'RE MISSING
THEM.
IN TERMS OF GREEN SPACE ACCESS
TO GREEN SPACE IT'S ABSOLUTELY
IMPORTANT THANK YOU SO THE THANK
YOU FOR THAT COMMENT THE URBAN
GREENING PROGRAM THAT'S NOT
FUNDED IN THE ADMINISTRATION'S
PROPOSAL BUT IS SOMEHOW.
A CAREER TESTIMONY INCORPORATED
INTO THE TRANSFORMATIVE CLIMB
THE COMMUNITIES THAT THEY'RE
VERY VERY DIFFERENT PROGRAMS AND
THE THE TCC.
AS YOU STATED IS FOCUSED ON FOR
COMMUNITIES HOUSE -- AND I'M NOT
SURE I UNDERSTAND -- THE
ADMINISTRATION'S APPROACH ON
THIS AND ALSO -- URBAN FORESTRY
AND WETLANDS IS -- IS LEFT OUT
CAN YOU EXPLAIN JUST KIND OF THE
OBVIOUSLY WE'RE GONNA COME BACK
WITH OUR PROPOSAL -- BUT WHAT'S
THE ADMINISTRATION'S THINKING ON
THIS NO ABSOLUTELY AND I SHOULD
CLARIFY I'M BY NO MEANS SAYING
THAT THOSE PROGRAMS ARE
INCORPORATED INTO DCC I'M JUST
SAYING THAT YOU SEE SEE HAS.
AN URBAN GREEN COMPONENT SO
THERE IS A COMPONENT SO ENOUGH
WORK AND IN MEAN INTERRUPTED BUT
AS FOR COMMUNITY YES THERE WOULD
BE SUMMER BEEN GREEN IN HIS ONE
ARE THE PRIORITY EXACTLY IT'S
ONE OF THE PRIORITY ELEMENTS OF
THOSE PROJECTS SO THAT I WAS
MERELY SAYING THAT THAT.
IS AN ELEMENT THAT'S
INCORPORATED ONE OF THE
INTERESTING THINGS ABOUT TCC IS
THAT IT.
THE CORPORATE TO MANY OF THESE
THINGS INTO INDIVIDUAL PROJECTS --
PLACE BASED INVESTMENT WITH LOTS
OF THE DIFFERENT CATEGORIES
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT SO GOOD
RIGHT ABOUT THE OTHER TWO
CATEGORIES HOWEVER.
THE BEG THE QUESTION WHY WHY NOT --
URBAN GREENING URBAN FORESTRY
AND AND WETLANDS FUNDING.
THAT IS A GOOD QUESTION NO I
THINK IN THE JANUARY BUDGET
THERE WAS A REAL INTENT AND IT
GOES TO SOMETHING SAID EARLIER.
TO TRY TO FOCUS MORE DOLLARS ON
FEWER THINGS AND CHOICES WERE
MADE AROUND AGAIN THOSE AREAS
WHERE WE'RE REALLY NOT SEEING
THE EMISSIONS IT REACTIONS AS
QUICKLY AS WE NEED TO SEE THEM.
AND WHERE THOSE THERE'S THOSE
KIND OF IMMEDIATE POLLUTION
IMPACTS.
WHAT DID NOT MAKE IT INTO THE
JANUARY BUDGET YOU SEE THE MAY
REVISE REALLY INCREASES THINGS
THAT WERE IN THE JANUARY BUDGET?
AND SO IT'S IT'S HARD TO ANSWER
I SPECIFICALLY FOR ME AT LEAST
WHAT EXACTLY MADE IT AND IT
DIDN'T BUT I WILL SAY THERE'S A
STRONG FOCUS ON JUST.
NARROWING AND I USING DOLLARS IS
ABOUT PLEASE POSSIBLE -- THE THE
LA -- ESTIMATES -- ABOUT A
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS
MORE IN CAP AND TRADE FUNDING
THAN THE ADMINISTRATION.
OF WE HAD AN AUCTION YESTERDAY I
THINK SOME OF THE LA OWES.
MOST OF THE LA OWES -- ANALYSIS
WAS PREDICATED ON A DIFFERENT
DATA.
SAID METRICS FOR YESTERDAY'S
AUCTION DO WE HAVE ANY --
INITIAL DATA ON YESTERDAY'S
AUCTION -- OF FOR EXAMPLE --
WE'RE ALL THE CREDITS SOLD WHAT
WE KNOW NOT THAT I KNOW OF IS --
INTERVIEW DO WE HAVE.
THAT.
UP THE COMING UP THEY HAVE THE
DETAILS.
THEY USUALLY DO IF.
I'M ACTUALLY AT CHIANG AS DEPUTY
EXECUTIVE OFFICER AT THEIR
RESOURCES BOARD I'M ACTUALLY
HERE TO TELL YOU THERE ARE NO
DETAILS.
SO AS AS THE LA -- MENTIONED WE
DID HAVE AN AUCTION YESTERDAY
WHAT I CAN TELL YOU IS THAT.
THE OPTION WINDOW OPENS AND THE
OPTION WHEN HOW CLOSE
SUCCESSFULLY WITH THE TECHNOLOGY
WORKS WE HAD A SUCCESSFUL
AUCTION WE ANNOUNCE AUCTION
RESULTS IT'LL BE EARLY NEXT WEEK
AND SO THAT IS WHEN ALL OF THE
INFORMATION IS AVAILABLE.
THERE'S NO INITIAL METRICS RIGHT
NOW EVEN THE QUESTION OF HOW
MANY -- WERE SOLD RIGHT I DON'T
KNOW I ACTUALLY I DON'T KNOW SO
ALL OF THAT INFORMATION IS KEPT
CONFIDENTIAL.
AND SO I DON'T KNOW ANY OF THAT
INFORMATION WE GO THROUGH A
PROCESS BETWEEN THE TIME OF THE
AUCTION IN THE TIME IT'S
ANNOUNCED.
WHERE -- WE VERIFY THAT ALL THE
PROCEDURES WERE FOLLOWED THE
MARKET MONITOR THE INDEPENDENT
MARKET MONITOR THAT WE HAVE GOES
THROUGH THE AUCTION TO MAKE SURE
THAT EVERYTHING WAS DONE
PROPERLY.
SO THERE'S A GAP AS WE'RE GOING
THROUGH THAT PROCESS BEFORE THAT
RESULTS ARE OFFICIALLY ANNOUNCED
AND AND THE OFICIAL
ANNOUNCEMENT IS THAT A DATE
CERTAIN OR IS THAT IT IS AND I
THINK I'M TRYING.
TO IT'S USUALLY LIKE THREE DAYS
OR FOUR DAYS AFTER THE AUCTION I
THINK IT'LL PROBABLY BE THIS
MONDAY CERTAIN GODDESS.
IT'S I THINK IT'S MONDAY OR
TUESDAY I CAN LOOK I CAN LOOK IT
UP BECAUSE IT ACTUALLY I THINK
IT IS POSTED ON OUR WEBSITE BUT
I DON'T HAVE IT OFF THE TOP WE
HAVE YEAH I MEAN AT AN SORRY.
MR CHAIRMAN -- MOST OF THE TIME
I THINK IT'S A A WEEK AFTER THE
AUCTION OCCURS USUALLY AROUND
NOON KIND OF THE YOU KNOW THE
NEXT WEEK ON THE SAME DAY.
SO -- PERHAPS TUESDAY OBJECTIVE
DATA NOON I THINK BETWEEN OUR
LOOK IS SCHEDULED MEETINGS FOR
NEXT WEEK THERE YOU GO.
OF ALL RIGHT WELL THANK YOU FOR
THAT -- FOR THAT INFORMATION --
LET'S TAKE PUBLIC COMMENT NOW --
AND I AND I KNOW THERE'S A
NUMBER OF YOU WHO ARE -- COMING
FORWARD TO SPEAK -- I EIGHT NEED
TO INSIST SNOT **** BUT INSISTS
THAT YOU STATE YOUR NAME WHO
YOU'RE REPRESENTING AND A VERY
VERY BRIEF STATEMENT OF THE THE
FUNDING GOT A REQUEST YOUR
SUPPORT THAT YOUR OF PROVIDING
US WITH.
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS SYLVIA
SOLUTION ON BEHALF OF THE SAN
HOCKING VALLEY AIR POLLUTION
CONTROL DISTRICT.
WE ARE GRATEFUL FOR THE INCREASE
IN FUNDING FOR THE FARMER
PROGRAM WE WOULD LIKE TO SEE AN
ADDITIONAL AUGMENTATION THIS IS
A PROGRAM THAT REDUCES CRITERIA
POLLUTANTS AS WELL AS GHG
EMISSIONS -- VERY SUCCESSFULLY
WE WOULD ALSO LIKE TO SEE AN
INCREASE IN AB SIX SEVENTEEN
FUNDING.
I JUST A REMINDER THE VALLEY HAS
TWENTY OUT OF THE THIRTY TOP
MOST DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
IN THE STATE THIS FUNDING IS
CRITICAL FOR US TO MEET OUR
STATE IMPLEMENTATION PLAN GOALS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU.
BEEN SUGGESTED BY MY COLLEAGUE
THAT IT SHOULD BE A REQUEST IT
SHOULD BE A DEMAND.
BUT WE HOPE MAINTAIN IT AS A
REQUEST.
GOOD MORNING ABOUT ANYWHERE SO
IT'S NOT WITH THE CALIFORNIA
FARM BUREAU FEDERATION WE
SUPPORT THE INCREASE IN THE
FUNDING FOR THE AGRICULTURAL
DIESEL ENGINE ON REPLACEMENT
PROGRAM BUT LIKE THE SAN JOAQUIN
VALLEY.
AIR POLLUTION CONTROL DISTRICT
WE WOULD ALSO LIKE TO SEE
ADDITIONAL FUNDS PROVIDED TO
THAT IMPORTANT PROGRAM THANK.
GOOD MORNING OF FURTHER ON THE
ON BEHALF CALIFORNIA RELEASE --
DO ONE OFFER A QUICK COMMENT ON
ON THE URBAN FORESTRY IN
GREETING AND HE SAYS HE
DISCUSSION.
WE'RE VERY SUPPORTIVE TCC AND
AND ARE GLAD TO SEE THE
INVESTMENTS BE MOVING FORWARD
BUT WANT TO CLARIFY THAT BECAUSE
TO SEE AS PRIMARILY FOCUSED ON
THE TOP 5% OF DC'S -- FOR
EXAMPLE AND AND BE A SOMETHING
ONE WANTS DISTRICT -- PACOIMA
WHAT QUALIFYING BUT ANYBODY
ANYWHERE ELSE IN THE DISTRICT
WOULD BE DISADVANTAGED OR DE
PRIORITIZED I SHOULD SAY --
WHICH IS WHY ADDITIONAL
INVESTMENTS FUHRMAN GREETING
URBAN FOR SURE SO CRITICAL --
JUST A TAD ADDITIONAL CONTEXT OF
THE TWO HUNDRED MILLION TO DATE
AND THAT WILL BE.
ISSUED TO TCC THAT'LL PLANT
ABOUT TEN THOUSAND TREES IN AN
OBVIOUSLY VERY CRITICALLY TO
CEMENT COMMUNITIES BUT JUST THE
SEVENTY MILLION THAT WENT OUT
LAST WEEK FROM CALIFORNIA'S AND
FORCE YOU PROGRAM USING --
EXISTING FUNDING THAT IS NOW
METABOLIZED -- TWENTY ONE
THOUSAND TREES WILL BE PLANTED
JUST TO PROVIDE SOME CONTEXT
THAT'S THAT'S THE BANG FOR YOUR
BUCK -- IN BEING ABLE TO REACH
MANY MORE COMMUNITIES THROUGHOUT
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA -- WHAT
IT WOULD ALSO LIKE TO I THANK
THE CHAIR FOR FOR CONTINUED
COMMENTS ON THE BROADER NATURAL
LOOKING LANDS -- DISCUSSION AND
ENCOURAGE ADDITIONAL PRIORITIES
AND PRIVATIZATION THERE THANK
YOU.
WELL ONE OF THE MEAT ON A
WITHOUT A BY CALIFORNIA WERE
INCREDIBLY DISAPPOINTED WITH THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL WHERE
DOESN'T HAVE -- IN PRIORITIZE
NATURAL WORKING LAND
SPECIFICALLY WETLANDS IN AREAS
LIKE THAT -- THE THE THE THE THE
SECRETARY OR STATED THAT MAIL
FROM THE BEGINNING THEY
PRIORITIZE MORE MONEY ON CERTAIN
AREAS AND WAS INTERMIX THAT THE
PRIORITIZE OTHERS.
AND IT'S REFLECTED IN THE BUDGET
THEY DE PRIORITIZED THE NATURAL
WORKING LAND SECTOR WITH THE
OTHER YOU KNOW -- IDEAS OF BACK
FILLING WITH PROP SIXTY EIGHT
MONEY WHICH IS NOT WHAT IT'S
SUPPOSED TO BE DOING SO WE WANT
TO SEE THOSE THINGS INCLUDED
BACK IN THANK YOU.
MARIN BMB HAVE AND TURN NATIONAL
LONG SURE WHERE HOUSE UNION --
HAS THAT EVERYONE KNOWS WE HAVE
A GOAL TWENTY THIRTY FOUR ZERO
EMISSION EQUIPMENT -- WHERE THAT
REGULATION HAS PUT -- THE I. O.
W. IN THE WORKERS IS THAT A LOT
AND SOME EMPLOYERS ARE PUSHING
TO AUTOMATION.
I USING PUBLIC FUNDS -- WHICH
MEANS LOSING HUNDREDS OF JOBS I
THINK THAT ISSUE IS.
IS KNOWN HERE IN THE LEGISLATURE.
AND WHAT WE'RE ASKING IS FOR
SPECIFIC ALLOCATION FOR OP POOR
EQUIPMENT.
WE ARE THERE IS AN ALLOCATION
THERE WE ASK FOR AN INCREASE WE
HAVE EMPLOYERS TO HAVE.
COMMUNICATED TO US TODAY.
THEY WANT THEY NEED SOME
ADDITIONAL STATE FUNDING I SO
THEY KEEP OUR WORKERS EMPLOYED
AND NOT WE COULD HAVE WE SUPPORT
CAN IMPORTS BUT WE DON'T ONE AND
UP WHAT FULLY AUTOMATED.
I PORTS **** AN OPPORTUNITY TO
KEEP JOBS IN CLEAN THEM HERMAN
THANK YOU.
A GOOD MORNING MATTEO CROWN TO
HAVE THE MOUNTAINS RECREATION
CONSERVATION AUTHORITY AND SANTA
CLARA VALLEY OPEN SPACE A THIRTY
WOULD LIKE TO ALIGN OUR COMMENTS
WITH AUTUMN ON CALIFORNIA.
AND REITERATE OUR SUPPORT -- FOR
NATURI SOURCE INVESTMENT THAT WE
DON'T SEE IN THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL THANK YOU.
MR TURN MEMBERS THE SILENCE
ELLIS WITH THE NATURE
CONSERVANCY IN THE INTEREST OF
TIME WE WOULD ALSO LIKE TO ALIGN
OUR COMMENTS WITH THOSE MADE BY
OTHER BOND.
AS WELL AS RELIEF JUST IN TERMS
OF OUR ONGOING CONCERNS RUN A
LACK OF FUNDING FOR NATURAL
WORKING LET'S THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS BRENDAN TO
WORK ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
AIR POLLUTION CONTROL OFFICERS
ASSOCIATION THAT'S THAT THIRTY
FIVE EXECUTIVE OFFICERS FROM THE
THIRTY FIVE LOCAL AIR DISTRICTS --
JUST ON AB SIX SEVENTEEN
INCENTIVE FUNDING WE HAVE BEEN
ADVOCATING FOR A SUBSTANTIAL
INCREASE IN THAT FROM A FROM THE
TWO HUNDRED MILLION.
AND THE NEED IS MASSIVE. FOR
THIS INCENTIVE FUNDING IN THE
ASSOCIATED REDUCTIONS AND WE ARE.
THE PROGRAMS -- IT WOULD BE OVER
AT THE MONIES OVERSUBSCRIBED AND
WE'RE CONFIDENT THAT WE CAN GET
THAT.
MONEY OUT TO EXPEDITIOUSLY --
THE OTHER THING IS ON EIGHTY SIX
SEVENTEEN IMPLEMENTATION FUNDING
AND WE DO APPRECIATE THE
QUESTIONS RELATED TO THAT --
THERE IS -- AN ONGOING NEED.
NOT HAVING A CONSISTENT FUNDING
SOURCE -- THAT YOU CAN RELY ON
FOR THAT IMPLEMENTATION FUNDING
IS CAUSING ISSUES AT AT THE
LOCAL DISTRICTS IN TERMS OF
HIRING STAFF WE ALSO THAT MONEY
IS ALSO USED -- FOR THAT THAT
COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH PURCHASING
MONITORING EQUIPMENT DEVELOPING
THE EMISSION REDUCTIONS PLANS
AND SO I JUST I DID WANT TO KEEP
THAT ON THE RADAR -- AS A VERY
IMPORTANT ISSUE GOING FORWARD TO
MAKE SURE WE KEEP THE PROGRAM
RUNNING SMOOTHLY SO I THINK WE
DID HEAR COMMENTS EXCUSE ME.
ATARI.
DID YOU HAVE A COMMENT THAT YOU
WANT TO ADD NOW OR A QUESTION
JUST A QUESTION THAT WE HEARD
EARLIER THAT.
THEY ARE BE WAS AT CAPACITY.
SO.
ARE YOU IS A ARE BE ABLE TO TAKE
ON MORE MONEY AND PROVIDE MORE
MONEY MORE MORE ASSISTANCE TO
COMMUNITIES I CAN'T SPEAK TO
THAT.
THE STATEMENT THAT WAS MADE BY
AIR BE BUT I CAN TELL YOU AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL -- WE WOULD BE
CONFIDENT AND IN BEING ABLE TO
GET THAT MONEY OUT THANK YOU
OKAY [inaudible]
WELCOME.
ALLEN ABS WITH THE BAY AREA AIR
QUALITY MANAGEMENT DISTRICT LIKE
TO ASSOCIATE MY COMMENTS WITH --
MY COLLEAGUE FROM CAP COLA ALSO --
TO NOTE -- ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GARCIA'S COMMENTS ABOUT -- WE
STARTED OUT WITH TEN A. B. SIX
SEVENTEEN COMMUNITIES THERE'S AN
EXPECTATION THAT WE'RE GOING TO
BE ADDING COMMUNITIES EVERY YEAR
FOR THE FORESEEABLE FUTURE WHICH
MEANS MORE IMPLEMENTATION COSTS.
AS WELL AS MORE INCENTIVE
FUNDING TO GET EMISSION
REDUCTIONS IN THOSE COMMUNITIES
BUT WHAT WE'RE SEEING RIGHT NOW
IS ACTUALLY DECREASING --
AMOUNTS GOING TO SIX SEVENTEEN
AND SO -- AS MR TO ACCEPT WE'D
LIKE TO SEE -- THOSE ARE SIX
SEVENTEEN AMOUNTS INCREASED ALSO
TO NOTE HIS COMMENT -- THE BAY
AREA A Q. M. D. COULD SPENT WERE
TREMENDOUSLY OVER SUBSCRIBED --
FOR DIESEL EMISSION REDUCTION --
INCENTIVE FUNDING AND WE COULD
SPEND MONEY AS FAST IS -- CARB
COULD PROVIDE IT -- IF THEY
COULD PROVIDE THANK YOU.
CHAIR MEMBERS ROSS BUT THE ON
BEHALF OF SOUTH COAST AIR
QUALITY MANAGEMENT DISTRICT LIKE
THIS IS A MY COST OF THE
PREVIOUS TWO SPEAKERS ABOUT THE
NEED FOR INCREASED FUNDING FOR
SIX SEVENTEEN PROGRAM.
THANK YOU.
THAT WAS VERY CONCISE.
WE NOW HAVE A LONG HISTORY
EVERYONE.
DO WE NOT ASK ABOUT HAVE THE
CALIFORNIA ELECTRIC
TRANSPORTATION COALITION WE
ACTUALLY I THINK THE
ADMINISTRATION FOR THE INCREASES
THAT IT'S MAKING IN LOW CARBON
TRANSPORTATION FUNDING
SPECIFICALLY MEDIUM AND HEAVY
DUTY.
IT'S STILL UNDER FUNDED BUT WE
APPRECIATE THE INCREASE AND THE
CLEAN VEHICLE REBATE PROGRAM WE
WANT TO MAKE ONE POINT.
THE GOVERNMENT THEY IT THE CARD
IS CURRENTLY WORKING ON CHANGES
TO THE PROGRAM WE THINK THE
ALLOCATION TO SEE THE R. P.
SHOULD REFLECT THE NEED FOR THAT
PROGRAM BASED ON THOSE CHANGES
WE ENCOURAGE THIS COMMITTEE. TO
WORK WITH KERR ABOUT WHAT THOSE
CHANGES WOULD BE AND WHAT THAT
NUMBER SHOULD ACTUALLY BE TO
LIVE WITHIN THEIR MEANS OF THAT
PROGRAM AND SO IT'S NOTHING
COULD BE MORE THAN TWO HUNDRED
MILLION BUT I DON'T.
BUT I DON'T KNOW AND YOU SHOULD
DEFINITELY WORK WITH CARBON
FIGURE THAT NUMBER OUT.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU CHEN MEMBERS NIKITA
CROWDED WITH THE NATURAL
RESOURCES DEFENSE COUNCIL WE
SUPPORTING AUGMENTATION IN THE
LOW INCOME WEATHERIZATION
PROGRAM UNDER CST IT'S ONE OF
THE MOST CRITICAL AND EFFECTIVE
PROGRAMS FOR MAINTAINING HEALTHY
IN AFFORDABLE HOMES FOR LOW
INCOME FAMILIES.
AS YOU PROBABLY KNOW LOW INCOME
FAMILIES SPEND A
DISPROPORTIONATE SHARE OF THEIR
INCOME ON THEIR HOUSEHOLD ENERGY
BILLS THIS PROGRAM IS REDUCE ON
AVERAGE ENERGY BILLS BY 30% AND
HOUSEHOLD ENERGY USAGE BY ALMOST
40% -- ALL LIKE ON THE OTHER
PROGRAMS THAT HEAVILY
OVERSUBSCRIBED AND WE'D LIKE TO
SEE THAT AUGMENTED THANK YOU SO
MUCH.
HI ANALLY SEVERO DEFENDERS OF
WILDLIFE AND WE'D LIKE TO ALIGN
OUR COMMENTS WITH THOSE MADE BY
AUDUBON IN THE NATURE
CONSERVANCY AND OUR
DISAPPOINTMENT A LACK OF FUNDING
FOR NATURAL WORKING LANDS THANK
YOU.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS CHAISSON BRIAN ON BEHALF
OF THE WESTERN I'D DERRY MEN --
SHOULD THE GOVERNOR'S INVESTMENT
AND HELPING THE DAIRY INDUSTRY
REDUCE ITS METHANE EMISSIONS WE
THINK MORE IS NEEDED NECESSARY
IN ORDER TO MEET THE OBJECTIVES
OUTLINED.
THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE SB THIRTY
THREE I WAS A POOR TO WORK WITH
MINISTRATION IS COMMITTED TO DO
THAT THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING TREES BROKERAGE ON
BEHALF OF THE COMMUNITY ALLIANCE
WITH FAMILY FARMERS AS WELL THE
CALIFORNIA COMPOST COLLISION
WE'RE JUST URGE THE COMMITTEE TO
ADOPT THE SENATE VERSION OF THE
D. G. R. F. WHICH INCLUDES
THIRTY MILLION FOR HEALTHY SOILS.
A HUNDRED MILLION FOR COVER
CYCLE AND TWENTY FIVE MILLION
FOR ALTERNATIVE MANURE
MANAGEMENT THANK YOU.
HI GOOD MORNING PVC LEADERSHIP
COUNCIL FOR JUSTICE AND
ACCOUNTABILITY AND A MEMBER AND
ON BEHALF OF SAY HI.
I'M THREE THINGS REAL QUICKLY
WERE SUPPORTIVE OF THE INCREASE
IN T. C. C. WE WERE REALLY
HOPING TO SEE AN INCREASE TO A
HUNDRED FORTY MILLION DOLLARS.
THE IMPORTANT PROGRAM AND LIKE
TO SEE THAT THAT GOING UP AND UP --
FOR TRANSFORMATIVE INVESTMENTS
ON SIX ONE SEVEN OR HAPPY WITH
IT WITH THE FUNDING WE NEED TO
SEE RULES AND REGULATIONS SO
THAT.
ACTUALLY RESULT IN EMISSION
REDUCTIONS -- IN IN ALL OF THE
MOST IMPACTED AREAS AND
THROUGHOUT THE STATE FINALLY WE
WERE DISAPPOINTED TO SEE AN
INCREASE IN THE METHANE
REDUCTION ON THE THAT THAT DAIRY
SIDE.
IN THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET WE WERE
HOPING TO SEE NO FUNDING
DIRECTED TOWARDS DERRY DIE
JESTERS SO WE'RE DISAPPOINTED TO
SEE BOTH THE INCREASE.
AND LACK OF CLARITY AS TO WHICH
PROGRAM THAT MONEY WILL BE
DIRECTED TOWARDS.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS AT JENNIFER APPEARING ON
BEHALF OF THE CENTER FOR FOOD
SAFETY IT'S SIMILAR TO MY
COLLEAGUE SETON.
THAT CENTER FOR FOOD SAFETY
REMAINS TROUBLED BY ANY
PROPOSALS TO FUND DERRY DIE
JESTERS AND THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL DOES LACK CLARITY ON
THIS FRONT.
THIS TECHNOLOGY DOES NOTHING TO
ADDRESS THE MASSIVE WATER
CONTAMINATION AND OTHER
ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACTS OF THESE
MASSIVE OPERATIONS AND WE'D LIKE
TO SEE THE LEGISLATURE STOP
SUPPORTING THE FALSE PROMISE OF
DATE AYE JESTERS AND START
INVESTING MORE AND REGENERATIVE
FARMING PRACTICES.
THAT BETTER PROTECT PUBLIC
HEALTH THE ENVIRONMENT AND
ANIMAL WELFARE THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
ON WITH WEIDMAN TO APPEAR ON
BEHALF OF THE WHY DID A
CALIFORNIA BASED MANUFACTURER
BETTER ELECTRIC TRUCKS AND BUSES
AND WOULD LIKE TO THINK THE
ADMINISTRATION FOR THE
AUGMENTATION TO THE S. PATROL
FOR HEAVY DUTY PROGRAMS.
BUT WOULD ALSO LIKE TO SEE MORE
STABILIZE FUNDING AND CONSISTENT
FUNDING OVER THE NEXT COUPLE OF
YEARS THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS BY THE
WALL FROM CALIFORNIANS AGAINST
WASTE A WE'RE VERY HAPPY TO SEE
THAT I INCREASE IN FUNDING FOR
THE HEALTHY SOULS PROGRAM.
ARE DISAPPOINTED THAT -- I
FUNDING FOR COVER CYCLES ORGANIC
DIVERSION PROGRAMS HAVE NOT
INCREASED -- THEY'RE STILL
ORDERS OF MAGNITUDE LOWER THAN
THEY NEED TO BE TO ME ARE THE
STATE'S ASPIRATIONAL GORE GOALS
FOR SB THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE ARE
CURRENTLY TWENTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS ALLOCATED BUT THE STATE
ESTIMATES THAT. TWO TO THREE
BILLION DOLLARS WILL BE NEEDED
I'D TO MEET THOSE GOALS -- AND
AGAIN JUST AS A REMINDER IF
THESE ARE THE PROVING TO BE THE
MOST OF COST EFFECTIVE -- WAYS --
IN TERMS OF DOLLAR SPENT TOWARDS --
TONS OF GREENHOUSE GASES REDUCE
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE LARA
KNOWING HE CHECK ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA CITRUS MUTUAL
CALIFORNIA FRESHFORD ASSOCIATION
CALIFORNIA CONGENERS GROWERS
ASSOCIATION WESTERN ACT
PROCESSORS ASSOCIATION.
CALIFORNIA JERRY ZINC AND OTHER --
ACT TRADE ASSOCIATIONS AND
COMMISSIONS -- WE JUST WANT TO
EXPRESS OUR APPRECIATION AND
SUPPORT FOR THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET OF INCREASING BOTH THE
FUNDING FOR THE FARMER PROGRAM
THAT ACTORS OR PLACEMENT.
AND THE JERRY METHANE REDUCTION
PROGRAM -- AS WE DISCUSSED IN
THIS COMMITTEE FOR THEY'RE BOTH
IMPORTANT PROGRAMS -- WE'D WE DO
WANT TO WORK WITH THIS COMMITTEE
AND THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE ON
INCREASING THAT FUNDING EVEN
MORE -- TO MEET OUR CLIMATE
BOTH -- SB THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE
AND THEN ALSO CARBS STATE
IMPLEMENTATION PLAN THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING COMMITTEE MEMBERS --
AND CHAIR I AM HERE FROM CAN
AMERICAN FARMLAND TRUST KATIE
PATTERSON AND WE ARE HERE IN
SUPPORT OF THE HEALTHY SOILS --
AUGMENTATION AND WE'RE VERY
APPRECIATIVE OF THE
ADMINISTRATION'S -- LONG TERM
INVESTMENTS THERE -- WE DO SEE
THAT THERE IS ADDITIONAL FUNDING
THAT SHOULD BE PROVIDED -- TO
REALLY GIVE THE PROGRAM THE
SCALING CAPACITY FOR TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE PROVIDERS AND
IMPLEMENTATION ON THE GROUND AND
FIFTY MILLION IS REALLY WHAT
THAT TARGET NUMBER IS --
ADDITIONALLY -- FORTY MILLION
FOR AMP AND SWEEP WHICH IS THE
STATE WATER EFFICIENCY
ENHANCEMENT PROGRAM WHICH IS --
CRITICAL AND LOOKING AT SOME OF
OUR CHALLENGES THAT ARE FACING
AGRICULTURAL INDSTRY AND OUR
OTHER COMMUNITIES DOWN THE
VALLEY -- FOR IMPLEMENTATION OF
SIGMA WE SEE THAT IS A REALLY
CRITICAL TOOL WHILE WE'RE NOT IN
DROUGHT RIGHT NOW -- THIS IS A
REASONABLE INVESTMENT TO PREPARE
FOR FOR THE FUTURE OCCURRENCE
HAS WE BELIEVE THAT TO BE
INEVITABLE THANK YOU SO MUCH.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS RECALL MONSTER TO NOT A
WITH THE TRUST FOR PUBLIC LAND.
I WANT TO CONTINUE TO THANK THE
CHAIR AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER TO
GIVE US AND REST FOR YOUR
CONTINUED SUPPORT OF THE URBAN
GREENING IN URBAN FORESTRY.
THOSE -- PROJECTS ARE PROBABLY
OUR BEST INVESTMENT IN
INTERVENTION TO PREPARE OUR MOST
VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES FOR
HEATING FLOODING.
AND WHILE TORNADOES AND
HURRICANES GET THE HEADLINES
HEATING FLOODING ARE THE
DEADLIEST WEATHER RELATED EVENTS
IN THE LAST THIRTY YEARS IN THE
UNITED STATES.
AND TO THE ADMINISTRATION'S
POINT THE TCC PROVIDES AN URBAN
GREENING COMPONENT THAT'S TRUE
BUT GETTING AT TCC PROJECT IS
LIKE WINNING THE NBA LOTTERY I
MEAN YOU GET.
MAYBE FOR PROJECTS THE FIRST
GERMAN GREENING GRANTS ONE OUT
TO THIRTY NINE COMMUNITIES WE
NEED AS MANY OF THESE
COMMUNITIES PREPARED FOR WHAT WE
KNOW IS COMING AS POSSIBLE.
THIS IS VERY URGENT SOUL IN MY
OPINION A LIFE OR DEATH
SITUATION.
AND I THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONTINUED SUPPORT AND URGE THAT
WE RESTORE INVESTMENTS TO THESE
PROGRAMS.
HELLO PERSONAL CLOSE ON BEHALF
OF CALIFORNIA PRODUCT
STEWARDSHIP CANCEL NATIONAL
SEARCH A COUNCIL -- AND STOP
PLACES ALWAYS ASSOCIATION NORTH
AMERICA HAD EXPRESSED OUR
DISAPPONTMENT THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET NOT FOR AN INCREASE.
OUR CYCLE FUNDING -- WE URGE THE
COMMITTEE TO LEASE ALLOCATE.
HUNDRED MILLION FOR FROM G. G.
R. F. I'M ALSO HERE ON BEHALF OF
LOS CITY OF LOS ANGELES AMERICA
CITY ON ANOTHER ISSUE TO EXPRESS
THAT WE ARE DISAPPOINTED SEE THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET.
DOES NOT INCLUDE FUNDING FOR CAL
FIRE URBAN AND COMMUNITY
FORESTRY PROGRAM AND URGED ME TO
PROVIDE. FIFTY MILLION
CALIFORNICUM THE FORESTRY FUNDS
ARE USEFUL FOR CITY OF LOS
ANGELES AND OTHER MUNICIPALITIES
AROUND THE STATE BECAUSE THEY
LOVE FOR EARLY TREE MAINTENANCE
INVENTORY PROGRAMS AND THE
DEVELOPMENT OF URBAN FORESTRY.
MAGIC PLANS THESE INVESTMENTS
ARE NECESSARY FOR CITIES TO
PROACTIVELY MANAGE THEIR URBAN
FORCED TO A STORE CARBON SAVE
ENERGY AND PROTECT RESIDENTS.
AS THE TEMPERATURE INCREASES FOR
THIS REASON WE ARE SUBCOMMITTEE
THANK YOU.
REBEKAH MARCUS REPRESENTING
CALIFORNIA CLIMATE IN
AGRICULTURE NETWORK AND THE
CARBON CYCLE INSTITUTE WE ARE
PLEASED BY THE GOVERNOR'S
PASSION FOR THE HEALTHY SOILS
PROGRAM AND SUPPORT THE TEN
MILLION DOLLAR INCREASE TO THE
PROGRAM AND THE MAY REVISION.
IN ADDITION WE ARE SUPPORTING A
COMPREHENSIVE HEALTHY SOILS
INITIATIVE ASK FOR FORTY MILLION
LIGHT ITEM FOR THE ALTERNATIVE
ANYWHERE MANAGEMENT PROGRAM AND
A HUNDRED MILLION FOR THE RECESS
ACT HOW RECYCLE ORGANIC
DIVERSION PROGRAM.
WE ALSO SUPPORT FORTY MILLION
FOR THE STATE WATER ENERGY
EFFICIENCY PROGRAM WHICH HAS
BEEN ZEROED OUT IN THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL THANK YOU.
JOHN KENNEDY WITH WORLD COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES OF CALIFORNIA
WE'RE HERE TO SUPPORT THE
CONTINUED FUNDING FOR HEALTHY
FORESTS AND WILDFIRE RISK
REDUCTION PROJECT -- AND WE'RE
ALSO HERE TO REITERATE OUR
SUPPORT FOR HUNDRED MILLION FOR
ORGANIC WASTE RECYCLING WITH SB
THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE WE'RE
LOOKING AT TWO HUNDRED TO THREE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS A YEAR
IN COMPLIANCE COSTS. TO MEET THE
AMBITIOUS ORGANIC RECYCLING
MANDATES SO THIS IS A GOOD STEP
FORWARD TO BUILD THE
INFRASTRUCTURE OUT THAT WE
DESPERATELY NEED THANK YOU.
MORNING MR CHAIR -- COUPLE
ISSUES -- COUPLE DIFFERENT
CLIENTS TODAY FIRST ON THE CLEAN
VEHICLE REBATE PROGRAM ON BEHALF
THE ALLIANCE OF AUTOMOBILE
MANUFACTURERS WE'D LIKE TO SEE
AN INCREASE IN THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL TO CRITICAL PROGRAM AND
MEETING OURS HAVE GOALS HERE IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
LIKE TO ECHO MISTER KENNEDY'S
COMMENTS WITH RESPECT TO A
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR --
ALLOCATION TO CAL RECYCLE FOR
THE WASTE DIVERSION PROGRAM FOR
WASTE MANAGEMENT.
AND THEN LAST -- FOR METHANE
REDUCTION AND THE AG DIESEL
ENGINE REPLACEMENT UPGRADE
PROGRAMS -- WE SUPPORT THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL FOR NINETY
MILLION DOLLARS ON BEHALF OF THE
MILK PRODUCERS COUNCIL -- IN
THAT PROGRAM AND ONE ASSOCIATE
OURSELVES ON THE METHANE PROGRAM
WITH COMMENTS THAT MR BROKEN
DOOR WAS ABOUT TO MAKE.
THANK YOU MICHAEL BOCA DOOR ON
BEHALF OF THE AG ENERGY
CONSUMERS ASSOCIATION WERE VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF THE GOVERNOR'S
INCREASING THE DERRY METHANE
REDUCTION PROGRAM.
I THINK IT NEEDS TO GO FURTHER
AND WE WANT TO WORK WITH THE
COMMITTEE.
I DO WANT TO ADDRESS THE
COMMENTS ABOUT -- THE FALSE
PROMISE OF THE DIGEST ARE
PROGRAMS THAT WERE MADE BY THE
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE TO ME
BECAUSE I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT
TO GET THE FACTS ON THE RECORD.
NOTHING COULD BE FURTHER FROM
THE TRUTH THIS IS THE NUMBER ONE
PROGRAM OF ALL THE CLINTON
INVESTMENT PROGRAMS IN TERMS OF
OVERALL.
GHG REDUCTION IT'S THE SECOND
MOST COST EFFECTIVE REDUCING A
TON OF METHANE FOR EVERY EIGHT
DOLLARS INVESTED.
BY THE STATE.
AND YOU CAN MAKE THE SIMPLE
ARGUMENT THAT THIS IS THE BEST
INVESTMENT THE STATE IS MAKING.
I ALSO WANT -- TO SUPPORT THE
COMMENTS FROM THE SCORTON.
THE INTERSECTION BETWEEN THIS
PROGRAM AND TRANSPORTATION AND
THE TRUCKS THAT ARE ENDING UP IN
MISS RACES DISTRICT THAT GO TO
MISS GARCIA'S DISTRICT AND THE
PORT.
THESE ARE THE VERY TRUCKS THE
DERRY DIE JUST A PROGRAM IS NOW
MAKING RENEWABLE NATURAL GAS
WHICH WILL GO INTO HEAVY DUTY
FREIGHT TO REPLACE DIESEL.
IN DOING SO WE'RE MAKING FIFTY
MILLION D. G. E. EQUIVALENT WHEN
ALL THESE PROJECTS GET
IMPLEMENTED.
THAT WILL LEAD TO A SUBSTANTIAL
REDUCTION OF KNOX AND SOUTH
COAST IN SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY WHEN
THAT ISUSED TO REPLACE DIESEL
TRUCKS.
SO IT HAS TREMENDOUS BENEFITS
ACROSS THE BOARD IT ALSO
BENEFITS WATER QUALITY IT WAS
SAID THEY DO NOT.
EVERY PROJECT THAT IS FUNDED BY
CDFA MUST LINE THE LAGOON ON THE
DAIRY SO WE'RE GETTING
SUBSTANTIAL WATER QUALITY
BENEFITS FROM THIS PROGRAM AS
WELL.
SO I JUST IF THERE ANY QUESTIONS
ABOUT THE BENEFITS WE SUGGEST
YOU READ THE REPORT DONE BY A R.
B. AND FINANCE IT'S VERY
THOROUGH IT SHOWS THAT THIS IS
THE BEST INVESTMENT THE STATE'S
MAKING THANK YOU.
THE MORNING CHAIRMAN BLOOM
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE PAUL
MAY SLOW THE CIVIC FOREST TRUST
BATTING CLEANUP -- ALTHOUGH THEY
WERE ALSO.
AGREE WITH MANY OF MY AND YOUR
COLLEAGUES EXPRESSED
DISAPPOINTMENT THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET WE'VE HAD THIS
CONVERSATION HERE BEFORE TALKING
ABOUT THE NEED TO INVEST IN
NATURAL RESOURCE.
PROGRAMS FURTHER ADAPTATION
BENEFITS AND THEY COMPLETELY
FAILED TO DO SO.
I WOULD SUGGEST THAT AS THE
ASSEMBLY LOOKS TO DEVELOP A
PROPOSAL OF THEIR OWN THE YOU'D
RATHER THAN STARTING FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION PROPOSAL WHICH SO
CLEARLY MISSES THE MARK ON
ISSUES THE YOU'VE MADE CLEAR ARE
IMPORTANT TO THIS COMMITTEE.
THE START WITH THE SENATE --
PROPOSAL THAT THEY'RE TALKING
ABOUT DOWNSTAIRS NEXT WHICH I
THINK IS A MUCH MORE BALANCED
PROPOSAL AND ADDRESSES SOME OF
THESE ISSUES THAT -- ARE GOING
TO BE REALLY IMPORTANT TO
PREPARING FOR THE UNAVOIDABLE
IMPACTS OF CLIMATE CHANGE THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU THIS CALL I HAVE ONE
QUICK QUESTION MAYBE FIDELIO.
IT'S HARD I IN IN IN IN LISTINGS
OF THE PUBLIC COMMENTS INTERMENT
DETERMINING.
THE EFFICACY OR THE METRICS AND
HOW TO JUDGE WHETHER WHICH
PROGRAMS ARE THE BEST OR THE OR
OR NOT WORKING A WORKING.
WOULD IT MAKES MORE SENSE FROM A
PROCESS STANDPOINT TO ACTUALLY
DO A TWO YEAR PLAN.
AND THEN -- PROVIDE SOME
STABILITY AND THEN ALLOW THE
LEGISLATURE TO DO OVERSIGHT AND
DETERMINE WHETHER THESE PROGRAMS
ARE INDEED WORKING DEPENDING ON
WHETHER THERE ARE CLEAR
TRANSPARENT METRICS.
AND WHETHER THE FUNDS ARE BEING --
I GET I GUESS I'M I'M NOT SURE
ON FOR THE TWO TWO YEAR PLAN
QUESTION.
OF OR OR OR JUST ON THE TWO
YEARS OF DOING IT THOUGH AND OUT
THERE BUT MULTIPLE YEARS SO
THERE IS SOME SOME STABILITY BUT
THEN WE ACTUALLY DO HOLD THE
PROGRAMS ACCOUNTABLE THAT IF
THEY ARE ACHIEVING THEIR GOALS.
THAT MAYBE WE DO NEED TO SHIFT
THE FUNDS THE MORE -- COST
EFFECTIVE -- ABOUT PROJECTS OR
PROGRAMS YEAH I MEAN I THINK THE
THE KIND OF CORE OFYOUR
QUESTION AROUND -- YOU KNOW
HOLDING PROGRAMS ACCOUNTABLE AND
MAKING SURE THAT WERE THERE WHEN
WE ALLOCATE THE FUNDS THAT WERE
REVIEWING IN OF THE PROGRAMS AND
TRYING TO TRACK KIND OF CLEAR
METRICS ON WHAT THOSE PROGRAMS
ARE ACHIEVING AND THEN -- TAKING
THAT INTO CONSIDERATION BEFORE
WE KIND OF ALLOCATE ADDITIONAL
FUNDS THAT TYPE OF PROCESS
ABSOLUTELY IS THE TYPE OF
PROCESS WITH THAT WE SHOULD BE
SOME REPORTS THAT NHà COME OUT
OF THE ADMINISTRATION HAS KIND
OF AN ANNUAL REPORT TO COME THAT.
COMES OUT THAT PROVIDE SOME
INFORMATION ON METRICS FOR SOME
OF THESE PROGRAMS BUT A LOT OF
CASES IT'S IT DOESN'T INCLUDE
ALL OF THE RELEVANT INFORMATION
I THINK THAT -- FOR POLICY
MAKERS THAT YOU WOULD LIKE TO
HAVE IN ORDER TO KIND OF BALANCE
A LOT OF THESE TRADE OFFS
ASSOCIATE WITH THE DIFFERENT
PROGRAMS INCLUDING GHGS BUT AS
AS WELL AS LOCAL AIR POLLUTION
REDUCTIONS AND OTHER THINGS AND
SO.
THEY'RE DOING WHAT YOU CAN -- TO
YOU PUSH THE ADMINISTRATION TO
MAKE SURE THAT WHEN THEY'RE
COMING FORWARD WITH BUT ALLOCATE
WITH ALLOCATIONS AND PROPOSALS
TO TRY AN OUTLINE WHAT THOSE
EXPECTED OUTCOMES ARE BEFORE YOU
ACTUALLY ALLOCATE.
ANY ADDITIONAL FUNDING AND CUT
KNOWING ABOUT WHAT YOU'VE
ACHIEVED SO FAR IS IS ABSOLUTELY
THE RIGHT PROCESS TO FLOW IN IT
IF THE CHAIRMAN TOLD ME I MEAN
IN IN TERMS OF RECENTLY PLACE
INVESTMENT UP UNTIL A LITTLE
DEMAND -- BRIEF THIS BUT IT LIKE
FOR EXAMPLE IN IN TERMS OF INTO
THE AGRICULTURE IF YOU'RE IF YOU
WERE CALLING FOR AGRICULTURE
CHEN TO MAKE INVESTMENTS BUT
YOU'RE ONLY DOING IT FROM YEAR
AFTER YEAR AND IT ZEROS OUT OR
GOES UP YOUR YOUR THEN NO ONE
CAN PLAN.
SO IN MY IN MY AT LEAST FROM MY
PERSPECTIVE IT SEEMS TO MAKE
MORE SENSE THAT WE PROVIDED TO
YEAR. THREE YEAR MULTI YEAR --
PLAN AND THEN IF AND THEN AS IT
GOES AS AG THEIR GOALS AND THEN
THE FUNDING GOES DOWN ON RIGHT
IF THERE'S BEEN SUCCESSFUL AND
THEN MAYBE MAKE INVESTMENTS AND
SOMETHING ELSE.
YEAH I MEAN I I THINK THERE'S
THERE'S DEFINITELY SOME BENEFITS
TO PROVIDING CERTAINTY AROUND
FUNDING OVER MORE THAN JUST ONE
YEAR THAT HELPS WITH PLANNING
FOR BUSINESSES AND THAT ARE
MAKING KIND OF MORE LONGER TERM
INVESTMENTS AND BUSINESS
DECISIONS.
THERE'S JUST THERE IS JUST THAT
THIS TRADE OFF ON YOU KNOW
LEGISLATURE'S PRIORITIES MIGHT
CHANGE A LITTLE BIT FROM ONE
YEAR TO THE NEXT AND SO YOU'RE
KEEPING THAT FLEXIBILITY IS IS
ALSO IMPORTANT SOCIALLY BALLOTS
IN THOSE TWO FACTORS.
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR THE
PRESENTATIONS -- SO I AM GOING
TO BE CALLING AN AUDIBLE HERE --
IF YOU WILL ON THE ORDER OF THE
AGENDA WE HAVE MISTER OF
BLUMENFELD HERE -- AND HE HAS
SOME TIME CONSTRAINTS ARE GONNA
SKIP FORWARD TO ISSUE FOR AND
ADDRESS THE ONE AND ISSUE -- FOR
CALLIE PA.
WELCOME -- IT'S GOOD THANK YOU
HERE -- I WAS JUST REMINDED THAT
YOU ARE ONE OF THE FEW PEOPLE
WHO'S LIKE THE AND TIRED HE OF
THE A PACIFIC COAST TRAIL ALL
TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED MILES OF
TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED MILES SO --
YOU ARE STILL IN ONE PIECE.
ASSEMBLY ERECT ONE PIECE YEAH
WHEN DID YOU COMPLETE THAT -- I
STARTED -- MAY NINTH TWENTY
SIXTEEN AND I FINISH SEPTEMBER
FIFTEENTH.
SO LIKE FOR FOUR MONTHS FEW DAYS
[inaudible]
YEAH.
GOOD TO SEE YOU HERE.
GERMAN.
SO THIS IS THIS IS A VERY --
TARGETED REQUEST IN THE BUDGET --
I CAN GO INTO AS MUCH DETAIL AS
YOU WANT BUT REALLY WANTED TO
GIVE YOU A FLAVOR OF IT -- IF
YOU THINK ABOUT -- THE
CALIFORNIA I'M ENVIRONMENTAL
PROTECTION AGENCY WE HAVE BOARDS
DEPARTMENTS AND OFFICES THAT ARE
AND US AND REALLY MY GOAL IS TO
MAKE US ONE CAL EPA TO REALLY
COORDINATE.
THE FUNCTIONS TO MAKE SURE THAT
WOULD NOT JUST WORKING IN A
STOVE PIPES THAT WORK ACROSS
THEM AS WE HAD A LITTLE BIT IN
THE G. J. R. F. CONTEXT.
YOU KNOW THE ENVIRONMENT DOES
NOT -- NO ANY BOUNDARIES AND AND
REALLY NOT SURE DOT AGENCY SAYS.
THE POSITIONS -- ARE ONES THAT I
KIND OF NEEDED TO BRING US
TOGETHER TO COORDINATE -- AND TO
MAKE SURE THAT WAS SERVING THE
PUBLIC EFFECTIVELY SO -- I CAN
GO THROUGH IN IN FAIRLY QUICK
ORDER -- THE POSITIONS ARE IN IN
THE AREAS OF STRATEGIC PLANNING.
LEAN SIX SIGMA TRAINING INTERNAL
COMMUNICATIONS CONTRACT AND
LABOR LAW AND ENFORCEMENT
COORDINATION TO THOSE ALL OF
THEM AND I'M I'M HAPPY TO GO
INTO. TO I'LL I'LL KIND OF JUST
BRIEFLY.
TALK ABOUT EACH ONE OF THEM SAID
THIS YOU SEE THAT.
I THINK -- RATHER THAN -- GOING
THROUGH A AT ALL A KIND OF A
LINE ITEM -- DISCUSSION IF YOU
COULD FOCUS YOUR COMMENTS ON THE
STAFF COMMENT AND THAT A
QUESTION OF HOW YOU WILL --
CLEARLY ARTICULATE THE
OBJECTIVES -- FOR OF OUR FOR
THESE POSITIONS AND AND AND HOW
YOU'LL MEASURE SUCCESS I THINK
THAT WOULD EXTREMELY HELPFUL
CHAVEZ STARTING WITH GIGI
PLANNING -- THE WAY THAT
STRATEGIC PLANNING IS DONE IN
THE DIFFERENT AGENCIES SOME
LASTED IN TWO THOUSAND AND FIVE
OTHERS DONE OR RECENTLY REALLY
UNDERSTANDING WHAT ARE OUR
OBJECTIVES HOW DO WE EXPECT TO
BE HELD ACCOUNTABLE BY YOU IN
THE PUBLIC -- THAT WITHOUT
HAVING A CLEAR STRATEGIC
PLANNING FRAME WE DON'T HAVE A
WAY OF DOING GOOD PERFORMANCE
MANAGEMENT ONE OF THE HOLDING
OUT STOP ACCOUNTABLE FULL SAYS
CITY PLANNING IS IS THE MOST
CRITICAL -- AND YOU KNOW THE THE
ODDS ARE ABOUT COUNT ABILITY
WILL REALLY BE IN THE AREA OF
KEY PERFORMANCE INDICATORS HOW
DO WE DEVELOP INDICATE IS.
THAT WE CAN HAVE ON A WEBSITE
WHETHER IT'S YOU KNOW WHAT YOU
JUST TALKING ABOUT WITH THE G.
G. R. F. OR CRITERIA POLLUTANTS
ALL PESTICIDES OR WHATEVER THE
ISSUE IS.
WE NEED CLEAR METRICS -- IN
ORDER TO GET THAT -- WE WANT TO
IMPLEMENT A PROGRAM OF LEAN SIX
SIGMA WHICH IS A CONTINUOUS
IMPROVEMENT -- TOLD TO HELP STOP
ACROSS THE AGENCY REALLY USE
THAT TOOL.
AS AN EXAMPLE HOW DO WE GET RID
OF MANY OF THE PROCESS STEPS
THAT WE HAVE AN UPCOMING.
THAT YOU KNOW DR YOU KNOW SOME
OF THE REGULATED COMMUNITY CRAZY
BECAUSE I KNOW ADDING
ENVIRONMENTAL VALUES -- BUT
THEY'RE IN THE PROCESS I HAD A
HAD A WEEK MAKE THAT -- WHAT
MORE EFFECTIVELY AND THEN?
WE HAVE SIX THOUSAND EMPLOYEES
BUT WE DON'T HAVE A CENTRAL WAY
OF TRAINING THEM -- IF THERE ARE
WHICH THEY ARE MOST VALUABLE
ASSET REALLY THINKING ABOUT THE
THE SKILLS GAP WHAT DO WE NEED
TO GET.
THE EMPLOYEES TO THE SKILLS WE
NEED IN ORDER TO TO IMPLEMENT
WHAT WE'RE DOING -- BY EXAMPLE
YOU KNOW THE FROM ETHICS
TRAINING TO SEXUAL HARASSMENT --
TO TO COMPETENCY ASSESSMENTS AND
THEN WITH LEGAL SUPPORT THAT
KIND OF ROUNDS OUT WHAT ONE OF
OUR NEEDS WHICH IS.
WE HAVE A VERY LARGE CONTRACTS --
THAT GO THROUGH THE AGENCYBUT I
DON'T FEEL LIKE I HAVE THE
CONTROLS OVER THOSE CONTRACTS TO
MAKE SURE THAT WHEN I COME
BEFORE YOU.
I CANNOT SO WAS SHORT THE ABOUT
THE CLARITY OF THOSE CONTRACTS
ARE HAVING A LABOR CONTRACTS
ATTORNEY FOR ME IT IS IS
CRITICAL.
AND THEN TO ROUND IT OUT -- THE
LAST TWO POSITIONS WANTED TO DO
INTERNAL COMMUNICATIONS AND
EXTERNAL WHAT IS IT YOU KNOW
PART OF PART OF WHAT I'VE
LEARNED ABOUT GOVERNMENT AND IN
MY PROBABLY TWENTY IS DOING
GOVERNMENT.
IS THAT WE OFTEN DON'T DO A GOOD
JOB OF EXPLAINING TO OUR PUBLIC
WHAT IT IS THAT WE DO FOR THEM --
AND SAYS EXPLAINING THE BENEFITS
THE GOVERNMENT PROVIDES -- TO
OUR CONSTITUENTS AND TO A STOP
TO SOMETHING I I REALLY WANT TO
FOCUS ON AND THEN THE FINAL.
POSITION RELATES TO ENFORCEMENT
COORDINATION HAVING CLEA --
CLEAR TARGETS OF WHAT WE'RE
DOING AROUND ENFORCEMENT HOW
WE'RE DOING IT AND MAKING SURE
THAT -- ALL THE DIFFERENT
PUBLICS NOW ABOUT IT REALLY THEY
GO TO CHAD TO THE HEART OF YOUR
QUESTION WHICH IS.
I WANT TO BE ABLE TO GIVE YOU
THE ON SAYS.
TO WHAT ARE THE METRICS OF OUR
SUCCESS THESE POSITIONS WILL
ALLOW US TO DO THAT SO THEY ARE
IN FACT INSTRUMENTAL TO
ANSWERING THAT BASIC QUESTION.
THANK YOU 	C OF ONE OF THE
ADVANTAGES OF HAVING A A NEW --
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR COME INTO --
POSITION IS HAVING A FRESH SET
OF EYES AND ON ON A DEPARTMENT
AND IT APPEARS SO YOU'RE.
TAKING THAT QUITE SERIOUSLY AND
MAKING SOME CHANGES THAT ALL --
HELP FACILITATE SOME -- SOME A
POSITIVE CHANGE IN THE IN THE
DEPARTMENT THAT'S ALREADY
FUNCTIONING HIGHLY SO I THINK
THAT'S GREAT -- TO THE LA --
HAVE QUESTIONS AND MS REYES.
SHAMA WITH LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE AND WE THINK THE BROAD
GOALS DESCRIBED IN THIS PROPOSAL
HAVE MERIT HOWEVER THE PROPOSAL
DIDN'T INCLUDE A DETAILED
DESCRIPTION OF THE PROBLEM IS
BEING ADDRESSED AND AND
ACTIVITIES THAT WOULD BE
UNDERTAKEN IN THE MEASURABLE
OUTCOMES THAT CALLIE PO'S CAN BE
USED.
TO DETERMINE WHETHER THEY
ACHIEVED SUCCESS WITH THEIR NEW --
PROPOSAL SO.
WE RECOMMENDED THAT THE
SECRETARY TESTIFYING ADDRESS
THOSE ISSUES AND I THINK THAT HE
HAS ADDRESSED SOME OF THOSE
ISSUES -- TODAY IN HIS TESTIMONY --
SO WE WOULD JUST NOTE THAT
YESTERDAY AND SENATE SUB TO THEY
ADOPTED SUPPLEMENTAL REPORT
LANGUAGE TO REQUIRE CALLIE PA TO
PROVIDE DETAILS ON EXISTING
SHORTCOMINGS.
IN ADDRESS ACTIVITIES IT WOULD
BE UNDERTAKEN AND MEASURABLE
OUTCOMES THAT WOULD BE
ESTABLISHED FOR EACH OF THE
COMPONENTS OF THE PROPOSAL.
THANK YOU OF A FINANCE NO REPORT
TO A ANY QUESTIONS FROM THE DICE
IS THERE ANY -- PUBLIC COMMENT
[inaudible]
SEEING NONE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION APPRECIATE IT WILL
HOLD THIS ITEM OPEN AS
RECOMMENDED.
AND THE NOW WILL JUMP BACK -- TO
ISSUE NUMBER TWO AND THREE WILL
TAKE UP PUBLIC COMMENT -- ON THE
CPC -- TWO ISSUES AFTER WE
COMPLETED ISSUE NUMBER.
THREE BOTH OF THESE HAVE
RECOMMENDATIONS TO HOLD OPEN
WILL BEGIN WITH.
ISSUE TO THE WILDFIRE CLIMATE
CHANGE [inaudible]
MATTER.
ALL NOTE THAT IT'S ALREADY --
ALMOST TEN FORTY FIVE AND WERE --
ONLY THREE ISSUES -- INTO THE
AGENDA -- AS PER SE.
GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN AND
ASSEMBLYMEMBERS MY NAME IS
BERNARD AS A VETO.
I AM THE ADMINISTRATIVE SERVICES
DIRECTOR FOR THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION.
TODAY I HAVE WITH ME THE CPC'S
REPRESENTATIVES TO ADDRESS
ISSUES TWO AND THREE THE ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
DID YOU HAVE A AT YOU LOOK LIKE
YOU'RE READY TO ADD SOME
COMMENTS -- HIGH AA AND LEASE
ABOLISHING CAM THE DEPUTY
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR SIXTEEN
THE FOR SOME FOLLOW SAID THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION.
AND THE WORLD PORTION OF THE
REQUEST HERE AT THAT.
IS BEING ASKED TO SAFETY IS --
TO CONTRACTS THE ONE IS FOR
THIRTEEN MILLION TO DO POLICY
WORK RELATED TO WILD FIRES AND
THEN AT TWENTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLAR REIMBURSEMENTS AUTHORITY.
L. -- FOR DOING INSPECTIONS OF
UTILITY INFRASTRUCTURE -- TO
ENSURE COMPLIANCE WITH
COMMISSIONS GENERAL ORDERS AND
THE L. WILD FIRE MITIGATION
PLANS ARE BEING ADOPTED AND ALSO
SOME STAFF AUGMENTATION TO
SUPPORT SO PROACTIVE POWER SHUT
OFF FOR THE D. IMAGES ATION.
L. PROGRAMS OF UTILITIES.
THANK YOU HELLO.
SO -- IN CONCEPT WE THINK THESE
ACTIVITIES HAVE A LOT OF MERIT --
THEY'RE MEANT TO ADDRESS -- THE
VERY IMPORTANT ISSUE OF
MITIGATING WILDFIRE RISK FROM
UTILITIES AND EMPLOYMENT AND
WHILE FOR MITIGATION PLANS WE
JUST WANT TO NOTE.
THESE ARE ARE REALLY KIND OF NEW
ACTIVITIES OR IN KIND OF NEW
TERRITORY HERE AND THERE'S NO.
CLEAR IMPLEMENTATION PLAN FOR
FOR EXAMPLE THE ENFORCEMENT
RESOURCES ON KIND OF WHEN THOSE
WILL ACTUALLY OUT BE OUT ON THE
GROUNDS -- AND IT'S ALSO UNCLEAR
KIND OF HOW THE PC WILL USE
THEIR EXPERIENCE FOR THIS ONE
TIME CONTRACT FOR LONGER TORN
TERM ENFORCEMENT PLANNING AND
ACTIVITIES.
SO WE RECOMMEND THE LEGISLATURE
ADOPTS A SUPPLEMENTAL REPORT
LANGUAGE REQUIRING THE PC TO
REPORT IN APRIL OF NEXT YEAR.
ON HOW MUCH OF THE ENFORCEMENT
MONEY HAS BEEN SPENT SWAT
OUTCOMES THEY'VE ACHIEVED AND
IMPORTANTLY HOW THE EXPERIENCES
INFORMED OF LONG TERM --
DEVELOPMENT OF ONGOING
MEDICATION PLAN ENFORCEMENT AND
IN OUR VIEW THIS WOULD HELP --
ENHANCE LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT OF
THE MITIGATION PLAN
IMPLEMENTATION AND INFORM ON
GOING FUTURE ACTIVITIES RELATED
TO BE CAN UP THE STING THESE
TYPES OF ACTIVITIES.
THANK YOU FINANCE.
AMANDA MARTIN DEPARTMENT FINANCE
IN INTEREST TIME KEEP IT BRIEF
BUT TO RESPOND TO THE LA THOSE
COMMENTS ABOUT HOW THIS ONE FORM --
FUTURE ACTIVITIES WE WOULD NOTE
THAT THE REQUESTS ARE ONE TIME
IN NATURE OVER THREE YEARS IN
THE IDEA BEING EXACTLY TO TAKE
THE RESULTS OF THESE ACTIVITIES
TO INFORM WHETHER -- THESE KIND
OF BOOTS ON THE GROUND
INSPECTIONS TO CONTINUE WITH THE
P. C. WITH ANOTHER ENTITY -- GET
THAT KIND OF DATA -- NEEDED TO
IMPROVE WILDLIFE MITIGATION PLAN
SO THAT ONE TIME IS VERY
INTENTIONAL.
THANK YOU -- NOT SURE WHO WANTS
TO ANSWER THIS QUESTION BUT HAS
THE ADMINISTRATION CONSIDERED
CREATING A SEPARATE DEPARTMENT --
TO OR NEEDED TO FOCUS ON
ADDRESSING THE WILDFIRE ISSUE IT
SAYS SOMETHING IS GONNA BE WITH
US.
FOR QUITE SOME TIME -- THE
PREVENTION INSPECTION WORK THAT
THE CPC IS PROPOSING TO CONTRACT
OUT MIGHT -- MIGHT THAT NOT BE --
HANDLE LONG TERM BY A STAFF.
THERE IS NO PROPOSAL IN THE
CURRENT MAY REVISION BUT AS A
NOTED.
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT WILL HELP
HAVE A DATE I KNOW THERE ARE
CONVERSATIONS.
ALL AROUND WILDFIRE HAPPENING
WITH BOTH HOUSES AND THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE MINISTRATION
SO -- THERE IS NOT A CURRENT
PROPOSAL THE TABLE FOR THAT.
OKAY I UNDERSTAND THAT THERE'S
NO CARE PROPOSAL I'M LOOKING FOR
FEEDBACK -- MEN AND
UNDERSTANDING OF YOU KNOW KIND
OF WHERE THE ADMINISTRATION'S --
OR THE DEPARTMENTS THINKING AS
ON THIS NOW.
CHAIRMAN AND IF I MAY ANSWER
YOUR QUESTION SLIGHTLY FURTHER.
OF THE GREAT THE DIRECTORS OF
THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION THE OFFICE OF
EMERGENCY SERVICES AND CAL FIRE
ARE ACTIVELY MEANING.
THEY ARE -- TRYING TO DETERMINE
RECOMMENDATIONS -- AS DIRECTED
BY THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE AND
THOSE PROPOSALS WILL COME FROM
THOSE MEETINGS AS
RECOMMENDATIONS TO FINANCE AND
TO OTHERS IN THE FUTURE SO WE
ARE ACTIVELY ENGAGED.
IN THOSE DISCUSSIONS AND TO MAKE
THIS HIS RECOMMENDATIONS --
WOULD I BE CORRECT IN ASSUMING
THAT THAT'S NOT GOING TO HAPPEN --
THOSE RECOMMENDATIONS ARE NOT
GOING TO HAPPEN BEFORE WE CLOSE
OUT THE BUDGET TO IN THE CYCLE
THAT IS CORRECT OKAY
[inaudible]
ADDRESS.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
AS A MEMBER OF THE UTILITIES AND
ENERGY COMMITTEE AND ALSO THE
WILDFIRE CONFERENCE COMMITTEE ON
SB NINETY NINE A ONE I RECOGNIZE
HOW IMPORTANT IS.
TO DEAL WITH THE ISSUES RELATED
TO WILD FIRES AND TO DO IT AS
SOON AS POSSIBLE.
I I AM INTERESTED HOWEVER IN
THIS WILDFIRE SWAT TEAM AND THE
THE THE THE FUNDING HAS BEEN
PROVIDED. TO ENFORCE ARE THEY
GOING TO ENFORCE WILDFIRE --
MITIGATION PLANS.
IS A PART OF YOUR DOING.
AND THEN THEIR SECOND PART IS
ARE THEY GOING TO BE MONITORING
EVERYTHING FROM THE VEGETATION
MANAGEMENT TO DEGENERATE DE
ENERGIZED ENERGIZE ATION.
OF THE ERA.
THIS.
PURPOSE OF THIS REQUEST IS TO
FILL THE CURRENT GAP AROUND
INSPECTIONS SO THE PC DOES NOT
HAVE ANY INSPECTION THE STAFF TO
GO OUT AND ACTUALLY INSPECT
UTILITY INFRASTRUCTURE AT SCALE
OUR PROGRAM WAS SET UP AS AN
AUDITING UNITS. TO REVIEW ALL
RECORDS OF UTILITIES AND MAYBE
DO SOME SPOT CHECKS BUT WE DO
NOT HAVE ANY CAPABILITY TO GO
OUT.
AND INSPECT UTILITY
INFRASTRUCTURE SO THIS SPECIFIC
CONTRACTORS IN FOOD BOOTS ON THE
GROUND TO A HALT.
AND THEN CITY THAT CAN SCALE UP
FAST THAT CAN GO OUT THERE AND
ACTUALLY -- DO VERIFICATIONS OF
WHAT IS HAPPENING IN THE FIELDS
WE GET THAT FEEDBACK AS TO THE
REALITY ON THE GROUND VERSUS
WHAT WE'RE SEEING CAN UP IN OUR
PROCEEDINGS AND ON RECORDS --
EIGHTY I WOULD SAY THAT THE
THERE ARE YOU KNOW PRIMARY FOCUS
WOULD BE ON AN ACTUAL
INFRASTRUCTURE IN VEGETATION
MANAGEMENT THE THINGS THAT YOU
CAN EASILY VISUALLY INSPECT.
ALL MY AS THIS PROGRAM DEVELOPS
AND RAMPS UP THEY MAY START
LOOKING EL ON HOPING WITH THE
ASSISTANCE ALL.
UNITS AROUND SOME OTHER PROGRAMS
LIKE THE ENERGY IS THE USUAL
HYPOTHETICALLY SPEAKING YOU
COULD HAVE SOME AUGMENTATION OF
STAFF FOR THE P. YOU SEE TO DO
SOME VERIFICATIONS.
IN THE FIELD ALTHOUGH IT
CONDITIONS UTILITIES REPORTING
WHEN THEY DID MAKING DECISIONS
TO JENNER J. SOMETHING THE SAME
AS HIGH THREAT CONDITIONS THIS
HIGH WINDS YOU KNOW IF WE HAD
THE KIND OF STOPPING TO SEND OUT
AN INSPECTOR. TO THAT LOCATION
TO VERIFY THAT IT ACTUALLY IS A
HIGH THREAT CONDITION THAT COULD
BE USEFUL WITH THE HOT STOP WITH
THAT RIGHT NOW BUT I WOULD SEE
THAT AS THE MORE ADVANCED
FUNCTION RIGHT NOW WE AT I WOULD
SAY THE FIRST FOCUS FOR THEM
WOULD BE.
ON CONSTRUCTION DESIGN
MAINTENANCE STANDARDS AROUND
INFRASTRUCTURE IN VEGETATION
MANAGEMENT.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER.
THANK YOU -- COUPLE OF FURTHER
COMMENTS -- A FIRST OF ALL --
THE NOMENCLATURE OF SWAT TEAM.
DOESN'T QUITE SEEM TO BE
APPROPRIATE.
IN THIS -- IN IN THE SETTING COM
I UNDERSTAND THAT -- THAT THIS
IS INTENDED TO BE SOMETHING THAT --
THAT -- IS AN OF AN
INVESTIGATORY -- AND ENFORCEMENT
NATURE BUT TRY TO COME UP WITH
SOMETHING.
THAT'S A LITTLE.
LESS -- CONNECTED TO THE A VERY
IMPORTANT -- SWAT TEAM WORKS
IT'S DONE BY. ONE FOUR SPENT
STEP UP FOR ME THERE'S A
DISCONNECT THERE -- BUT OF THE
OTHER COMMENT -- IT'S THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION TO HAS MADE TO
NUMEROUS PROPOSALS OF CROSS SO
WIDE NUMBER OF DEPARTMENTS TO
ADDRESS THE STATE'S WILDFIRE
ISSUE AND THERE'S CONCERN ABOUT --
OTHER THINKS BEEN EXPRESSED
ABOUT COORDINATION OF THESE
EFFORTS TO COST THE STATE'S ROLE
AND WHEN IT'S APPROPRIATE TO
CONTRACT.
OUT AND WHEN IT'S BEST TO
DEVELOP.
OUR IN HOUSE STATE EXPERTISE AND
WE'RE GONNA HOLD THIS ITEM OPEN
THE SUBCOMMITTEE WILL CONTINUE
TO EVALUATE.
TO OF ALL ALL OF THESE PROPOSALS.
A AND WITH THAT -- LET'S MOVE ON
TO ISSUE THREE AND THEN AGAIN
WILL TAKE PUBLIC COMMENT ON
ISSUES TWO AND THREE AFTER WE'RE
DONE WITH THIS -- ONE LIFELINE
ASSISTANCE
.
GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN LIMóN
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
MY NAME IS JONATHAN MARKETS
NEVER PROGRAM MANAGER AT THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION.
TODAY WE'RE SEEKING FOUR HUNDRED
AND FIFTY FOUR MILLION FIFTEEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS AN
APPROPRIATION FOR THE LIFELINE
PROGRAM FOR FISCAL YEAR. TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN THIS IS AN
INCREASE OF SIXTEEN POINT 4% ON
THE APPROPRIATION APPROVED A
TWENTY EIGHTEEN BUDGET OCT.
IN COMPARING THE MAYBE VISION TO
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED JANUARY
BUDGET.
THE LOCAL ASSISTANCE INCREASES
BY EIGHTY SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS.
BECAUSE OF GROWTH AND PROGRAM
PARTICIPATION AND THE ADDITION
OF PILOTS.
STATE OPERATIONS ESTIMATE
INCREASES BY FOUR POINT NINE
MILLION DOLLARS IN THIS IS
DRIVEN LARGELY BY OUT REACH
AMERICAN ELEMENTS OF THE PILOTS
THAT WILL BE OCCURRING.
IN FISCAL YEAR.
TWENTY NINETEEN AVAILABLE TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE.
THANK YOU ALEJO.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR WE DON'T
HAVE ANY SPECIFIC CONCERNS WITH
THIS PARTICULAR PROPOSAL -- I
DID JUST WANT TO FLAG JUST VERY
BRIEFLY -- IT RELATES TO REPORT
THAT -- WE ISSUED LAST MONTH
WHICH WAS REQUIRED AND AN SRO
WHICH REQUIRED OUR OFFICE TO
LOOK AT A COUPLE DIFFERENT
ASPECTSOF THE LIFELINE PROGRAM
ONE THEIR BUDGETING AND THE
METHODS FOR ESTIMATING FUTURE
PROGRAM COSTS -- AND ON THAT
ISSUE WE FOUND THAT YOU KNOW IN
THE PAST THERE BEEN A LOT OF
CHALLENGES AND ESTIMATING THE
COST FOR THIS PROGRAM LARGELY
RELATED TO A SIGNIFICANT.
CHANGE IN THE PROGRAM WHERE THEY
INCLUDED WIRELESS TO THE PROGRAM
AND SO THAT ADDED A LOT OF
UNCERTAINTY RESTAURANTS --
APPEAR TO HAVE BEEN IMPROVING
AND QUITE A BIT IN RECENT.
YEARS -- AND SO WE DON'T HAVE
ANY CONCERNS WITH THE THE
ESTIMATES THAT ARE IN THIS
PARTICULAR PROPOSAL BUT IT'S
JUST ONE OF FLAG OUT FOR YOU
THERE IS SOME BUDGET BILL
LANGUAGE IN THERE THAT WOULD
GIVE THEM SOME FLEXIBILITY -- IF
COSTS GO HIGHER THAN WHAT
THEY'RE ESTIMATING HERE -- WE
ALSO IN IN THAT REPORT KIND OF
THE INCLUDED AN OPTION THE
LEGISLATURE MIGHT WANNA CONSIDER
ADDING SOME SORT CAP TO THAT
THAT FLEXIBILITY BUT WE DO THINK
SOME FLEXIBILITY AS IS
REASONABLE.
THE SECOND ISSUE WAS RELATED TO
THE ENROLLMENT IN THE PROGRAM --
SOME CONCERNS I THINK AROUND
KIND OF THE ENROLLMENT RATE JUST
FOR CONTEXT THERE'S ABOUT ABOUT
FORTY THE ESTIMATE IS ABOUT 40%
OF THE ELIGIBLE HOUSEHOLDS ARE
ACTUALLY ENROLLED IN THE PROGRAM.
AND SO WE LOOKED AT SOME OF THE
POTENTIAL EXPLANATIONS FOR WHY
THAT MIGHT BE THE CASE AND THE
OTHERS A FEW DIFFERENT
CATEGORIES ONE IS JUST GENERAL
AWARENESS OF THE PROGRAM SO --
HOUSEHOLD MIGHT NOT BE BE AWARE
THAT THE PROGRAM EVEN EXISTS --
TO EVEN IF THEY ARE AWARE IT
MIGHT BE JUST A MATTER OF AND
THEY PREFER ANOTHER PLANNER
CARRIER TO THE ONES THAT ARE
BEING OFFERED HERE AND THEN
THIRD -- IT COULD JUST BE IS
SIMPLY A MATTER OF IT IT'S
DIFFICULT TO AND OR RENEW IN THE
PROCESS AND SO -- WELL ALL THOSE
IT COULD BE POTENTIALLY
CONTRIBUTING FACTORS TO THE
CURRENT ENROLLMENT RATE -- IT'S
NOT QUITE CLEAR WHICH ONES OF
THOSE ARE KIND OF THE MAJOR
FACTORS CONTRIBUTING TO IT AND
SO OUR RECOMMENDATION WAS TO
DIRECT THE PC.
TO CONDUCT AN EVALUATION OF THAT
IT LIKELY IN THE FORM OF THE
SURVEY OF ELIGIBLE HOUSEHOLDS TO
GET A SENSE OF WHAT WHICH ONE OF
THESE FACTORS IS REALLY KIND OF
THE PRIMARY.
DRIVER -- FOR THE CURRENT
ENROLLMENT RATES AND SO -- AS IT
RELATES TO THIS PARTICULAR
PROPOSAL IT DOES INCLUDE THE
ESTIMATED FUNDING FOR A PILOT --
THAT THE COMMISSION RECENTLY
ADOPTED WHICH TRIES TO ADDRESS
SOME OF THESE ISSUES ARE
BRINGING ON YOUR PROVIDING
SUBSIDIES TO A NEW KERRIER THAT
MIGHT BE -- KIND OF BETTER KNOWN
AMONG SOME OF THE POPULATIONS
AND INCLUDING SOME ADDITIONAL
NEW KIND OF ELIGIBILITY
ENROLLMENT PROCESS HE'S FOR
CERTAIN -- HOUSEHOLDS AND SO
THERE IS SOME MONEY IN THAT FOR
THIS -- AND THE PC HAS AN
ONGOING PROCEEDING WHERE THERE
ARE VALUE AND SOME OTHER
POTENTIAL PILOT PROGRAMS TO TRY
TO INCREASE ENROLLMENT IN THE
PROGRAM.
YES HOW ARE YOU GOOD MORNING
MISTER HARRISON.
OF FOUR HUNDRED AND SOME ODD
MILLION [inaudible]
OPERATING FROM.
FEES ON OTHER USERS CORRECT.
THIS IS NOT A GENERAL FUND THIS
IS A FEE THAT IS.
TAKEN FROM.
OTHER.
PEOPLE ON A RECURRING BASIS
CORRECT ANOTHER TELEPHONE THOSE
YES YEAH THAT'S RIGHT -- IS A
100% OF THIS FOUR HUNDRED AND
SOME ODD MILLION.
GOING TO THE SUBSIDIES NECESSARY
TO GET THESE INDIVIDUALS THE RIP
RELIEF.
OR ARE THEY ARE THIRD PARTY.
PARTICIPANTS IN THIS THAT ARE
GETTING SOME OF THIS MONEY -- SO
THERE'S A PORTION OF THE MONEY
THAT GOES TO A THIRD PARTY
ADMINISTRATOR THAT HELPS
ADMINISTER THE ELIGIBILITY AND
ENROLLMENT PROCESS -- THE WAY
THE PROGRAM IS STRUCTURED IS
THAT THE SUBSIDIES ARE PROVIDED
TO THE CARRIERS THEMSELVES.
WHICH THEN -- KIND OF DETERMINE
THE STRUCTURE OF THE SERVICE
THAT THEY OFFER BUT THERE'S SORT
OF A FLAT SUBSIDY THAT GOES TO
THE CARRIERS -- THAT DEPENDS ON
THE NUMBER OF THE AND OUT HOW
HELD OUT A ROLE OR HUNDRED AND
SOME ODD MILLION HOW MUCH OF
THAT.
ACTUALLY GETS TO THE PEOPLE WHO
NEED IT. THREE HUNDRED AND FIFTY
A HUNDRED AND FIFTY ALMOST ALL
OF IT BUT I MEAN I THINK IT'S
IT'S STILL BE YOU SEE NOW.
SO DOES STATE OPERATIONS ARE AT
TWENTY SEVEN MILLION AND THAT
INCLUDES TO THE THIRD PARTY
ADMINISTRATOR -- AND THEN I
THINK IT'S A LITTLE BIT MORE
DIFFICULT TO ANSWER ON THE KIND
OF THE SUBSIDIES THAT ARE
PROVIDED TO THE CARRIERS TO THEN
PROVIDE -- THE SUBSIDIZED PHONE
SERVICE BECAUSE THE SUBSIDY GOES
TO THE KERRIER -- AND THEN THAT
THEY KIND OF DETERMINE YOU KNOW
WHAT WHAT EXACTLY THE SERVICES
THAT'S OFFERED TO THE TO THE
CUSTOMERS OF THE CUSTOMERS
GETTING.
SOME BENEFIT BUT IT'S DIFFICULT
TO KIND OF QUANTIFY THE THE
EXACT DOLLAR AMOUNT OF THAT
OKAY [inaudible]
ANY OTHER.
JUST TO CLARIFY THAT WE DO
REVIEW AND APPROVE THE PLANS.
AND WE MAKE SURE THAT THE PLANS.
ARE -- DISCOUNTS OFF RETAIL
PLANS ARE WIDELY AVAILABLE IN
THE MARKETPLACE.
SO WE DO BELIEVE THAT THE
MAJORITY OF THE SUBSIDIES FORM
DIRECTLY TO THE CONSUMERS AND OF
THE FOUR HUNDRED FIFTY FOUR
MILLION DOLLARS FOUR HUNDRED AND
TWENTY SIX MILLION DOLLARS ARE
FOR SUBSIDY PAYMENTS TO
CONSUMERS.
AS THE HELLO POINTS OUT THEY DO
GO.
THE KEIRSEY COMPENSATION AFTER
THEY OFFER THE DISCOUNTED
SERVICE TO CONSUMERS AND IS THAT
SOUGHT COMPENSATION.
CONNECTED TO THE ENROLLMENT YES
THAT THIS IS DIRECTLY BASED UPON
THE ROMAN YOU OUT OF THE FOUR
HUNDRED AND SOME ODD.
THAT MONEY IS GOING TO ENROLLEES
AND ROBERTS THAT'S CORRECT YES
THANK YOU -- I THINK MS REVERSE
YOUR FIRST IN THIS RACE.
I AM VERY CONCERNED THAT THIS
PROGRAM HAS VERY LOW IN MORE
THAN ROLL MAN YOU KNOW 40%.
OF YOU KNOW I REPRESENT A
COMMUNITY THAT WOULD BENEFIT
FROM THE SERVICE THAT REALLY
NEEDS IT.
AND PROBABLY THERE'S NO OUT
REACH THEIR TWIN ROLE ANYBODY IN
THIS PROGRAM -- YOU KNOW IT'S AN
IMPORTANT PROGRAM AND I REALLY
BELIEVE IN THAT -- BUT YOU KNOW
DO YOU HAVE AN ENROLLMENT GOAL
AND WHAT ARE YOU DOING THIS YEAR
TO GET THEIR SURE SO THERE'S
SEVERAL ACTIONS THAT WE'RE
UNDERTAKING ENROLLMENT OCCURS
PRIMARILY IN TWO WAYS. FOR
WIRELINE CUSTOMERS IT OCCURS
WHEN THEY CONTACT KERRY TO
ESTABLISH SERVICE IN THE KERRY
INFORMS THEM OF LIFELINE.
AND FOR WIRELESS CUSTOMERS
ENROLLMENT AS A MAN FOR HER
REFERENCE TO WHAT ARE CALLED
STREET TEAMS THERE THE POP UP
TENTS THAT YOU MAY SEE.
IN YOUR AREA AND THOSE ARE WAYS
WE'RE ALSO LOOKING AT PILOTY
WAYS TO USE COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS TO INCREASE THE
AWARENESS AND COMMUNITIES.
WE A PILOT CURRENTLY BEFRIEND
BEFORE US THAT WE'RE EVALUATING
THAT THE PIPE DEEPLY HAS TO DO
WITH.
THE S. R. OWES IN GETTING DOING
OUTREACH TO THOSE PARTICULAR
COMMUNITIES BUT WE'RE ALSO
ENCOURAGING OTHER PILOTS TO BE
SUBMITTED.
INCREASE ENROLLMENT THE
COMMISSION ALSO HAS THE TEAM
PROGRAM WHICH PROVIDES FOR A
WIDE RANGE OF CAN BE BASED
ORGANIZATIONS EDUCATION ABOUT
TELECOMMUNICATIONS ISSUES WERE
PARTING WITH -- TO INCREASE
AWARENESS OF LIFE FLIGHT.
OKAY I'M YOU KNOW I'VE HEARD
THAT THERE MAY BE SOME BARRIERS
FOR COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS -- TO HELP WITH
THAT OUR REGION I HOPE THAT --
THE CPUC WILL BE WORKING TO
STREAMLINING GET RID OF THOSE
BARRIERS.
I UNDERSTAND YOUR CONCERN YES
WE'RE WORKING TOWARD THE GOAL.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
HIS REST.
CLEARLY NOT A DATE FOR SHEET THE
COMMENTS THAT WERE MADE ON THIS
40% THAT IS OF GREAT CONCERN --
THAT SO FEW ARE RECEIVING THE
BENEFITS THAT IS.
BY ITS VERY NATURE BY ITS VERY
NAME A LIFELINE -- IT JUST A
THOUGHT -- AND GOING BACK TO MS
REVERSES COMMENTS WE HAVE YOU
THOUGHT OF PERHAPS I'M SURE
YOU'VE THOUGHT OF THIS BUT I
WANT TO ASK.
ABOUT -- MAKING SURE THAT AS YOU
GIVE THE INFORMATION DID YOU USE
THOSE.
GROUPS THAT ARE ALREADY
RECEIVING BENEFITS THAT WOULD
CLASSIFY THEM AS BEING UNDER THE
POVERTY LEVEL OR OR BEING IN
NEED LIKE THE RECIPIENTS OF SS I
SS P. -- CAL FRESH CAL WORKS TO
PROVIDE THE INFIRMITY FORMATION
TO THEM SO THAT THEY KNOW THIS
IS A BENEFIT THAT THEY PROBABLY
ALREADY QUALIFY.
FOR YES WE ARE ACTIVELY IN
CONVERSATIONS WITH CAL FOR US IN
WITH OTHER STATE AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO PROVIDE.
A PUBLIC ASSISTANCE BENEFITS.
TO BOTH PARTNER WITH THEM IN
TERMS OF OUT REACH BUT ALSO
POTENTIAL TO PARTNER WITH THEM
TO DO ELIGIBILITY DETERMINATIONS
ENROLLMENT IN OUR PROGRAM.
SO WE'RE HAVING THOSE
DISCUSSIONS ACTIVELY. ONE OF I
WILL TELL YOU THAT IN MY
COMMUNITY. FOR MY SENIOR FAIRS
THERE'S ALWAYS SOMEBODY THERE
ALWAYS SOMEONE THERE TO TALK TO
MY SENIORS MY APPRECIATE THAT
VERY MUCH.
GLAD TO HEAR THAT THANK YOU.
I WOULD JUST -- BEFORE WE TAKE
PUBLIC COMMENT -- A CALL
ATTENTION TO THE STAFF COMMENTS
ON THIS ITEM THAT TO REFER TO
THE GROWTH OF THE CPUC THE
ADDITIONAL RESPONSIBILITIES THAT
OF BEEN TAKEN ON AND AND KIND OF
RAISING THE QUESTION WHETHER OR
NOT -- THE LEGISLATURE MIGHT
WANT TO EVALUATE -- WHERE THE
RIGHT HOME FOR THIS PARTICULAR --
THE PROGRAM -- IS -- I I THINK
THERE'S A LOT OF ROOM -- FOR
INCREASING THE THE UTILIZATION
OF LIFELINE PROGRAM AND IT'S
IT'S SOMETHING THAT WE ALL VALUE
AND IT'S EXTREMELY IMPORTANT
GIVEN -- THE INCREASE IMPORTANCE
THAT CONNECTIVE ITTY HOUSE BOTH
FOR EMERGENCY SERVICES AND JUST
REALLY YOU KNOW BEING CONNECTED.
IN GENERAL SO -- IT IS -- A
REFER TO AS SOMETHING WE MIGHT
WANT TO CONSIDER THROUGH THE
POLICY -- PROCESS AND OF THAT --
THROWS OUT AN IDEA FOR OF A BILL
IN THE NEXT -- TO HALF OF THE
SESSION I THINK THAT THAT WOULD
BE COMPLETELY A APPROPRIATE SO
THAT WE CAN DO SOME OF THE U.
ATION AT A MINIMUM OF THAT
CONCEPT.
OF AND WITH THAT WE'LL LOOK AT
WILL LOOK TO RECEIVE PUBLIC
COMMENT NOW AND ISSUES TWO AND
THREE AND AGAIN PLEASE KEEP YOUR
COMMENTS AS CONSTRAINED AS
POSSIBLE YES SIR.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR JUST
ABOUT THE WITH THE WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY JUST
TO REITERATE THE GREAT CONCERN
THAT WE HAVE FOR ONLY 40%
PARTICIPATION RATE -- THIS IS AN
ISSUE NOT ONLY FOR ACCESS TO
BENEFITS AS YOU KNOW WE'RE
TRYING TO TO MOVE OUT -- THE
APPLICATION PROCESS -- FOR HOW
WORKS MEDICAID COVERAGE ONTO A
MORE ELECTRONIC PROCESS AND
TELEPHONIC PROCESS AND AS WE DO
THAT.
AND AT THE SAME TIME DON'T OF
BRING THESE FEDERALLY FUNDED AND
SAY FUNDED -- PHONE TELEPHONE
SUPPORTED -- BENEFITS TO
EVERYBODY WHO'S ELIGIBLE WERE
UNDERMINING EFFORTS THAT YOU'RE
SUPPORTING ELSEWHERE -- ONE LAST
THING TO KNOW AND THAT IS WITH
THE HOUSING CRISIS AND WITH
HOMELESSNESS -- BEING -- AS AS
BIG AS IT IS -- HAVING ACCESS TO
A PHONE ISN'T JUST ACCESS TO
BENEFITS IT'S ALSO ACCESS TO
HELP -- PEOPLE WHO ARE HOMELESS
ARE INCREASINGLY VICTIMS OF
CRIME AND HAVING -- AWAY TO CALL
FOR HELP WHEN YOU NEED IT IS IS
IMPORTANT AND SO PEOPLE WHO
DON'T HAVE REGULAR.
ONGOING STUDY NON INTERRUPTED
ACCESS TO HAVE -- LIFELINE --
ARE UNDERMINED AND AND GETTING
THAT HELP AS WELL.
SO WE URGE YOUR FURTHER
CONSIDERATION SUPPORT FOR HER
PERCENT PARTICIPATION RATES AND
THANK YOU FOR THE CALL FOR
SECTION.
HELLO I'M DATING JOHNSON ON THE
CEO AND OWNER OF TRUE CONNECT
COMMUNICATIONS WERE THE ONLY
CALIFORNIA BASED TO LIFE ON
PROVIDER. FOR WIRELESS AND
PREVIOUSLY WIRELINE SERVICE IN
CALIFORNIA -- SUCH WERE VERY --
SUPPORT OF THE INCREASE IN THE
BUDGET OUR FOCUS IS MORE ON THE
OUTREACH -- THAT'S OCCURRING
WE'RE KANSI FOCUS ON AVERAGE
WITH CBO'S.
IN RURAL AREAS OUR MAIN ISSUES
RELATED -- TO THE ISSUE AROUND
HOW WE CAN DO OUTRAGE WHEN THEIR
CONSTITUTIONS RELATED.
TO GETTING THE FULL PROGRAM --
ON ELECTRONIC DIGITAL FORMAT.
FROM THE IN THE ROMAN IS DONE
THROUGH DIGITAL PROCESS WITH THE
TPI.
INTO THAT AND THAT PART WORKS
BUT WITH ISSUES RELATED WE
CERTIFICATION OF THE THINGS THAT
ARE.
STILL NOT DIGITAL AFTER FOUR
YEARS -- THAT MAKES THE ISSUE
VERY CUMBERSOME AND RESULTS IN A
LOT OF CHURN FOR CARRIERS.
WE HAVE FOCUS ON CHURN AND
MAINTAIN OUR CUSTOMER BASE AND
THAT TAKES AWAY FROM THE ROLE IN
OUTREACH EFFORTS SO THOSE ISSUES
TENTATIVE LAWSON'S CONVERSATION.
AT THIS CONVERSATION IF YOU LOOK
FOR YEARS NOW.
AND WE VERY MUCH WANT TO GET
THAT ADDRESSED -- TO ADDRESSTHE
QUESTION THAT THAT SOME WOMEN
PATTERSON PROPERLY -- YES THE
BULK OF THE FUNDING GOES TOWARDS
TORQUE SERVICE THE AND CONSUMER --
IT'S CARRIED THROUGH BOTH AND
COSTS REALLY THE TP A FOR THE
DIGITALLY -- PROVIDED SERVICE --
THAT'S PAID THROUGH THE CBC AND
THE CARERS PEANUTS AND OTHERS.
COVER THE COST TO PROVIDE A
SERVICE UP FRONT AND THEN WE
SEEK REVERSING THE CPC
AFTERWARDS SO MAJORITY ACROSS IS
COVERED AND DIRECTOR BECAUSE THE
CONSUMER.
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS BERNIE OROZCO WITH THE
CABLE INDUSTRY -- WE HAVE SOME --
CAN RESERVATIONS ABOUT THE
PROPOSAL WITH MAY BE PREMATURE
AT THIS TIME AND MISTER
PATTERSON'S POINT.
THIS IS ALMOST A HALF A BILLION
DOLLARS IT'S COLLECTED FROM
CUSTOMERS SO THIS IS ONLY ONE OF
SEVERAL -- SURCHARGES THAT A
CUSTOMER WILL HAVE ON THEIR BILL
EVER TALKING ABOUT INCREASING
THE NINE ONE ONE SURCHARGE THIS
CAN BE MORE THAN DOUBLE SO IT
GOING FROM ABOUT FOURTEEN CENTS
ABOUT THIRTY FOUR CENTS.
SO THIS THIS WITH THIS AMOUNT OF
MONEY HALF A BILLION DOLLARS
ALMOST -- WE'VE GOT TO HAVE
SALUTE BIT MORE INSURANCES ABOUT
GETTING TO THE BEYOND THAT 40%
PARTICIPATION RATE.
THE PROGRAMS THAT WERE PROPOSING
HERE TODAY OR THE COMMISSION'S
PROPOSED HERE TODAY IS NOT.
IT'S IT'S TARGET A CERTAIN GROUP
OF PARTICIPANTS THIS IS GOING TO
BE FOSTER KIDS UP TO THE AGE OF
TWENTY SIX SO IF YOU'RE LOOKING
TO JUST INCREASE YOUR NUMBERS
THIS IS ONE WAY TO DO IT.
BUT WE WOULD SAY STEP BACK I
THINK LET'S JONES HAS
RECOMMENDED A MORE COMPREHENSIVE
FORMAL STUDY OF THE PROGRAM TO
FIND OUT HOW BEST TO IMPLEMENT
THAT.
MISTER CHAIRMAN TO YOUR POINT
ABOUT GETTING SERVICES TO THE
RIGHT PEOPLE -- I THINK
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S IN THE MID
NINETIES HAD A GREAT STUDY THAT
WAS CALL MAKING GOVERNMENT MAKES
SENSE.
AND IN THAT STUDY THEY LOOK AT
WHERE AT BIRD THE CONTACT POINTS
THAT YOU MEET THESE INDIVIDUALS
SO MAYBE IT IS MAYBE ANOTHER
APARTMENT YOU SHOULD BE LOOKING
AT THAT SHOULD -- IMPLEMENT THIS
PROGRAM BUT AT THIS POINT WE'RE
WE HAVE SOME RESERVATIONS BUT
THE PROGRAM BUT WE ARE SUPPORTER
OF THE OF THE PROGRAM OVERALL
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU -- WILL -- HOLD THE
BOTH OF THESE ITEMS OPEN THANK
YOU FOR YOUR PRESENTATION THIS
MORNING GOD OF FOLKS WE HAVE
TWENTY THREE ISSUES LEFT. TO TO
TO WADE THROUGH AND THIS VERY
PONDEROUS AGENDA SO -- WE'RE
GOING -- TO TRY AND SPEED THINGS
UP NOW WITH ISSUE NUMBER FIVE
DEPARTMENT OF CONSERVATION.
YEAH I HAVEN'T HEARD BACK
[inaudible]
GOOD MORNING.
GOOD MORNING TO YOU TO KEEP YOUR
COMMENTS TO A SUMMARY PLEASE YES
SIR.
GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS WENDY WEAVER I'M THE CHIEF
INFORMATION OFFICER FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF CONSERVATION I'M
HERE SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF THE
WELL STAR SPRING FINANCE LETTER.
I DO TO STATUTORY AND REGULATORY
CHANGES THAT HAVE OCCURRED SINCE
THE INITIAL SCOPE OF THE WILL
STAR PROJECT -- WERE ASKING FOR
ADDITIONAL FUNDS TO ENHANCE THE
FUNCTIONALITY OF THE SYSTEM.
RELEASED FOR WELL STAR WENT LIVE
SUCCESSFULLY IN APRIL -- TWENTY
THIRTEEN I'M SORRY TWENTY
NINETEEN THAT WAS THE FINAL
RELEASE OF THE PROJECT WHICH HAS
BEEN ON TIME AND UNDER BUDGET
DURING ITS LIFE CYCLE.
WE'RE CURRENTLY WORKING ON A
FACE TO WHICH WERE USING FUNDS
THAT WE WERE ABLE TO SAVE DURING
THE PREVIOUS PROJECT EFFORTS TO
COMPLETE THIS.
WERE ASKING FOR ADDITIONAL FUNDS
SO THAT THE FULL FACE TO CAN BE
IMPLEMENTED -- WE HOPE TO
IMPLEMENT THIS AT THE END OF
OCTOBER THIS YEAR.
I UNDERSTAND THE COMMITTEE MAY
HAVE SOME CONCERNS REGARDING
POTENTIAL FUTURE FUNDING FOR
MODIFICATIONS AS THEY WOULD
RELATE TO STATUTORY AND
REGULATORY CHANGES THAT COME UP --
SO IN OCTOBER WE BEGIN
MAINTENANCE AND OPERATIONS OF
THIS THE FOCUS OF MAINTENANCE
AND OPERATIONS FOR APPROXIMATELY
EIGHTEEN MONTHS WOULD BE TO
REMEDIATE ANY POTENTIAL DEFECTS
THAT WE FIND.
MAKE ANY ENHANCEMENTS THAT ARE
NECESSARY AND CHANGES TO
FUNCTIONALITY.
THAT MAINTENANCE AND OPERATIONS
PHASE IS ALREADY FULLY FUNDED
THROUGH THE INITIAL B. C. P.
THAT WE HAVE -- BEYOND THIS THE
DEPARTMENT HAS AN APPROPRIATION
OF APPROXIMATELY FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS ANNUALLY WE
WOULD EXPECT -- TO USE THIS OF
FUNDING THAT WE ALREADY HAVE
WITH IN HOUSE STAFF IN ORDER TO
DO ANY ADDITIONAL MAKE THAT
MODIFICATIONS THAT MAY BE NEEDED.
SO IF THERE WERE MAJOR CHANGES
THAT CAME DOWN THE LINE DUE TO
STATUTORY OR REGULATORY CHANGES
WE COULD POTENTIALLY HAVE TO ASK
FOR ADDITIONAL FUNDS AT THAT
TIME.
BUT IF THAT WERE TO OCCUR THE
DEPARTMENT WOULD KNOW THIS IN
ANY LEGISLATIVE BILL ANALYSIS
THAT WAS PUT OUT THERE AND YOU
GUYS WOULD BE WELL AWARE OF THAT
UP FRONT.
THANK YOU DO YOU HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS -- THANK YOU -- LA JOH
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE QUESTIONS
FROM THE DíAS IS THE PUBLIC
COMMENT ON THIS ITEM.
SEEING NONE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR THE PRESENTATION WILL HOLD
THIS ITEM OPEN ISSUE.
SIX DEPARTMENT OF RESOURCES
RECYCLING AND RECOVERY
[inaudible]
CAL RECYCLE.
URGENCY DEBRIS CLEANUP AND
RECOVERY.
THIS FIRST LINE WELCOME.
SUMMARY ONLY PLEASE.
MORNING MR JR MEMBERS AND SCOTT
SMITH LINE WITH A DEPARTMENT OF
RESOURCES RECYCLING RECOVERY --
TO KEEP IT BRIEF CAL RECYCLE
REQUEST TWO POINT SEVENTY TWO
MILLION DOLLARS IN BUDGET YEAR
AND THREE POINT FOUR ONE FOUR
MILLION ANNUALLY THEREAFTER TO
SUPPORT TWENTY ONE POINT FIVE
PERMANENT POSITIONS. FOR
DEDICATED STAFFING RESOURCES AND
DEPARTMENT INFRASTRUCTURE TO
PROVIDE EMERGENCY DEBRIS REMOVAL
SERVICES.
CAL CAL RECYCLING PLOYS AT THE
STAFF MANAGEMENT AN EXECUTIVE
LEVEL ARE FREQUENTLY RE DIRECTED
FROM THE REGULAR DUTIES TO
ASSIST WITH PROVIDING PUBLIC
AVERAGE COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT
TECHNICAL EXPERTISE ENGINEERING
SUPPORT.
CONTRACT MANAGEMENT LEGAL FISCAL
AND BUDGETARY ADMINISTRATIVE
SERVICES FOR DEBRIS REMOVAL
OPERATIONS THIS REQUEST WILL
PROVIDE STAFFING LEVELS
COMMENSURATE WITH THE DEGREE OF
CARE.
OVERSIGHT TIMELINESS AND
ATTENTION TO DETAIL THAT
CALIFORNIA'S DEBRIS REMOVAL
OPERATIONS REQUIRE.
IN SHORT IT'S BECOME MORE
PREDICTABLE THAT WE NEED -- TO
THESE KINDS OF SERVICES MORE OR
LESS ON A YEAR ROUND BASIS SO WE
HAVE NEW POSITIONS TO
ACCOMMODATE TO KIND OF THE NEW
REALITY WE HAVE RIGHT HE HE
THOUSAND SEVEN WE'VE BEEN CALLED
TO TWENTY TWO OPERATIONS.
ON THE LAST. FOR YEARS HALF OF
THE MOST DESTRUCTIVE WILDFIRES
WE'VE HAD BEEN IN THE LAST FOUR
YEARS SO YES THE FREQUENCY AND
THE INTENSITY -- AND THE
DURATION AND THE THAT THE THE
DURATION OF THEM AND AND TERMS
OF LATE SEASON VIRUSES HAS ALL
EXPANDED WHICH CAUSES US TO
BASICALLY BE.
HAVING ONE DEBRIS REMOVAL
OPERATION ROLL OVER INTO THE
NEXT FIRE SEASON SO YES ALL
THOSE ARE TRUE THANK YOU MISS
PETERS.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR JUST
COMPUTERS AT THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE.
WE DON'T HAVE ANY CONCERNS WITH
THIS PROPOSAL JUST WANT TO NOTE
FOR THE COMMITTEE AND WHEN WE
LOOKED AT THAT THAT BACK AT AND
THAT DEPARTMENT PROVIDED VERY
GOOD INFORMATION AND NOT JUST ON
SORT OF THE PEAK WORKLOAD WITH
SOME OF THE MORE SEVERE FIRES
THAT HAVE HAPPENED IN.
RECENT YEARS -- BUT LOOKING BACK
AND AT THEIR REDIRECTED
RESOURCES IN THE LEVEL OF
STAFFING MAKES SENSE IN ADDITION
AT THE PROPOSAL HAS THREE
LIMITED TERM POSITIONS -- AS
WELL TO HELP DEAL WITH SOME OF
THE PEAK WORKLOAD THAT THEY'RE
EXPERIENCING RIGHT NOW RELATED
TO THE CAMPFIRE AND SAID THE
PROPOSAL FOR ALL SEEMS
REASONABLE.
THANK YOU FINANCE NOTHING THE
QUESTIONS FROM THE DíAS.
IS THERE ANY PUBLIC COMMENT ON
THIS ISSUE ISSUE.
SIX SEEING NONE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WILL ENABLE THIS ITEM OPEN.
ISSUE SEVEN THE SANTA MONICA
MOUNTAINS CONSERVANCY.
BRING CASH FROM THE NATURAL
RESOURCES AGENCY REPRESENTING
THE SANTA MONICA MOUNTAINS
CONSERVANCY TODAY -- THE
CONSERVANCY'S REQUESTING FIFTEEN
MILLION DOLLARS AND TWO
POSITIONS TO COVER THE STATE
COSTS FROM DAMAGE FROM THE
WOLSELEY FIRE.
THANK YOU MISS PETERS.
NO CONCERNS I JUST WANT TO POINT
OUT FREE YOU HAVE A SIMILAR
PROPOSAL UNDER A DEPARTMENT
PARKS RECREATION -- ALSO RELATED
TO THE WALLS THE FIRE ON THIS
WHEN AND IT'S A ONE TIME ONE
YEAR PROPOSAL.
AND THAT CONSERVANCY DID PROVIDE
A PRETTY DETAILED INFORMATION ON
HOW THE FUNDS WOULD BE SPENT WE
HAVE NO CONCERNS.
WITH SPELL EXPECT NOTHING LESS
FROM MY CONSERVANCY -- MY LOCAL
CONSERVANCY -- FINANCE AS NO
REPORT AND I'M SEEING NO HANDS
RAISED ON THE DíAS IS THERE ANY
PUBLIC COMMENT ON THIS ITEM.
SEEING NONE THANK YOU FOR THE
PRESENTATION.
HOLDING THAT OPEN -- ISSUE EIGHT
UNDER DEPARTMENT OF FORESTRY AND
FIRE PROTECTION CAL FIRE.
EXCUSE ME ISSUES EIGHT THROUGH
[inaudible]
TWELVE AND AS HAS BECOME OUR
PRACTICE WILL TAKE PUBLIC
COMMENT AT THE CONCLUSION OF
ISSUE TWELVE FOR ISSUES EIGHT
THROUGH.
TWELVE GOOD MORNING WELCOME
MORNING.
MISTER CHAIRMAN OF THE COMMITTEE
MET DS EXECUTIVE OFFICER BOARD
OF FORESTRY AND FIRE PROTECTION --
THE BORDER FORCING FIRE
PROTECTION IS NINE MEMBER BOARD.
DELEGATE THE AUTHORITY. TO TO
DEVELOP AND MAINTAIN A SCHEME OF
REGULATORY AND POLICY LEVEL --
BUT REGULATION POLICIES RELATES
TO FORCE MANAGEMENT WILD FIRE
PROTECTION WHILE NOT FAR
PREVENTION.
AND WANT TO KEEP PROJECTS THAT
WE'VE BEEN WORKING ON OVER THE
LAST MANY YEARS IS THE CAL VTP.
IT'S A PROGRAMMATIC HE I ARE
THAT -- IS GOING.
TO ASSIST AND INCREASE THE PACE
AND SCALE OF WATER AND FIRE
PREVENTION ACTIVITIES AS A
WRITER.
PAGE MANAGEMENT ACROSS TWENTY
MILLION ACRES OF CALIFORNIA.
A LOT OF THAT PROJECT THE
BORDERS REQUEST A ONE TIME
ALLOCATION OF SEVEN HUNDRED
THIRTY THOUSAND DOLLARS TO
ASSIST AND ALLOWING US TO MEET
OUR AGGRESSIVE TIME LINES OF
CERTIFICATION OF THAT DOCUMENT
BY THE END OF THIS YEAR.
ALLOWING OUR COLLEAGUES TO
CALIFORNIA'S OTHER -- OTHER
STATE INTERESTS AND ACHIEVING
THEIR GOALS OF WATER AND FIRE
PREVENTION ACTIVITIES
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
NO CONCERNS HOPEFULLY THIS TAKE
THAT ACROSS THE FINISH LINE.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU LET'S MOVE
ON ISSUE EIGHT EXCUSE ME.
NINE I CHAIRMAN BLOOM JOE TYLER
A DEPUTY DIRECTOR CHIEF FIRE
PROTECTION WITH CAL FIRE.
OUR REQUEST IS RE REQUEST FOR
FOUR POINT SIX MILLION GENERAL
FUND IN NINETEEN TWENTY FOUR
POINT SIX MILLION GENERAL FUND
AND TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND TWO
POINT.
TWO MILLION IN GENERAL FUND IN
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO TO REQUEST
THE USE OF AN EXCLUSIVE USE A C.
ONE THIRTY AIRCRAFT FOR THE
PURPOSES OF TRAINING -- FUTURE
PILOTS TO FLY -- THE C. ONE
THIRTY IS THAT ARE BEING
RECEIVED.
BY THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA FROM
THE NATIONAL DEFENSE
AUTHORIZATION ACT OF THROUGH THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT FROM THE
UNITED STATES COAST GUARD IN THE
UNITED STATES AIRFORCE.
OF THE PILOTS WILL COMPLETE
THEIR TRAINING SO THEY CAN FLY
THE C. ONE THIRTIES AS SOON AS
THOSE AIRCRAFT ARRIVE.
OF THE EXCLUSIVE USE TO SEE ONE
THIRTY WOULD ALSO HAVE A
SECONDARY BENEFIT.
OF BEING AN ADDITIONAL
FIREFIGHTING AIRCRAFT CARRYING
FOUR THOUSAND GALLONS RETARDANT.
A TO FIGHT FIRES ACROSS THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA -- WE HAVE
AN EXECUTIVE STEERING COMMITTEE
THAT HAS BEEN IN CONTACT WITH
THESE FEDERAL AGENCIES.
AND IN THE JANUARY BUDGET WE HAD
TO ASSUME THAT THE FIRST PLANET
BEALE DELIVERED IN TWENTY TWENTY
ONE BUT I HAD HOPED THAT A PLANE
WOULD BE DELIVERED SOONER THAN
THAT -- WITH THAT TO LEARNING
THAT THAT WASN'T GOING TO OCCUR --
WE'RE COMING FORWARD WITH A
REQUEST FOR OF THIS TRAINING
PLATFORM FOR THE NEXT THREE
YEARS WITHOUT THIS PLATFORM --
WE WILL HAVE CREWS AS THE NEW
SEE ONE THIRTIES COME IN FROM
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT THEY MAY
BE UNABLE TO FLY THESE AIRCRAFT
UNTIL THEY ARE TRAINED -- THERE
BY SITTING ON THE TARMAC AT
MCCLELLAN OR THEIR LOCATIONS A.
B. ASSIGNED.
UNTIL SUCH TIME AS THOSE PILOTS
ARE TRAINED.
THIS BUDGET REQUEST WILL ALLOW A
AS SOON AS THESE AIRCRAFT ARE
RETROFITTED IN A SIGNED --
SWIMMING THAT WILL GET THE FIRST
ONE IN -- TWENTY TWENTY AND THEN
THERE AFTER RECEIVE THEM THROUGH --
TWENTY TWENTY THREE THAT WE WILL
HAVE ANOTHER AIR ASSETS
AVAILABLE -- TO FIGHT FIRES
ACROSS THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
AS I MENTIONED AS A SECONDARY
BENEFIT -- IT IS A FIRE FIGHTING
AIRCRAFT THAT WOULD BE ACTIVE
DOG WITH THE TWENTY TWO BEST TO
TEASE THAT WE HAVE CURRENTLY IN
THE FLEET.
MY CONCERN IF WE DON'T ACQUIRE
THIS AIRCRAFT AS IS THEIR CRAFT
COULD BE ACQUIRED BY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT UNDER CONTRACT WITH
THEM.
IN THEIR FOUR WOULD BECOME A
NATIONAL FIREFIGHTING ASSET NOT
AN ASSET THAT'S CONTROLLED WITH
IN CALIFORNIA.
IN ADDITION -- PLACING AN
EXCLUSIVE USER TANKER -- IT ON
CONTRACT WITH US WILL ALLOW TO
RESPOND IMMEDIATE DISPATCH
WITHIN TEN TO FIFTEEN MINUTES.
OF VERSES AND A CALL WHEN NEEDED
AIRCRAFT THE MAY TAKE TWENTY
FOUR FORTY EIGHT OR SEVENTY TWO
HOURS TO ROUTE TO RESPOND.
A YOUR EMERGENCY FINALLY WE
LEARNED YESTERDAY FROM MAJOR
GENERAL -- BALDWIN THAT ONE OF
HIS TO SEE ONE THIRTIES WE
TYPICALLY USE FOR MASS
ACTIVATIONS AT THE CHANNEL
ISLANDS IS CURRENTLY DEPLOYED
OVERSEAS AND WON'T BE AVAILABLE
LATE IN THE YEAR THIS AIRCRAFT
AFTER LEARNING THAT YESTERDAY
COULD AUGMENT THAT ABILITY WERE
WE TYPICALLY RELY ON THE
NATIONAL GUARD AS WELL --
ULTIMATELY WE BELIEVE -- BASED
ON PREVIOUS USE OF EXCLUSIVE USE
AND SEE -- ONE THIRTIES AND
OTHER LARGE AIR TANKERS THAT
THIS IS A COST NEUTRAL PROPOSAL --
MISS PATTERSON -- LET ME ASK A
QUESTION FIRST IF YOU DON'T MIND
IT -- COMES AS QUITE A SURPRISE
THAT WE ONLY LEARNED YESTERDAY
THAT WE WON'T HAVE USE OF A C.
ONE THIRTY BECAUSE IT'S OVERSEAS
IN THE A WHAT -- IF THERE WERE
TO BE A START TOMORROW I ASSUME
THAT THE THAT AIRCRAFT COULD BE
CRITICAL TO OUR RESPONSE.
HOW IS IT THAT THIS -- HAPPENS
THAT YOU KNOW.
IT AND AND UNFOLDED IN THE WAY
THAT IT DID.
UNDERSTAND WE HAD AN
INFORMATIONAL HEARING THE A
YESTERDAY MORNING A JOINT
COMMITTEE -- WHERE THE -- MAJOR
GENERAL EXPRESS THAT TO ONE OF
HIS AIRCRAFT WERE OVERSEAS -- IT
WAS OUR FIRST OPPORTUNITY TO I
KNOW THAT THAT HAD OCCURRED --
HOWEVER -- FOR FIREFIGHTING
MISSIONS CURRENTLY ARE ASKED TO
TEASE ARE ACTIVELY DEPLOYED --
IN A COLUMBIA HOLLISTER PASO
ROBLES PORTERVILLE -- HEMET RYAN
AND RAMONA CURRENTLY TO MEET THE
INITIAL ATTACK NEEDS THAT WE
HAVE AS OF TODAY -- SEEMS LIKE
AN ISSUE.
HEY -- MISTER PATTERSON TO HAVE
A QUESTION.
I THINK IS REALLY.
IMPORTANT.
ISSUE IN THE BIGGER PICTURE SO I
WANT TO UNDERSTAND -- THIS WILL
COME ON LINE PRIOR. TO THE SEVEN
YES SIR RIGHT.
AND NOT UNTIL. TWENTY TWENTY THE
FIRST TO SEE ONE THIRTY FROM THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IS EXPECTED
TO ARRIVE.
IN FISCAL YEAR.
TWENTY TWENTY AND THIS ONE WILL
BE USED.
RIGHT AWAY.
SO WE LATELY WE WE APPROPRIATE
THIS AND YOU'RE FLYING THAT
AIRPLANE YES SIR GREAT WONDERFUL --
HOW LONG DO YOU?
SUSPECT IT WILL BE TO GET.
RETRO FIT AND GET IN SERVICE THE
SET THE SEVEN AIRCRAFT.
IT IS OUR EXPECTATION THAT -- IN --
TWENTY TWENTY FISCAL YEAR TWENTY
TWENTY THAT WE WOULD RECEIVE A
WE'RE HOPING TO RECEIVE BASED ON
OUR DISCUSSIONS. THREE C. ONE
THIRTY AIRCRAFT.
OF THAT WE WOULD EXPECT AT LEAST
ONE OF THEM TO GO IN SERVICE AND
TWENTY TWENTY IN.
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO BASED ON
AIRFORCE TIMELINES WE WOULD
EXPECT TO RECEIVE ONE AND WOULD
HAVE TWO AIRCRAFT ONLINE.
IN TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE WE
WOULD RECEIVE AN ADDITIONAL
AIRCRAFT FROM THE AIRFORCE --
WITH FOUR PLANES ONLINE IN
TWENTY THREE TWENTY FOUR WOULD
RECEIVE THE FINAL TWO WITH FIVE
AIRPLANES ONLINE.
THE RESULTS FIVE INSTEAD OF
SEVEN IS TWO OF THOSE AIRCRAFT
WOULD BE IN MAINTENANCE RESERVE
ONE IS GENERALLY ALWAYS.
IN MAINTENANCE ONE IS IN A TEAR
DOWN SO FIVE WILL BE ACTIVELY
DEPLOYED ACROSS THE STATE -- IN
TIMES OF REALLY STARK
EMERGENCIES WITH FIRES EXPLODING.
COULD DOES TO BE QUICKLY PUT
BACK INTO SERVICE WE HAVE.
AT FIRST INFORMACIóN IMPORTANT
NOTE THAT THE PILOTS CO PILOTS
AND FLGHT ENGINEERS OF THE C.
ONE THIRTY YOU'RE DYING CORPS
INTERNATIONAL CONTRACTED PILOTS.
WE HAVE THE CAPABILITY OF THOSE
AIRCRAFT AVAILABLE JUST AS OUR
S. TO TEASE ARE NOW TO PLACES
AIRCRAFT IN SERVICE IF THEY'RE
NEEDED.
THAT WITH WITH OFF DUTY FLICKERS
THAT'S A YES YES RIGHT YES I
WILL WE WOULDN'T WANT TO YES THE
SERVICE READY TO FLY YOUR PLANE.
SITTING IN A HANGAR SOMEWHERE
YES CORRECT SIR GREAT CAN YOU
HELP ME UNDERSTAND IT JUST SEEMS
LIKE.
THAT'S A LONG LONG TIME I WISH
WE COULD DO IT.
QUICKER WHAT ARE THE BARRIERS
YOU'RE FACING TO THAT -- WE WORK
CLOSELY WITH -- SENATOR
FEINSTEIN'S OFFICE -- AND WITH
THE UNITED STATES AIRFORCE AND
THE UNITED STATES COAST GUARD
THE PLANES ARE ACTUALLY ASSIGNED
TO THE UNITED STATES COAST GUARD
UNDER HOMELAND SECURITY.
THE RETRO FIT UNDER THE NATIONAL
DEFENSE AUTHORIZATION ACT
REQUIRED THE AIRPLANES TO GO TO
THE WARNER ROBINS AIR LOGISTICS
BASE IN GEORGIA TO BE
RETROFITTED.
BY THE UNITED STATES AIRFORCE.
DEPARTMENT OF DEFENSE SO WE'VE
HAD A SOME BARRIERS THAT WE'VE
OVERCOME DOES AN EXECUTIVE
STEERING COMMITTEE THERE-- BUT
ULTIMATELY AT THE END OF THE DAY
IT IS A FEDERAL FEDERAL
PROCUREMENT THROUGH AN RFP
PROCESS FOR THE RETURN DELIVERY
SYSTEM TO BE PLACED INTO THE
AIRCRAFT.
AS WELL AS THE INTERN OUTER WING
BOXES OF THE AIRCRAFT TO BE
RETROFITTED IN THE MAINTENANCE
DONE OF THESE AIRCRAFT.
PRIOR TO DIRECTLY TRANSFERRING
THEM TO OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA -- SO THE BERRIES ARE
BARRIERS -- TO BE.
THAT THIS IS THE QUICKEST THAT
THE UNITED STATES AIRFORCE AT
THE WARNER ROBINS AIR LOGISTICS
BASE CAN TURNER CRAFTS AROUND A
PROVIDE THEM THE STATE THEY WILL
COME TO US THERE WERE THE AND
RETROFIT IT YES SIR. ONE FOR ONE
FINAL HOW DOES THIS TIMELINE OF
THE C. FIVE OR THE ONE WAS HE
ONE THIRTIES.
ARE INTER PLAY WITH THE
ACQUISITION OF THE NEW
HELICOPTERS.
SO -- SO I TALKED ABOUT THE
TIMELINE FOR THE ACQUISITION OF
THE AIRCRAFT AS RELATES TO THIS
THE S. SEVENTY AYE HELICOPTERS.
OF THE FIRST ONE WE EXPECT TO
ARRIVE IN JUNE.
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN OF THE
SECOND ONE UNFORTUNATELY WAS
INVOLVED IN IT IN A IN AN
ACCIDENT -- IS BEING TRANSPORTED
ACROSS THE COUNTRY WAS
RELATIVELY MINOR IT'S BEEN
REPAIRED AND IS CURRENTLY BEEN
FLOWN TO DECATUR TEXAS FOR ITS
PAINT.
FROM THERE WILL GO TO INGLEWOOD
COLORADO FOR ITS AVIONICS
EXPECTED IN THE FALL -- AFTER
THAT WILL EXPECT THIS THE S.
SEVENTY AYE -- HELICOPTERS
RECEIVER TO TO ARRIVE EVERY
HUNDRED TWENTY DAYS OR SO
THEY'RE NOT HELD WE GET TO
TWELFTH UNTIL WE GET.
TO TWELVE ASSUMING THAT -- IN
THAT THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED
BUDGET APPROVED THE ACQUISITION
OF FOR ADDITIONAL HELICOPTER
SHORTLY AFTER JULY FIRST OF TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY SORRY NINETEEN
AND THE FINAL THREE I'M SURE HE
WOULD GLADLY.
MAKE THAT HAPPEN THANK YOU SIR
HAS ASSUMING THAT -- AND NONE OF
THE OTHER HELICOPTERS FALL OFF
OF TRUCKS.
YES I DID I DID THIS REALLY
REALLY IMPORTANT GET AN AIR
FLEET THAT THAT IS.
THIS SIZE AND ACT QUICKLY -- TO
DEPLOYED I THINK AIR -- IS GOING
TO BE ONE OF THE CRITICAL
FACTORS IN GOING FOR WITH SOME
OF THESE BIG EXPLOSIVE FIRES I
APPRECIATE THE EFFORT AND I I
THINK WE ALL.
ARE CHEN YANG GETTING HERE GET
HIM UP IN THE AIR AS FAST AS WE
CAN THANK YOU SIR APPRECIATE THE
EFFORT.
LA ALSO ADD THAT IT HOW FAR HAS
NOTED THAT THAT PROPOSAL OR SORT
OF THAT THAT PROPOSAL IS COST
NEUTRAL -- AND WE JUST WANT TO
FLAG FOR THE COMMITTEE THAT
WHILE THERE WILL LIKELY BE SAM
OFFSETTING SAVINGS AND THROUGH
AT THE PROCUREMENT OF CONTRACT
PLANES I DURING PEAK FIRE SEASON
SINCE THIS PROPOSAL HAS SORT OF
TWO PURPOSES.
MEETING THAT PEAK FIRE SEASON
NEED AS WELL AS THE TRAINING
PLATFORM -- IT'S IT'S SORT OF
INCONCLUSIVE TO WHAT EXTENT THAT
WILL FULLY OFFSET THE COSTS HERE
SO THAT IT COULD BE AT SORT OF A
COST INCREASE EVEN WHEN YOU TAKE
THAT INTO CONSIDERATION.
REALLY IT'S ALL GOING TO DEPEND
ON WHAT THE NEEDS WOULD BE
DURING PEAK FIRE SEASON OVER THE
COURSE OF THE NEXT THREE YEARS.
A WHILE THIS PLANE IS UNDER
CONTRACT WHICH NOBODY CAN REALLY
PREDICT ANSWER DID JUST WANT TO
FIND OUT FOR YOU HOWEVER AS IS
INDICATED THERE ARE BENEFITS TO
HAVING THE PLANE AND ALREADY
UNDER CONTRACT -- AS OPPOSED TO
DOING A CALL WHEN NEEDED WHERE
IT'S AVAILABLE MORE QUICKLY AND
IT ALSO HAS THAT COULD BENEFIT
OF BEING.
THE PUT THAT TRAINING PLATFORM
FOR THIS HE WENT THIRTIES AND
ALSO JUST KIND OF WANT.
TO REITERATE THIS IS REALLY PART
OF THE LARGER C. ONE THIRTY
PROPOSAL THAT THE COMMITTEE
REVIEW THAT WAS -- BUT FOR IN
JANUARY.
AND WHILE IT DOES HAVE THESE
OTHER BENEFITS RELATED TO PEAK
FIRE SEASON YOU MAY WANT TO
ALIGN -- WHAT YOU DO ON THIS
PIECE OF THE PROPOSAL WITH THAT
THE LEGISLATURE'S ACTIONS ON THE
LARGER C. ONE THIRTY PURPLES ALL?
ON AND AND HOW THAT BALANCES OUT
WITH ALL OF THE AND FIRE.
SUPPRESSION PROPOSALS THAT THE
LEGISLATURE ULTIMATELY LANDS ON
THANK YOU FOR MY FINANCE HOUSING
YOUR DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE JUST
WANT TO REITERATE FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PERSPECTIVE THE
BENEFITS OF HAVING THIS PLAN
AVAILABLE TO CAL FIRE TO ENHANCE
ITS FIRE SUPPRESSION EFFORTS AS
WELL AS ENSURING THAT WE CAN
TRAIN THE FLIGHT.
CREWS CRIED CB FLIGHT CREWS THAT
WE NEED TO BE ABLE TO DEPLOY THE
SEA WHEN THIRTIES AS QUICKLY AS
POSSIBLE -- FOLLOWING THEIR
DELIVERY.
THANK YOU I I THINK IN CONTEXT
THIS DOES THIS DOES MAKE SENSE
BUT IT ALLOWS ME ANOTHER
OPPORTUNITY -- TO TALK ABOUT --
OUR AIR PROGRAM IN IN GENERAL IT
SEEMS TO ME THAT -- OVER THE
YEARS AT LEAST SINCE I'VE BEEN
HERE -- OUR APPROACH HAS BEEN
MORE REACTIVE THAN PROACTIVE --
WHEN IT CAME TO THE HELICOPTERS
WE HAD TO REPLACE THAT SLEEP
BECAUSE -- THE EXISTING.
A FLEET OF HELICOPTERS TO REACH
THEIR WELL BEYOND THE THERE --
PERIOD OF OBSOLESCENCE -- AND
THIS IS A PROGRAM OF OPPORTUNITY
THAT -- SEE ONE THIRTIES HAVE
SORT OF BEEN OFFERED -- A TO US
BY THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AND
THERE'S SOME ADVANTAGES. TO US
IN IN TAKING ADVANTAGE OF OF
THAT OFFER AND THEN THIS
TRAINING PROGRAM FOLLOWS.
I HAVE A GOVERNOR BROWN -- CO A
QUITE APPROPRIATELY -- TALKED
ABOUT -- WILDFIRES THAT THE
CURRENTLY AND IN THE FUTURE IS
THE NEW NORMAL -- AND YET I
DON'T THINK WE HAVE -- TAKEN A
COMPREHENSIVE LOOK AT WHAT THE
FIREFIGHTING GUY AIR FLEET OF
THE FUTURE LOOKS LIKE.
AND I THINK WE NEED TO BEGIN
DOING THAT I THINK ONE OF THE
THINGS WE NEED TO THINK ABOUT IS
WHETHER -- WE SHOULD BE FINDING
A WAY TO DEVELOP AIRCRAFT THAT
ARE BUILT TO FROM THE GROUND UP
SPECIFICALLY FOR FIRE FIGHTING
PURPOSES IF THIS IS OUR NEW
NORMAL AND IT CERTAINLY -- IS --
THEN SHOULD OUR FLEET NOT --
REFLECT THAT IN OUR THEIR COST
EFFICIENCIES THAT -- KAMEL ALONG
WITH THAT -- I DON'T THINK WE'RE
IN A POSITION TO ANSWER THOSE
QUESTIONS BUT WE SHOULD PUT
OURSELVES IN A POSITION TO
ANSWER THOSE QUESTIONS SO THAT
WE CAN THEN -- BEGIN ALLOCATING
FUNDS -- TO AT ACHIEVE -- BOTH A
MORE EFFECTIVE AND MORE
EFFICIENT -- TO ERR -- ERR FLEET --
AND WITH THAT WENT AWAY -- MOVE
ON TO ISSUE -- TEN THE FARMERS
SOLUTION.
GOOD MORNING FAILING PARKER
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE -- SO AS
YOU MAY BE AWARE WE'VE BEEN
UNDERGOING A MISSION BASED
FIRE MARSHALL'S FIRE AND LIFE
SAFETY DIVISION FOR THE PAST TWO
YEARS.
THIS PROPOSAL REALLY REFLECTS
THE CULMINATION OF THAT REVIEW
OF THAT DIVISION THIS IS BEEN
REALLY A DEEP DIVE IN
COLLABORATION.
WITH THE DIVISION.
I WOULD POINT YOU TO LAST YEAR'S --
PROPOSAL WHICH WAS A REALLY A
DETAILED AND COMPREHENSIVE LOOK
AT THE WORKLOAD -- AND WE
ADDRESS SOME OF THE THE
INCREASED WORKLOAD THAT HAS
OCCURRED IN RECENT YEARS AS THE
CONSTRUCTION BOOM AS OCCURRED
YOU JUST NEED.
TO LOOK AROUND.
AND SEE ALL THE CONSTRUCTION
CRANES THAT ARE CURRENTLY.
DOTTING THE SKYLINE IS -- ACTING
FIRE MARSHAL -- RICH WIND.
WHAT IT OUT YESTERDAY?
IN THAT BCP LAST YEAR WE REALLY
HIGHLIGHTED SEVERAL KEY THINGS
THAT WE'RE GOING TO BE ADDRESSED --
IN THE REMAINDER OF THEIR VIEW
WHICH WAS A STATUTORY REVIEW OF
THAT.
KIND OF FRAMEWORK AND
REGULATIONS THAT THE DIVISION
OPERATES AND ALSO TRYING TO
ADDRESS.
ANY CONSTRUCTION DELAYS OR
PROJECT DELAYS THAT ARE.
RELATED TO SOME OF THEIR
STAFFING -- ISSUES.
AND FINALLY -- A LOOK AT THEIR
BILLING RATES AND METHODOLOGY SO
WITHOUT GOING INTO DETAIL UNLESS
YOU HAVE.
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS WE REALLY
FEEL THAT THIS PROPOSAL --
ADDRESSES THOSE CRITICAL NEEDS
AND AND REALLY SPECIFICALLY
ADDRESSES THOSE THREE ISSUES
THAT WE HIGHLIGHTED.
IN LAST YEAR'S PROPOSAL
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU -- LA -- WE DON'T HAVE
ANY CONCERNS WITH THE PROPOSAL
AND THAT THEY RESOURCES AND THE
CHANGES I'M BEING PROPOSED HERE
DO APPEAR TO BE A STEP IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION TOWARDS
ADDRESSING CONCERNS THAT WE SORT
OF ANECDOTALLY HEARD.
OVER THE YEARS RELATED -- TO THE
OFFICE OF THE STATE FIRE MARSHAL
AND DO YOU JUST WANT TO FLAG FOR
THE COMMITTEE THAT -- WHEN THIS
WAS HEARD IN THE SENATE
SUBCOMMITTEE YESTERDAY ON THE
SENATE DID REJECT THE PROPOSAL
WITHOUT PREJUDICE -- I LEAVE
JUST WANTING MORE TIME TO REALLY
HAVE THE LEGISLATURE BE ABLE
TODAY AGAIN AND I UNDERSTAND
THAT THESE SORT OF BASS
PROGRAMMATIC CHANGES -- AND SO
WHILE WE DON'T HAVE ANY CONCERNS
WITH WHAT'S BEING PROPOSED HERE
AND IT DOES APPEAR TO BE A MOVE
IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION -- IF THE
LEGISLATURE HAD MORE TIME YOU
YOU MIGHT WANT TO GO FURTHER YOU
MIGHT THINK OF MORE RESOURCES
ARE NEEDED -- LAST -- OR BEAT
WANT TO TAKE A MORE
COMPREHENSIVE VIEW OF IT AND SO
JUST ONE TO FIGHT THE SENATE
ACTION FOR YOU -- AND TO THE
EXTENT THE LEGISLATURE WANTS
MORE TIME AND YOU KNOW THE THE
MINISTRATION CAN ALWAYS BRING IT
BACK NEXT YEAR [inaudible]
THANK YOU -- FINANCE.
THE CHROME.
I WOULD JUST NOTE -- EITHER THE
PROCESS THAT WE GO THROUGH IN
CHOOSING THESE -- MISSION BASED
REVIEWS NOT JUST THIS ONE BUT IT
ABMAYBE WHERE WE'RE GOING
UNDERGOING A YOU KNOW AND
SEVERAL DIFFERENT MISSION BASED
REVIEWS OF A PROGRAMS UNDER OR
DEPARTMENTS AND THESE ARE REALLY.
CHOSEN FOR A VARIETY OF REASONS --
WHETHER THEY REFLECTS CRITICAL
NEEDS OF THE STATE OR THE
TRADITIONAL BUDGET PROCESS HAS --
YOU KNOW HASN'T BEEN ABLE TO
ADDRESS -- IN ONGOING CHALLENGES
OR THE SIGNIFICANT GENERAL FUND
IMPACT -- AND SO I WOULD I WOULD
JUST NOTE THAT -- WE REALLY AS
THE ADMINISTRATION BELIEVE THAT
THIS -- MISSION BASED REVIEW WAS
IT WAS CHOSEN FOR SEVERAL.
OF THOSE REASONS -- AND AND AND
THAT THESE THESE RESOURCES ARE
REALLY -- CRITICAL -- YOU KNOW
NOT JUST FOR THE DIVISION BUT
FOR THE STATEWIDE -- YOU KNOW
ESPECIALLY AS I MENTIONED -- DUE
TO THE NATURE OF OF THE
CONSTRUCTION BOOM THAT'S GOING
ON AND SO MUCH OF THAT WORK LIVE
FLOWING THROUGH THE DIVISION --
REALLY YOUR AIMED AT AVOIDING
CONSTRUCTION PROJECT DELAYS --
AND AND REALLY STREAMLINING SOME
OF THEIR THEIR WORK --
THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
RICHARD BLOOM A MIKE RICH WINE
ACT IN STATE FIRE MARSHAL FIND
ME AT ON THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION OF THIS PROPOSAL
THIS -- MISSION BASED BUDGET
REVIEW IT'S BEEN A VERY POSITIVE
EXPERIENCE. FOR FOR THE OFFICE
OF THE STATE FIRE MARSHAL VERY
GRATEFUL.
FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCES
TEAM COMING IN DOING A DEEP DIVE
INTO OUR MISSION AND OUR
STATUTORY AUTHORITY AND AN
OPENNESS TO RIGHT SIZE OUR
PROGRAM.
IT'S BEEN PLAGUED WITH -- WITH
STAFFING ISSUES FOR NUMBER OF
YEARS AND AND HAS RESULTED IN IN
DELAYS IN CONSTRUCTION AND AND
CONSTRUCTION COST INCREASES.
AND SO WE FEEL THIS IS THE RIGHT
APPROACH THESE POSITIONS WILL
AUGMENT OUR EXISTING STAFFING
AND PROVIDE SOME CRITICAL
RESOURCES AT A TIME WHEN IT'S
NEEDED SO WE THANK YOU FOR
CONSIDERATION.
A YOU'RE WELCOME -- LET'S MOVE
ON TO A ISSUE.
ELEVEN THANKS AGAIN
CERTIFICATION.
THANK YOU CHAIR BLOOM -- CAL
PLAYERS REQUESTING ONE POINT ONE
MILLION -- FROM OUR LICENSING
AND CERTIFICATION FIND AND FOR
POSITION STARTING IN NINETEEN
TWENTY TO SUPPORT OUR FIRE
ENGINEERING AND INVESTIGATIONS
DIVISIONS.
BUILDING MATERIALS AND FLAME
RETARDANT PROGRAM -- THIS
PROPOSAL WILL ENABLE THE TWO
PROGRAMS TO SATISFACTORY UPHOLD
OUR HEALTH AND SAFETY CODE
REGULATIONS TO CONDUCT
EVALUATIONS IMPLEMENT
INSPECTIONS AND EXECUTED MUCH
NEEDED ENFORCEMENT OPERATIONS --
FOR EXAMPLE INVESTIGATING
REPORTS OF LICENSE AND PRODUCT
FRAUD.
IN A TIMELY AND EFFICIENT MANNER.
THE THE DIVISIONAL RESOURCES
WILL BE FUNDED THROUGH
REGULATORY FEE INCREASES. TO THE
TWO PROGRAMS FEE STRUCTURES
ADDED THROUGH THIS REQUEST.
IN THESE THREE STRUCTURES HAVE
NOT BEEN UPDATED IN OVER TWO
DECADES -- SO WE CONSTANTLY GET --
REQUESTS FROM FROM INDUSTRY AND
FROM OUR EXTERNAL STAKEHOLDERS --
REQUESTING ADDITIONAL
ENFORCEMENT ACTIONS AND SO
THEY'RE VERY -- VERY MUCH
SUPPORTIVE OF OF EFFORTS TO
INCREASE STAFFING TO INCREASE
ENFORCEMENT AND I UNDERSTAND
THAT THAT COMES WITH AN
INCREASED COST.
THANK YOU OHIO DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE.
LET'S MOVE ON TO THE FINAL ISSUE --
I JUST LOVE THE TITLE OF THIS
ONE INNOVATION PROCUREMENT
SPRINT.
A GERMAN BLOOM THANK YOU AGAIN
JOE TYLER AT YOU FIRE PROTECTION
WITH CAL FIRE.
THIS MAY REVISION PROPOSAL
REQUEST FIFTEEN MILLION TO
ENABLE CAL FIRE TO PROCURE.
INNOVATIVE SOLUTIONS TO COMBAT
THE STATE'S WILDLAND FIRE CRISIS
CONSISTENT WITH EXECUTIVE ORDERS
ZERO FOUR DASH NINETEEN THAT WAS
ISSUED ON JANUARY EIGHTH TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN BY THE
GOVERNOR KNEW SOME.
OF THIS PROCESS IS SEEKING --
IDEAS AND SOLUTIONS TO HELP
MITIGATE THAT RISK THROUGH EARLY
WILDFIRE DETECTION PREDICTION A
PATH OF TRAVEL OF FIRE THAT
ALLOWS US TO USE PUBLIC
NOTIFICATIONS. TO PROVIDE
WARNINGS AND NOTIFICATIONS IN
ADVANCE OF THE FIRE TO BOTH
RESPOND HERS DECISION MAKERS AND
THE PUBLIC AT LARGE -- THE
ELEVATORS WERE -- WERE PLACED
INTO A PROCUREMENT PROCESS THAT
MY PARTNER BESIDE ME TOMAR
ARMSTRONG FROM THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF TECHNOLOGY WILL
EXPLAIN -- BUT WITH THAT -- THEY
HAVE CURRENTLY SUBMITTED --
SEVERAL IDEAS INNOVATIVE
SOLUTIONS TO AN EVALUATION PANEL
THAT IS CURRENTLY EVALUATING
THOSE WERE DUE BY.
APRIL TWENTY FIFTH TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN WITH A GOAL TO HAVE THE
EVALUATION TEAM.
ADDRESS EIGHT EIGHT ONE OR MORE
PROOF OF CONCEPT IDEAS. TO BE
LOOKED AT BETWEEN JULY AND
NOVEMBER TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN
WITH THE HOPES TO BE ABLE TO
WARD TO A CONTRACTORS SOMEBODY
WHO HAS GREAT TECHNOLOGY AND
INNOVATIVE IDEAS. TO HELP
MITIGATE THE FIRE THREATENED
CALIFORNIA BY MARCH OF TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY WITH THAT --
HELLO BUT FOR ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU I'M NOT SEEING ANY LA --
I THINK YOU'VE GOT TO SOME BRIEF
COMMENTS SURE AND THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR I'M AS AS YOU KNOW
MISTER CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS AND IT TYPICALLY A
DEPARTMENT TO WELL ALL.
AND DECIDE WHAT IT WANTS TO DO.
FIGURE OUT THE SCOPE OF THAT
PROVIDE DETAILS OF THAT HOW MUCH
IT'S GOING TO COST AND THEN COME
TO THE LEGISLATURE TO REQUEST
FUNDING -- IN THIS CASE I AM CAL
FIRE ADMINISTRATION IS TRYING A
DIFFERENT PROCUREMENT APPROACH
THAT SORT OF FLIP THINGS AROUND
AND RIGHT NOW THEY'RE ASKING FOR
MONEY BUT I HAVEN'T BEEN ABLE TO
ARTICULATE WHAT EXACTLY IT WOULD
FIND AND THAT'S JUST DUE TO THE
SORT OF CREATIVE.
NATURE OF THIS PROCUREMENT
METHOD -- RECOGNIZING THAT THERE
COULD BE POTENTIAL BENEFITS OF
THAT IT MIGHT BE SOMETHING THE
LEGISLATURE.
WANTS TO CONSIDER AND BUT WE
WOULD SORT OF NOTE THAT AND
THERE'S CONCERNS WITH THE IF YOU
GO ALONG WITH THE PROPOSAL
THERE'S PROVISIONAL BUDGET
LANGUAGE.
AND THAT HAS SOME REPORTING AND
AND WE HAVE SOME CONCERNS WITH
THAT LANGUAGE AND SPECIFICALLY
IT ALLOWS AN UNLIMITED
AUGMENTATION SO THERE'S NO CAP
ON THE AMOUNT OF FUNDING.
THAT YOU WOULD ACTUALLY BE
APPROVING IF YOU APPROVE THIS
LANGUAGE OTHERS AUGMENTATIONS
WOULD GO THROUGH A MAJOR BUDGET
ADJUSTMENT PROCESS THROUGH THE
JOINT LEGISLATIVE BUDGET
COMMITTEE WOULDN'T COME BACK.
BEFORE -- THAT THE SUBCOMMITTEE
OR THE LEGISLATURE I'M MORE
BROADLY AND SO YOU.
UNDER THE PROPOSAL YOU DON'T
QUITE HAVE A SENSE OF THE
MAGNITUDE OF WHAT YOU'RE REALLY
COMMITTING YOUR GENERAL FUND
RESOURCES.
TO HEAR AND IN ADDITION THAT
PROVISIONAL LANGUAGE DOESN'T
HAVE ANY SPECIFIC REQUIREMENTS
ABOUT THE TYPE OF INFORMATION.
THAT WILL BE PROVIDED TO THE
LEGISLATURE SO AND THIS IS AN
ONGOING PROCUREMENT PROCESS CAL
FIRE HAS RECEIVED THEY SORT OF
PUT OUT A CALL FOR IDEAS THEY'VE
RECEIVED THOSE BACK.
ON IN EVALUATING THIS OUR QUEST
I'M OUR OFFICE IN YOUR STAFF HAD
ASKED THE DEPARTMENT FOR
INFORMATION ON WHAT WHAT THE
STATUS OF THE PROCUREMENT IS HOW
MANY.
ON INNOVATORS OUR IDEAS HAVE
COME FORWARD WHAT THE SCOPE OF
THOSE IS WHAT THAT LOOKS LIKE
THE TYPES OF SOLUTIONS THE
POTENTIAL BECAUSE I'M AND
UNFORTUNATELY THE MINISTRATION
IS NOT ABLE TO PROVIDE ANY
INFORMATION ON THAT AND THEY ARE
UNDER CONFIDENTIALITY AGREEMENTS.
BEING THAT THEY ARE MIDWAY
THROUGH THE PROCUREMENT PROCESS
AND SO BUT THE LEGISLATURE IN A
DIFFICULT POSITION OF NOT REALLY
KNOWING WHAT YOU'RE BUYING FOR
THIS FIFTEEN MILLION OR FIFTEEN
MILLION PLUS.
IN FUNDING SO WE WOULD RECOMMEND
IF YOU DO WANT TO GO FORWARD
WITH THIS RECOGNIZING THERE
COULD BE SOME BENEFITS -- IT TO
MODIFY THE PROPOSED PROVISIONAL
LANGUAGE TO FIRST PUT A CAP ON
THE TOTAL LEVEL OFFENDING SO YOU
HAVE A SENSE OF WHAT YOUR YOUR
TOTAL COMMITMENT IS -- FROM THE
GENERAL FUND AND SECOND REQUIRE
THAT ALL NOTIFICATIONS THROUGH
THE JOINT LEGISLATIVE BUDGET
COMMITTEE FOR THOSE MAJOR
CHANGES BE THIRTY DAY
NOTIFICATIONS IN SOME CASES THE
EGGS THE LANGUAGE PROPOSED.
BY THE ADMINISTRATION IS A
FIFTEEN DAY NOTIFICATION WHICH
REALLY JUST DOES NOT PROVIDE
SUFFICIENT TIME FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO REVIEW --
POTENTIAL FUNDING INCREASES I
WOULD ALSO RECOMMEND THAT AND
CAO FIGHTER PROVIDE AN UPDATE TO
THE LEGISLATURE.
AND THROUGH THE JOINT
LEGISLATIVE BUDGET COMMITTEE --
ONCE THEY'RE PAST THIS INITIAL
REVIEW PERIOD AND TO GIVE A
SENSE BEFORE THEY START
COMMITTING FINDS AS HOW MANY
PROPOSALS DID THEY GET WHAT WERE
THEY TYPES SOME OF THOSE
QUESTIONS THAT WE HAVE RIGHT NOW
THAT THERE ENABLE TO ANSWER.
I'M AND THEN FOURTH AND TO
REQUIRE CAL FAIR TO PROVIDE A
DESCRIPTION AT THE OUTCOMES OF
ANY FIELD TESTING TO REALLY JUST
GIVE MORE INFORMATION TO THE
LEGISLATURE TO BRING YOU ALL
ALONG.
AND AS THIS GOES THROUGH THE
PROCESS AND RATHER THAN AN
UNLIMITED AMOUNT OF FUNDING THAT
YOU DON'T REALLY KNOW WHAT IT'S
FOR THANK YOU FOR FINANCE
CHURCHES WANT TO KNOW THAT THEY
HAD THE GOVERNOR ISSUED
EXECUTIVE ORDER AND FOR NINETEEN
AND INITIATED THE INNOVATION
PROCUREMENT SPRINT REALLY WITH
THE INTENT.
OF ADDRESSING AND THAT SORT OF
SEVERE WILDFIRE CONDITIONS THE
STATE IS FACING AND THE ENTIRE
GOAL OF THE INNOVATION
PROCUREMENT SPRINT AND THIS
PROCESS IS TO ENSURE THAT WE CAN
THE STATE CAN DEPLOY THE
WILDFIRE SOLUTIONS AS QUICKLY AS
POSSIBLE -- AND SO WE'RE SORT OF
NOT OPERATING UNDER NORMAL
CONDITIONS WERE OPERATING UNDER
VERY ABNORMAL CONDITIONS IN THE
SENSE THAT WE HAVE SORT OF A NEW
NORMAL RELATED TO THAT SORT OF
SEVERE -- AND INCREASED WILDFIRE
ACTIVITY THE NUMBER OF WILDFIRES
EXCITE ARRESTED THE ENTIRE
PROCESS IS AGAIN JUST DESIGNED
AROUND ENSURING THAT WE CAN GET
THE TECHNOLOGY ON THE GROUND AS
QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE.
AND AND AND ANY SORT OF I
CHANGES TO THE BUDGET BILL
LANGUAGE REALLY HAS THE
POTENTIAL TO CREATE DELAY IS
THAT THE TIME LINES ARE
STRUCTURED SO THAT THAT THAT
SORT OF FIVE FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS THAT ALLOCATED FOR THE
PROOF OF CONCEPT PHASE WHICH
AGAIN WE'RE JUST ASKING FOR THAT.
TO BE ABLE TO SPEND WITHIN THE
FIVE MILLION ANY.
EXPENDITURES ABOUT THAT WE WOULD
HAVE TO GO THROUGH THE
NOTIFICATION PROCESS AND THE
JAIL BC PROCESS AND WE WANT IT
DEPLOYED THOSE SOLUTIONS THIS
SUMMER AND SO THAT.
AND COMING BACK I'M SORT OF AND
ANY SORT OF ADDITIONAL
REQUIREMENTS THERE IN WOULD
DELAYED THE ABILITY TO DO THAT
AND THEN I GET A TIME LINE FOR
THAT AND THE EYES SORT OF
PROCUREMENTS OR FACE TO OF THE
PROCESS WHICH AGAIN.
AND THE DEPARTMENT OF TECHNOLOGY
CAN SPEAK TOO MUCH MORE
ELOQUENTLY THAN MYSELF AND THAT
IS ALL STRUCTURED AGAIN ON THE
BASIS OF BEING ABLE TO UTILIZE
THE RESULTS FROM THE FIELD
TESTING.
AND THEN AS QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE
ENSURE THAT WE CAN DEPLOY THAT
TECHNOLOGY THAT'S PROCURED -- IN
TIME FOR THAT FIGHT WILDFIRE
SEASON IN TWENTY TWENTY SIX AND
AND THE INTENT AND GOAL IS TO
BRING FORWARD INFORMATION
CONSISTENT WITH LIMITATIONS OF
THE PROCESS ITSELF BUT TO BE AS
TRANSPARENT AS POSSIBLE -- AND
ALSO NOTE THAT ANY ON GOING
FUNDING COMMITMENTS -- WOULD
HAVE TO COME BEFORE THE
LEGISLATURE SO THIS IS REALLY A
ONE TIME FUNDING TO INITIATE
THIS PROCESS THE OUTCOMES OF
THAT PROCESS WILL ULTIMATELY BE
BROUGHT FOR TO THE LEGISLATURE
IN THE FUTURE.
WELL WHETHER IT'S SO ONE TIME OR
ONGOING WE HAVE A
CONSTITUTIONALLY MANDATED
RESPONSIBILITY TO PROVIDE
OVERSIGHT AND AS THE STAFFORD
PORT TO WE HAVE A ONE CENT.
SAYS STAFF COMMENT THIS
PROCUREMENT PROCESS IS UNUSUAL
AND MAKES IT VERY DIFFICULT READ
IMPOSSIBLE FOR THE LEGISLATURE.
TO EVALUATE ITS MERITS -- AND I
UNDERSTAND THE INTENT HERE I
APPROVE OF THE END.
OF THE INTENT IT'S CLEARLY VERY
IMPORTANT.
YOU MENTIONED -- THIS IS
ABNORMAL AND MORE IN THE NEW
NORMAL THE WE'RE GONNA PROBABLY
GET TO A POINT WHERE WE START TO
ABUSE THOSE TERMS.
BUT IN THIS NEW NORMAL WE HAVE
TO FIND A WAY TO BOTH
ACCOMMODATE THE NEED TO MOVE
QUICKLY ON PROJECTS LIKE THIS.
AND RESPECT THE ROLE OF THE
ADMINISTRATION AND THE
LEGISLATURE IN OVERSEEING BUDGET
ITEMS LIKE THIS.
SO THIS IS KIND OF A GOOD TEST
CASE -- AND I THINK THE ALEJO
HAS A PROPOSED SOME GOOD IDEAS
ABOUT WHAT WE WANT TO THINK
ABOUT -- IN IN THE FUTURE -- SO
THAT WERE ABLE TO FULFILL ALL OF
ALL OF THE ALL ALL OF OUR
FUNCTIONS.
AND TO DO APPROPRIATELY AND
WHILE.
MS GARCIA.
THANK YOU I ALSO WANT TO ECHO
THE CONCERNS THAT THE CHAIR HAS.
MENTIONED WHEN I READ THIS I WAS
IT'S EXCITING TO SEE THAT WE'RE
THINKING OUTSIDE THE BOX AND
THAT WE ARE LIVING AND TAKING
THIS REALITY SERIOUSLY -- BUT I
THINK WE NEED TO DO IT IN A
RESPONSIBLE MANNER THAT THIS AND
SUPERSEDES -- THE WITH THE
VOTERS HAVE SENT US HERE TO DO.
ALL ALONG THE WAY IN SUCH AS
WE'D LIKE TO SEND THAT MESSAGE
TO OUR GOVERNOR ALONG THE WAY
THAT WE HAVE TO FIND A WAY TO DO
BOTH.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND NOW WILL TAKE
PUBLIC COMMENT ON ISSUE.
EIGHT NINE TEN ELEVEN TWELVE
MORNING PAUL MAY SO DOES THAT
FOREST DRESSED AS BRIEFLY WANTED
TO EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR THE
ADDITIONAL FUNDING THE BOARD OF
FORESTRY FOR THE MEDITATION
TREATMENT PLAN -- PROGRAMMATIC
THE T. P. E. I. ARE ONE OF THE
CALLING AND NOW IS AN
EXTRAORDINARILY AMBITIOUS POLL
PROPOSAL DO A PROGRAMMATIC
DOCUMENT FOR HALF A MILLION
ACRES OF AGITATION MANAGEMENT
STATE WIDE THAT.
TRYING TO THESE LONG TERM GOALS.
THEY'RE GONNA AT ALL THE LEGAL
AND TECHNICAL SUPPORT AND
FRANKLY BUILDING OF ADDITIONAL
LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT TO MAKE
SURE THE MAKING.
GOOD DECISIONS THAT ACTUALLY GET
THEM TO THAT OUTCOME BUT WE
SUPPORT THE AUGMENTATION THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND THAT
CONCLUDES -- THIS -- ITEM THANK
YOU VERY MUCH WILL HOLD ALL OF
THOSE ITEMS OPEN AND MOVE ON NOW
TO DEPARTMENT OF WATER RESOURCES
ISSUE THIRTEEN DAM SAFETY RISK
MANAGEMENT.
AND THE WELCOME I'M NOT BEING
RUDE BUT I'LL BE BACK IN A
MOMENT [inaudible]
PLEASE PROCEED.
WELL GOING TO KEEP IT SHORT --
SO GOOD MORNING CHAIR MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS ERIC
COKE I AM THE DEPUTY DIRECTOR
FOR FLOOD MANAGEMENT DAM SAFETY
FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF WATER
RESOURCES -- DELIVERS REQUESTING
SIX NEW POSITIONS AND ONE POINT
SIX TWO FIVE MILLION DOLLARS OF
ONGOING FUNDING FROM THE DâN
SAFETY FUND -- AND FORGIVENESS
OF THE REMAINING THREE YEARS OF
THE ONE POINT SIXTY FIVE MILLION
ANNUAL PAY BACK THE GENERAL FUND
LOAN MADE IN FISCAL YEAR --
TWENTY SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN IN
ORDER TO INCORPORATE THE
INDUSTRY BEST PRACTICE OF RISK
INFORMED DECISION MAKING INTO
THE CALIFORNIA DAM SAFETY
PROGRAM.
AS RECOMMENDED BY THE TECHNICAL
ADVISORY PANEL PROCESS AS
DESCRIBED IN AB -- TWELVE
SEVENTY WITH ME ASSURE AND HAPPY
AS SHE IS THE CHIEF OF THE
DIVISION OF SAFETY OF DAMS.
AND SHE CAN PROVIDE A BRIEF
OVERVIEW ON THE BENEFITS OF RISK
INFORMED.
DECISION MAKING IF YOU WOULD
LIKE HER TO DO SO OR WE COULD
JUST MOVED QUESTIONS.
LET'S JUST GO TO QUESTIONS.
AT RETAILERS WITH THE LA OUT
JUST WANT TO KNOW THAT THIS DOES
HAVE A GENERAL FUND IMPACT OF
FOUR POINT NINE MILLION DOLLARS --
IT'S BEEN SOMEWHAT INCONSISTENT
WITH THE STANDARD PRACTICE WE
HAVE A BENEFICIARY PAYS WERE DAM
OWNERS PAY FOR THE SERVICES
REGULATORY SERVICES THAT ARE
PROVIDED BY THE DEPARTMENT.
BUT GIVEN AS NOTED IN YOUR
AGENDA THEY'VE HAD A RELATIVELY
LARGE -- INCREASING THEIR FEES
IN THE PAST TWO YEARS TO
ACCOMMODATE SOME NEW REGULATORY
REQUIREMENTS -- AND THE ACTIVITY
CERTAINLY SEEM WORTHWHILE WE
THINK THAT THIS IS REASONABLE
AND THE DAM OWNERS WILL ASSUME
THAT COSTS -- AFTER THREE YEARS
ON AN ONGOING BASIS.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
OF QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
COMMENTS [inaudible]
THE HELLO [inaudible]
NEXT ITEM [inaudible]
THANK.
GOOD MORNING MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS CHRISTOPHER
TURN ALUM DEBBIE DIRECTOR AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF WATER RESOURCES --
AND OVERSEE THE INTEGRATED
WATERSHED MANAGEMENT PROGRAM FOR
THE DEPARTMENT'S PLEASURE TO BE
HERE TODAY.
AND WILL KEEP THIS PRETTY QUICK
I'M HERE -- TO SUPPORT AND TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS RELATED THE
GOVERNOR'S REQUEST FOR ROUGHLY
ONE MILLION DOLLARS ANNUALLY FOR
FOUR YEARS TO SUPPORT. TO
SUPPORT THE IMPLEMENTATION OF AB
SEVENTEEN FIFTY FIVE THE OPEN
AND TRANSPARENT -- WATER DATA
ACT -- THAT WAS PASSED IN AND
SIGNED INTO LAW IN -- TWENTY
SIXTEEN I THINK WE CAN ALL AGREE
WITH THE GENERAL STATEMENT THAT
DECISIONS ARE ONLY AS GOOD AS
THE INFORMATION THEY ARE BASED
ON AND THAT IS REALLY ALL ABOUT.
AND REALLY.
RATHER WHAT THIS BILL IS ALL
ABOUT AND CERTAINLY WHAT THE
SUCCESSFUL IMPLEMENTATION OF IT
IS ALL ABOUT -- WE'VE HIT SOME
CRITICAL MILESTONES SO FAR WHICH
IS FANTASTIC AND THE LEGISLATURE
LEGISLATION RATHER -- INCLUDES A
COUPLE OTHER MAJOR MILESTONES
LATER IN THIS YEAR -- WE'RE ON
THE HOOK FOR HAVING --
SIGNIFICANT PORTIONS OF STATE --
WATER AN ECOLOGICAL DATA
AVAILABLE I'M TO THE PUBLIC --
IN THE MANNER SET FORTH IN THE
LEGISLATION.
NEXT YEAR ON THE HOOK FOR DOING
SIMILAR -- FOR FEDERAL DATA AND
THE REQUEST THAT WERE HERE
TALKING ABOUT TODAY IS TO HELP
SUPPORT AND IMPLEMENTATION AND
SUCCESSFUL -- ACHIEVEMENT OF
THOSE ADDITIONAL MILESTONES SO
IT'S ALL ABOUT BIG DATA OPEN AND
TRANSPARENT ACCESS TO THAT
BETTER DECISION MAKING THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU HELLO YES ALTHOUGH
IT'S UNFORTUNATE THAT THE NON
STATE FUNDING SOURCES THAT WERE
ANTICIPATED FOR THIS HAVE NOT
MATERIALIZED IT IS AN IMPORTANT
STATEWIDE EFFORT AND WOULD BE
UNFORTUNATE TO LOSE THAT EFFORT
THAT'S ALREADY BEEN PUT IN AS
WELL AS THE ANTICIPATED BENEFIT
OF THE SYSTEM SO.
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES DO SEEM
NECESSARY AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU BERMAN FINANCE.
ANY PUBLIC COMMENT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
REPORT THANK YOU WILL HOLD THE
ITEM OPEN ISSUE [inaudible]
FIFTEEN UNDER A IDEA OF W. PARKS
AND REC AND NATURAL RESOURCES
AGENCY.
WELCOME BACK BRING CASH FROM THE
NATURAL RESOURCES AGENCY -- THE
MAY REVISION.
CONTAINS FORTY FIVE POINT ONE
MILLION IN CONTINUOUSLY
APPROPRIATED FUNDS FROM THAT
CANNABIS -- FROM THE CALIFORNIA
MARIJUANA TAX FUND -- THESE
THESE FUNDS COME FROM TWO
DIFFERENT ALLOCATIONS WITHIN THE
THE STATUTE -- FIVE POINT THREE
MILLION IS GOING TO COMMUNITY
ACCESS PROJECTS.
AND THEN THIRTY NINE POINT EIGHT
MILLION WILL BE GOING TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF WATER DEPARTMENT
OF FISH AND WILDLIFE AND
DEPARTMENT PARKS AND RECREATION --
TWENTY THREE POINT NINE MILLION
TO FISH AND WILDLIFE AND FIFTEEN
POINT.
NINE TO PARKS.
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME TO CHECK ON
GOOD TO SEE YOU BE BRIEF.
MY NAME'S JEFF ON AMONG THE
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND WILDLIFE
YOU ASKED TWO QUESTIONS IN THE
AGENDA.
FIRST HOW WITH THE DEPARTMENT
USE THE SEVENTY NINE POSITIONS.
WE DIVIDE THEM AND WOULD SEND
ABOUT THIRTEEN POSITIONS INTO
OUR BIOLOGICAL AND SCIENCE
COMPONENT OF OUR MULTI
DISCIPLINARY EFFORT.
EXCUSE ME FORTY SEVEN POSITIONS
THAT WAY AND WE'D SEND ABOUT
THIRTY TWO POSITIONS INTO OUR
LAW ENFORCEMENT DIVISION.
WITH SPLIT THE TWENTY THREE
MILLION DOLLARS THIS WAY.
ABOUT THIRTEEN POINT FOUR
MILLION WOULD SUPPORT THE
SCIENCE SIDE.
IN ABOUT TEN POINT FIVE MILLION
WOULD SUPPORT THE ENFORCEMENT
SIDE.
THE SECOND QUESTION YOU ASK IS
HOW WE COLLABORATE MY ANSWER IS
VERY WELL.
FROM COUNTY PLANNING COMMISSIONS
THROUGH COUNTY SUPERVISORS
THROUGH LOCAL SHERIFFS -- WE
HAVE A SERIES OF MEMORANDUMS OF
UNDERSTANDING WITH THE GUARD.
AND WITH A VARIETY OF FEDERAL
AGENCIES ALL OF WHICH ARE ABOUT
COORDINATING ACTIVITIES. TO DEAL
WITH TRESPASS ON PUBLIC LANDS
AND ILLEGAL CANNABIS CULTIVATION
AT A CARTEL LEVEL.
AND WITH THAT I WOULD TURN OVER
TO MY COLLEAGUE AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF PARKS.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR LEASE
MARKET -- DIRECTOR OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF PARKS AND
RECREATION -- I THINK A COUPLE
OF THINGS THAT I WOULD SAY TO
COME TO DISTINGUISH THE
RESOURCES THAT ARE BEING
REQUESTED FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
PARKS AND RECREATION.
FROM MY COLLEAGUE -- DIRECTOR
BONHAM IS THAT THESE RESOURCES --
THE FIFTEEN POINT NINE MILLION
THE FIFTY THREE POSITIONS WOULD
BE FOCUSING ON THE OVER ONE
POINT FIVE MILLION.
ACRES OF STATE PARKS PROPERTY --
ALSO THIS IS THE FIRST TIME THAT
THE DEPARTMENT OF PARKS AND
RECREATION HAS DESIGNATED
RESOURCES FOR THESE ACTIVITIES --
IN TERMS OF THE POSITIONS THAT
WERE FILLING IT'S REALLY A MULTI
DISCIPLINARY TEAM IT'S A
COMBINATION OF LAW ENFORCEMENT
MAINTENANCE WORKERS TO FIGURE
OUT THE TRAILS MOST OF THESE --
ILLEGAL GROWS THAT WE HAVE
DISCOVERED IN THE PAST OR IN
SOME OF THE MOST REMOTE PLACES
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
ALONG WITH ENVIRONMENTAL
SCIENTIST ARCHEOLOGIST BECAUSE
AS WE DO THE IMPORTANT
RESTORATION WORK THAT'S
NECESSARY HERE -- WE'RE GOING TO
NEED A MULTI DISCIPLINARY TEAM
TO THINK ABOUT THE IMPACT OF THE
CHANGES TO THE WATER SAID WHAT
IT MEANS TO OUR REDWOOD FORESTS --
CULTURAL -- IN ALL OF THOSE
IMPORTANT THINGS AS WE AS WE
MOVE TOWARDS A REBUILT -- I ALSO
WOULD SAY THAT ALONG WITH -- I
WOULD ECHO DIRECTOR BONHAM
SENTIMENTS THAT I THINK WERE
MOST SUCCESSFUL WHEN WE CONTINUE
TO WORKING KEEP CLOSE OUR ALLIED
LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES ON THE
FIELD -- AND WE ALSO EXPECT I
EXPECT -- OUR TEAM AT PARKS TO
CONTINUE TO COLLABORATE AND WORK
WITH FISH AND WILDLIFE TO MAKE
SURE THAT OUR TEAMS ARE
COMMUNICATING DISSEMINATING BEST
PRACTICES WE ALSO HAVE DEVELOPED
OUR PROPOSAL PARTLY INFORMED BY.
SOME OF THE EXPERTISE OF THE
NATIONAL PARK SERVICE THAT HAS --
KIND OF LEANED ON SOMEBODY'S
GROWS IN THE PAST.
AB SO THERE'S RELATIVELY LIMITED
LEGISLATIVE ROLE IN THIS BECAUSE
OF THE WAY THE PROPOSITION WAS
STRUCTURED THROUGH A HAVING A
CONTINUOUSLY APPROPRIATED FUNDS
BUT I BECAUSE IT IS A BAD MAN
NEW EFFORT AN EXPANDED EFFORT.
WHENEVER WROTE -- RECOMMENDING
FORMAL REPORTING REQUIREMENTS AT
THIS POINT BUT IT IS SOMETHING
YOU MAY WANT TO THINK ABOUT IN
THE COMING MONTHS AND YEARS
HAVING THAT APARTMENTS COME BACK
AND EXPLAIN HOW THE FUNDS ARE
BEING SPENT WHAT THEY'RE
LEARNING WHAT'S AFFECTED HOW
THEY'RE ADAPTING AND KIND OF A
PRIMARY FOR LEGISLATIVE.
OVERSIGHT HERE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
FINANCE THING -- ALL RIGHT WELL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE
PRESENTATION IS THERE ANY PUBLIC
COMMENT.
TO WE WERE ON A STREAK SIR.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN OF THE
COMMITTEE OF FEDERAL NO HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE NATURE CONSERVANCY --
REALLY VERY SUPPORTIVE OF THE
PROPOSED -- PREPARATION HERE
FROM PROP SIXTY FOUR FOR THE THE
RESTORATION AND AND AND
MITIGATION OF OUR MIDDLE IMPACTS
OF ILLEGAL CULTIVATION OF
MARIJUANA -- ON OUR PUBLIC LANDS --
CFW FOR JUST FIVE YEARS AGO
RELEASED A REALLY DETAILED
REPORT OUTLINING OVER A BILLION
DOLLARS WORTH OF IMPACTS ALREADY
TO OUR PUBLIC LANDS. TO OUR
RIVERS AND STREAMS AND KNOW THAT
THIS IS A REALLY CRITICAL.
COMPONENT TO HOW WE IMPLEMENT
PROPERLY PROP SIXTY FOUR TO THE
TUNE TRENT AND TO THE TRUE
INTENT OF WHAT THE VOTERS
SUPPORTED.
WHEN IT WAS ON THE BALLOT -- THE
LAST THING I WOULD MENTION
THOUGH IS -- AS IT RELATES TO
SOME OF THE MYSTICAL EXEMPTIONS
I THINK THERE NEEDS TO BE SOME
THOUGHT ABOUT AND MAKING SURE
NOT TO BROAD -- AS ALTERNATELY
THAT MAY END UP HINDERING OUR
ABILITY TO STAY TRUE TO THE THE
PUBLIC HEALTH AND AND PUBLIC
RESOURCE -- BENEFITS THAT WE'RE
TRYING TO TO GET AT IN THE FIRST
PLACE -- AND HAVE ALSO BEEN
ASKED TO ALIGN MY MY COMMENTS ON
BEHALF OF BOTTOM LINE CALIFORNIA
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND WE HAVE
ONE MORE COMMENT.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS PAT RAN OUT
THERE AND READING ASSOCIATES
REPRESENT THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF PROFESSIONAL
SCIENTISTS.
VERY SUPPORTIVE OF THE PROPOSAL
IN KIRCHER -- AYE VOTE WHEN YOU --
THE TAKE THIS UP AND VOTE ON IT --
WE REPRESENT THE SCIENTISTS WHO
WHO DO THIS WORK IN -- THESE
DEPARTMENTS.
AND WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR COME
THANK YOU FOR THE TIME.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- IN NO WAY
DO I WANT TO MAKE LIGHT OF OF
THIS ISSUE IT'S ONE THAT HAS
PERSISTED FOR A VERY LONG TIME
NOW IT'S GOOD TO SEE THAT --
THERE'S A SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF
MONEY BEING PUT INTO -- AT A AT
ADDRESSING THE VARIOUS ISSUES
WITH -- WITH ILLEGAL GROWS -- AT
IN FACT IT JUST IT SEEMS TO ME
THAT WERE ONLY SCRATCHING THE
SURFACE HERE GIVEN THE EXTENT OF
THE PROBLEM SO HOPEFULLY WE'LL
START HERE -- MAKE SOME PROGRESS
AND THEN CONTINUE -- TO MAKES
PROGRAM STRONGER.
THANK YOU THANK YOU -- WILL WE
STILL HAVE A DOZEN ISSUES LET
FOLKS -- ISSUE -- SIXTEEN UNDER --
DFW IS THE SCAN LAND RESTORATION
PLEASE YES CHAIR AGAIN MY NAME
IS CHUCK BONHAM ON THE DIRECTOR
OF THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
FISH WILDLIFE.
EACH BUDGET ITEM FOR ME IS A
SERIOUS ONE THIS IS PARTICULAR
SERIOUS -- BACK IN JUNE OF TWO
THOUSAND SIXTEEN A WILDFIRE
OCCURRED IN THE LAKE ISABELLA
AREA WHICH I BELIEVE IS IN MR
FUNG'S DISTRICT.
IT'S KNOWN AS THE SCAN FIRE THAT
DESTROYED OVER THREE HUNDRED
STRUCTURES AND WE HAD TO
FIDELITY'S WHICH IS TRAGIC.
THAT FIRE OCCURRED ON PROPERTY
OUR DEPARTMENT LEASES FROM THE
UNITED STATES DEPARTMENT OF THE
INTERIOR BUREAU OF LAND
MANAGEMENT.
WHICH WE IN TURN SUBLEASE -- TO
LOCAL NONPROFIT CALLED THE THE
ARCHERS ASSOCIATION THE KERN
RIVER ARCHERS.
ALL OF THESE ARRANGEMENTS
PREDATE EACH ONE OF US IN THIS
ROOM THEY WERE ESTABLISHED BACK
IN THE NINETEEN EIGHTIES.
TODAY WE ASK FOR THREE HUNDRED
AND TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS
OF GENERAL FUND. TO DO SOMETHING
VERY PRECISE.
CLEAN UP THE PROPERTY --
RESTORED TO THE CONDITION --
THAT ALLOWS US TO TERMINATE THE
CONTRACT.
WITH THE UNITED STATES A
PROVISION OF THE CONTRACT
REQUIRES THAT WE SURRENDER THE
PREMISES IN GOOD CONDITION.
THE BUREAU OF LAND MANAGEMENT
HAS TOLD US THEY WON'T TAKE THE
LAND BACK UNTIL WE RESTORE IT.
THIS MONEY WILL BE SPENT TO
RESTORE THE LAND.
WE WILL SEND IT BACK TO THE
UNITED STATES WILL STEP OUT OF
THIS ARRANGEMENT AND TERMINATE
THE CONTRACT WHICH IS THE SMART.
APPROPRIATE RISK MANAGEMENT
STRATEGY FOR THE STATE
[inaudible]
THANK YOU -- L. L. NO.
AND NO QUESTIONS SIR AS OR ANY
PUBLIC COMMENT ON ISSUE.
SIXTEEN SEEING NONE.
WILL HOLD THIS OPEN AND TO WE
NOW HAVE THREE ISSUES WITH
DEPARTMENT OF PARKS AND REC.
ISSUE SEVENTY IS PUBLIC SAFETY
EMERGENCY RESPONSE [inaudible]
WELCOME BACK.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR -- THIS
PROPOSAL'S A REQUEST FOR A ONE
TIME GENERAL FUND FOR THREE
POINT NINE MILLION DOLLARS TO
PURCHASE EQUIPMENT THAT WILL
ENHANCE.
THE DEPARTMENT'S EMERGENCY
RESPONSE EFFORTS I'M PRIMARILY
GOING TOWARDS UPDATING ON USING
NEW TECHNOLOGY FOR RADIOS AND
ALSO A COUPLE OF TRAILERS --
ALONG WITH SOME OTHER EQUIPMENT
I WOULD NOTE THAT IN DEVELOPING
THIS PROPOSAL WE WORK CLOSELY
WITH.
THE STATE OFFICE OF EMERGENCY
SERVICES TO MAKE SURE THAT IT
ENHANCE THE STATE'S WRITING ASSN
WASN'T DUPLICATIVE OF EXISTING
RESOURCES [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT THERE'S NO ADDITIONAL
COMMENTS AND THERE'S NO ONE LEFT
TO ASK QUESTIONS OTHER THAN ME.
I WILL REFRAIN -- IS THERE -- I
I WOULD SAY THIS IS A AGAIN THIS
IS IMPORTANT TO A FUNDING EVEN
THOUGH IT'S A RELATIVELY SMALL
AMOUNTS FOR AN IMPORTANT PURPOSE
AND WILL HOLD IT OPEN BUT I'M
SURE OF THE NIGHTLY IT'S GOING
TO BE APPROVED -- ISSUE EIGHTEEN
WHILE PART RIPARIAN REIMBURSED.
YES THIS IS SEVEN POINT NINE
MILLION DOLLARS IN GENERAL FUND
IN TWO POINT EIGHT MILLION AND
REIMBURSEMENT RETORTED FOR THE
STATE PARKS AND RECREATION FUND --
THESE FUNDS WOULD BE DEDICATED
TO RECOVERY PROJECTS PRIMARILY
TARGETING.
THE DAMAGE THAT WAS RESULTING IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA FROM THE
WALLS THE FIRE ON THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S SPOKE A
LITTLE EARLIER ON THIS ON A
RELATED PROPOSAL FOR ANOTHER
DEPARTMENT -- HOPING TO HAVE
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION FROM US
ON THE INDIVIDUAL PROJECTS AND
WE'VE COMMITTED TO GETTING THAT
TO HIM TO THEM TODAY.
INTO YOUR STUFF THANK YOU.
HELLO I'M THE THIS WHEN I'M DOES
DIFFER SOMEWHAT FROM THAT SANTA
MONICA MOUNTAINS CONSERVANCY
PROPOSAL WHERE IS AND THIS ONE
IS ACTUALLY A MULTI YOUR
PROPOSAL SO THIS IS JUST THE
FIRST YEAR.
SOME OF THE FUNDING HERE WOULD
BE TO DO AN ASSESSMENT OF WHAT
THE DAMAGES WHAT THE NEEDS ARE
AND THEN SOME OF THE FUNDING
WOULD BE TO AND TAKE CARE OF
SIGN.
ON INITIAL SET OF PROJECTS THAT
HAVE BEEN IDENTIFIED -- BUT WE
DO RECOMMEND THAT THE
LEGISLATURE AND SEEK AT THAT
LIST OF PROJECTS AND MORE
SPECIFICALLY HOW THE FUNDS WOULD
BE SPENT BEFORE YOU APPROVE ANY
MONEY FOR IT.
AND IT WAS CLEARLY.
TAKING CARE OF THIS DAMAGE AND
AND MAKING REPAIRS IS IS NEEDED
AND AND IS A REASONABLE THING TO
DO BUT YOU'RE GOING TO WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT -- THE LIST OF
PROJECTS -- LINES UP WITH AND
WITH WHAT YOUR PRIORITIES ARE
WITH WHITE AND FOLKS ARE GETTING
FROM THERE THEIR DISTRICTS AND
THAT THE COMMUNITY THINKS I'M IS
A PRIORITY AS WELL.
I WOULD JUST NOTE THAT GIVEN THE
TIMING OF THE MAY REVISION AND
WHILE THE DIRECTORS INDICATED
THAT LIST OF PROJECTS IS
FORTHCOMING AND THAT WITH
LIMITED TIME THE SENATE
YESTERDAY DID APPROVE
SUPPLEMENTAL REPORT LANGUAGE --
REQUIRING THAT LATEST AD TO BE
PROVIDED AND SO YOU MAY OR MAY
WILL NOT WANT TO CONSIDER THAT
JUST DEPENDING ON WHEN THE
INFORMATION'S PROVIDED RELATIVE
TO WHEN YOU BRING THIS ITEM BACK
FOR ABOUT.
THANK YOU -- I DON'T IMAGINE OF
FINANCE AS A REPORT.
THAT AND WHEN WE A MOVE ON TO
ISSUED IN. NINETEEN NINE
WATERCRAFT THIS GOT A LITTLE BIT
COMPLICATED BUT HOPING YOU'LL BE
ABLE TO DISTILL IT DOWN.
FOR THE GOVERNOR'S JANUARY
BUDGET ASSUMES THE RECEIPT OF
EIGHTY MILLION DOLLARS IN
REVENUE TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
PARKS AND RECREATION -- TO
SUPPORT ITS VARIOUS PROGRAMS --
SINCE THAT TIME CONTROL AGENCIES
HAVE REFINED THE FORMULA THAT
DETERMINED -- THE LEVEL OF
FUNDING THAT WOULD BE DEPOSITED
INTO SOME OF THE SPECIAL FUNDS
FOR THE DEPARTMENT.
UNDER THIS PROPOSAL IT WOULD
BACK FILL THE REDUCTION OF THOSE
FUNDS TO MAINTAIN THE CURRENT
SPENDING PLAN AND THE COMMITMENT
TO THE FIX OUR PARKS PROPOSAL
THAT WAS.
APPROVED BY THIS BODY LAST YEAR.
GREAT LA A A A YOU HAVE A COUPLE
COMEDY YEAH IT IS THIS IS SORT
OF A VERY UNFORTUNATE SITUATION
SO AND AS YOU'RE AWARE OF MISTER
CHAIR.
THAT IS STATE PARKS AND
RECREATION IT FINDER SPUR AND
HAD A LONG HAD SORT OF A HISTORY
AS A FUNDING DOWN AND STRUCTURAL
IMBALANCE IN THE FIND.
ON THE SP ONE REVENUES THROUGH
THE TRANSPORTATION AND FUNDING
PACKAGE -- SOMEWHERE I EAT
ADDRESS THAT TIME IS SHORT UP
THE FIND AND ALSO PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL FINDS OUT FOR PARKS
TO UNDERTAKE NEW ACTIVITIES AND
INCLUDING WHAT WAS REFERENCE BY
THE DOCTOR READY AND APPROVED IN
THE CURRENT YEAR.
I'VE AND FORTUNATELY THE AMOUNT
OF REVENUES THAT IS TO BE
RECEIVED BY SPUR OF AS WELL AS
THE HARBORS AND WATERCRAFT AND
IT WAS.
OVER ESTIMATED IN THE ACTUAL
REVENUES AND THE RESERVE S.
MEETING ERROR AND WHAT WHAT IS
ACTUALLY BEING RECEIVED BY THOSE
PLANS IS SOMEWHAT LESS.
ON THE PROPOSAL HERE FIRST BIRTH
IS TO I'M SURE UP THE FRIEND I
WITH THAT THIRTY FIVE POINT
SEVEN MILLION DOLLAR ONE TIME
TRANSFER FROM THE GENERAL FUND.
AND THEN TO HAVE A NINE POINT
SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS ANNUAL ON
GOING TRANSFER FROM THE GENERAL
FUND IN ORDER TO MAINTAIN THE
LEVEL PROGRAMMATIC EXPENDITURES.
THAT WERE AUTHORIZED IN THE
CURRENT YEAR AND RECOGNIZING
THAT THAT'S A PARTY FOR THE
LEGISLATURE IN SOMETHING THAT
YOU'RE APPROVED -- WOULD YOU
JUST WANT TO FLAG FOR YOU IT IS
ALSO AN OPTION FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO LOOK AT BRINGING
DOWN THOSE EXPENDITURE LEVEL
SOME WHITE IF YOU WANT TO BRING
IT MORE IN LINE WITH WHERE THE
ACTUAL REVENUES ARE.
ESPECIALLY JUST GIVEN HOW
RECENTLY AND THIS AUGMENTATIONS
WERE MADE IN THE CURRENT YEAR
I'M ALSO ONE OF FLAG FOR YOU ON
THE HARBORS AND WATERCRAFT FIND
AND THE PROPOSED SOLUTION HERE
IS ONE TIME.
AT THE END SO WE'LL BE LOOKING
FOR THE ADMINISTRATION TO COME
BACK WITH AN ON GOING SOLUTION
TO THAT FINE AND NEXT YEAR AND
IF THEY DO END UP GOING THE SAME
APPROACH OF BACK FILLING WITH
THE GENERAL FUND THEN YOUR
GENERAL FUND COMMITMENT.
COULD BE I'M COULD BE HIGHER --
AND THE SHORTFALL NOT FINISHED
ACTUALLY LARGER THAN THE
SHORTFALL ON THIS BIRTH.
THANK YOU WILL TAKE THOSE
COMMENTS INTO CONSIDERATION --
UP THAT HOLD THIS ITEM OPEN --
AS WITH THE OTHER TWO IS THERE
ANY PUBLIC COMMENT ON ISSUE
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN OR NINETEEN
SEEING NONE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
NEXT UP STATE WATER RESOURCES
CONTROL BOARD ISSUES TWENTY AND
TWENTY ONE ISSUE TWENTY IS THE
EMERGENCY RESPONSE PROGRAMME.
A GOOD MORNING -- GOOD AFTERNOON
MISTER CHAIR OF MY NAME IS
EILEEN SO BACK ON THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE STATE WATER
RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD -- THE
EMERGENCY PREPAREDNESS.
AND RESPONSE PROGRAMS REQUEST
THAT WE HAVE IS FOR ONE POINT
ONE MILLION DOLLARS FOR SUPPORT
OF SIX PROMINENT POSITIONS. TO
ESTABLISH AN EMERGENCY
PREPAREDNESS AND RESPONSE UNIT
WHICH IS NEEDED TO IMPROVE THE
CAPABILITIES OF THE BOTH THE
STATE WATER BOARD AND THE NINE
REGIONAL WATER QUALITY CONTROL
BOARD -- THERE NEEDED -- TO
PREPARE FOR AND RESPOND TO
DISASTERS MORE EFFECTIVELY
SUPPORT ON GOING TO SASTRE
RECOVERY EFFORTS. TO IMPROVE
STATE COORDINATION AROUND
PROTECTION OF DRINKING WATER
SYSTEMS AND WATERSHED ON HEALTH
AND ALSO TO MORE AGGRESSIVELY --
ENABLE US TO GO AFTER FEDERAL
FUNDING FOR RECOVERY
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
OHIO.
ALL RIGHT -- LET'S -- THAN --
MOVE ON TO THE NEXT ISSUE INYO
COUNTY PRIVACY DELEGATION
REPLICATION.
FULLER YES THANK YOU -- BUT SO
YOU'LL KEEP IT SHORT YES I WILL --
SO.
OUR PROPOSAL REQUEST THREE
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY SIX THOUSAND
DOLLARS AND TWO POSITIONS FOR
THE WATER BOARD TO ASSUME
REGULATORY RESPONSIBILITY. FOR
THE FEDERAL SAFE DRINKING WATER
ACT REQUIREMENTS IN INYO COUNTY --
IF THE WE GENERALLY IF THE
COUNTY WANTS TO DELEGATE PRIMACY --
TO TO COUNTIES TO REGULATE
SYSTEMS BELOW TWO HUNDRED
SERVICE CONNECTIONS.
BUT INYO COUNTY HAS BEEN UNABLE
TO REMAIN IN COMPLIANCE SO IN
FEBRUARY -- TWO THOUSAND NINE
THE WATER BOARD -- INFORM TO THE
COUNTY THAT IT FAILED TO MEET
REQUIREMENTS UNDER ITS
DELEGATION AGREEMENT IT'S NOW
BEEN REVOKED IF WE DON'T IF
WE'RE DEEMED NOT TO BE
PROTECTING THE PUBLIC AND HEALTH
AND SAFETY OF DRINKING WATER
SYSTEMS BY USEPA IF IT
JEOPARDIZES THE FEDERAL FUNDING
THAT WE RECEIVE AS A STATE. FOR
OUR DRINKING WATER PROGRAM SO
WE'RE REQUESTING THESE TWO
POSITIONS TO SUPPORT THE TAKING
OVER THE THE REGULATORY
OVERSIGHT OF INYO COUNTY.
THANK YOU IS -- LA A REPORT ON
THIS -- IS THERE PUBLIC COMMENT
ON EITHER OF THESE ITEMS ISSUES
TWENTY OR TWENTY ONE THERE ISN'T
SO YOU'RE FREE TO GO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR PRESENTATION
THIS MORNING -- NEXT UP IS THE
AIR RESOURCES BOARD.
IF YOU'RE TWENTY TWO WILL TAKE
UP PUBLIC COMMENT AGAIN AFTER
ISSUE.
TWENTY THREE GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIRMAN LIMóN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE I'M AT CHIANG MAI
DEPUTY EXECUTIVE OFFICER AT THE
AIR RESOURCES BOARD.
SO WE HAVE TO MAY REVISED
PROPOSALS THAT YOU'LL BE HEARING
TODAY BOTH OF THEM ADDRESS
DIESEL POLLUTION WHICH IS THE
NUMBER ONE SOURCE OF AIR TOXICS
IN THE STATE.
AND BOTH OF THEM ALSO INCLUDE
FEE COMPONENTS TO ENSURE THAT AS
WE IMPLEMENT OUR PROGRAMS WERE
DOING SO IN A FISCALLY
SUSTAINABLE AND PRUDENT MANNER.
SO IN THIS FIRST PROPOSAL IN
FRONT OF YOU.
WE'RE REQUESTING ONE POINT THREE
TO SIX MILLION DOLLARS FROM THE
AIR POLLUTION CONTROL FUND FOR
SEVEN FULL TIME POSITIONS TO
PERFORM APPROVALS OF NEW
TECHNOLOGIES IN THE FREIGHT
SECTOR.
ON EXISTING REGULATIONS AND
INCENTIVE PROGRAMS SPECIFY THAT
WE HAVE TO IMPROVE ZERO EMISSION
OR INNOVATIVE TECHNOLOGIES PRIOR
TO THEM BEING DEPLOYED.
SO WE WANT TO BASICALLY MAKE
SURE THAT WE CERTIFY OR VERIFY
THEM BEFORE WE SPEND MONEY ON
THEM OR REQUIRE INDUSTRY TO USE
THEM.
IN THE PAST RITUALLY ALL OF THE
EQUIPMENT THAT WE CERTIFIED
THEIR COMBUSTION ENGINES SO
WHETHER THEY'RE IN CARS OR
TRUCKS OR EQUIPMENT IT'S MOSTLY
ENGINES.
BUT TECHNOLOGY AND OUR PROGRAMS
HAVE SHIFTED -- TO HAVE A
GREATER INTEREST AND
REQUIREMENTS FOR ZERO EMISSION
AND INNOVATIVE TECHNOLOGIES TO
REDUCE EMISSIONS AND PROTECT
PUBLIC HEALTH.
RIGHT NOW THERE ARE NO
ESTABLISHED APPROVAL PROCEDURES
FOR THESE TYPES OF EQUIPMENT AND
THIS VCP BASICALLY PROVIDES THE
NECESSARY RESOURCES FOR US TO
MAKE SURE THAT THIS --
INNOVATIVE TECHNOLOGY IS
IMPLEMENTED.
THE AIR POLLUTION CONTROL FUND
WOULD INITIALLY FUND THESE
POSITIONS UNTIL FEES CAN BE
COLLECTED TO PROVIDE ONGOING
SUPPORT FOR THE PROGRAM.
AMBER REQUESTING THESE POSITIONS
TO BEGAN IN FISCAL YEAR NINETEEN
TWENTY IN ADVANCE OF THE FEES
BECAUSE QUITE FRANKLY WE WANT TO
GET THIS EQUIPMENT OUT AS SOON
AS POSSIBLE WE'VE GOT INCENTIVE
PROGRAMS THAT ARE RUNNING AS
WELL AS REGULATORY REQUIREMENTS.
SO WITH THAT I'D BE HAPPY TO
TAKE ANY QUESTIONS -- YOUR
BUILDING OUT A NEW TESTING
FACILITY DOWN AND IS A POMONA IN
RIVERSIDE REVERSED IN RIVERSIDE
YES WE'RE BUILDING A NEW
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA HEADQUARTERS
AND AND WILL THIS -- TAKE PLACE
IN THAT LOCATION OR WILL THEY BE
HAD FOR MOST OF THE WORK THAT
WE'RE GONNA BE DOING RELATED TO
THESE KINDS OF THINGS ARE
ACTUALLY.
CERTIFICATIONS THAT WE WOULD --
THAT TECHNOLOGY DEVELOPER WOULD
DO TESTING THEY FREQUENTLY A
CONTRACT FOR THAT TESTING AND WE
WORK WITH THEM OR ESTABLISH
PROCEDURES ON THE KINDS OF
TESTING THAT ARE DONE.
AND THEN WE WOULD EVALUATE THAT
TESTING SO IT'S MORE OF A PAPER
EXERCISE THAN THINGS THAT WE'RE
TESTING IN THE LAB AND I'LL GIVE
YOU AN EXAMPLE ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT WE'VE TESTED UNDER THESE
PROGRAMS IS.
AND A NEW WAY FOR PEOPLE TO
CONTROL EMISSIONS FROM SHIPS SO
WHEN SHIPS COME IN AND WE DON'T
WANT THEM TO RUN THEIR ENGINES
BECAUSE THEY'RE REALLY DIRTY SO
WE LIKE THEM TO PLAY AGAIN.
THAT'S NOT ALWAYS POSSIBLE FOR
INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDS AND OTHER
THINGS SO FOLKS HAVE DEVELOPED A
SYSTEM AND WE COLLOQUIALLY
QUALITY THE BONNET.
SO IT BASICALLY IS A BIG BONNET
THAT SITS OVER THAT SINCE THE
SMOKESTACK ON THE SHIP IN IT
SUCKS UP THE EMISSIONS.
SO THAT SOMETHING THAT YOU KNOW
THE TESTING FOR THAT CAN'T
HAPPEN IN OUR LAB IT HAPPENS ON
SITE WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THE
PROCEDURES ARE CRACKED AND
EVERYONE KNOWS WHAT THEY NEED TO
DO BEFORE HAND.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- LA --
FINANCE.
QUESTIONS FROM THE DíAS.
NEXT ISSUE.
OKAY SECOND ISSUE -- THIS IS
FACE TO GREENHOUSE GASES WE'RE
REQUESTING ONE POINT NINE
MILLION DOLLARS FROM THE AIR
POLLUTION CONTROL FUNDS AND TEN
POSITIONS PHASED IN OVER THREE
YEARS. TO REVIEW AND CERTIFIED
MEDIUM AND HEAVY DUTY ENGINES
VEHICLES AND TRAILERS TO NEW
FACE TO REGULATIONS -- YOU WILL
NOT BE SURPRISED THAT THESE ARE
THE SECOND PHASE OF GREENHOUSE
GAS EMISSIONS STANDARDS THAT WE
ADOPTED IN COORDINATION WITH
USEPA.
AND THE STANDARDS GOING TO
REDUCE GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS
BY ABOUT A THIRD OF MY TWENTY
FIFTY WHILE ALSO REDUCING SMOG
FORMING AN AIR TOXIC EMISSIONS.
SO THERE'S TWO MAIN REASONS WE
NEED ADDITIONAL RESOURCES FOR
THIS REGULATION THE FIRST IS THE
ENGINES THATARE MEETING THE
STANDARD ARE MUCH MORE
COMPLICATED THAN THE ENGINES
MEETING THE PHASE ONE STANDARD.
AND ARE STE OUR REQUIREMENTS FOR
DATA AND DOCUMENTATION HAVE
INCREASED SO THINK ABOUT WHAT
HAPPENED WITH THE W. WITH FIAT
CHRYSLER WERE.
WERE AMPING UP WHAT WE WANT ON
FROM FACE TO ALSO INCLUDES
GREENHOUSE GAS STANDARDS FOR
TRAILERS AND FOR THE FIRST TIME
WE'RE DEVELOPING NEW
CERTIFICATIONS AT PROCESS FOR
TRAILERS WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO DO
PROBABLY ABOUT A HUNDRED
CERTIFICATIONS A YEAR.
SO THE SECOND REASON THAT WE
NEED MORE RESOURCES IS FOR THE
PHASE ONE STANDARDS BASICALLY WE
HAD A PROCESS THAT IF YOU COULD
WERE CERTIFIED FOR U. S. E. P.
TO USEPA WE DEEM DO YOU TO
COMPLY WITH THE CALIFORNIA
STANDARDS.
IN THE FACE TO PROGRAM WERE
TAKING A MORE ACTIVE ROLE IN
THIS WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
THE REGULATION IS IMPLEMENTED
THE WAY THAT IT'S WRITTEN.
AND SO WE NEED MORE RESOURCES
FOR THAT.
AN IMPORTANT ELEMENT OF THIS B.
C. P. IS THE PROPOSED TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE TO ALLOW US TO
COLLECT CERTIFICATION FEES. FOR
ON ROAD VEHICLES AND ENGINES
RIGHT NOW THE TOTAL AMOUNT OF
FINES THAT WE CAN COLLECT FOR
OUR ON ROUTE CERTIFICATION
ACTIVITIES IS CAPPED AT NINE
POINT SIX MILLION DOLLARS IN.
TWENTY EIGHTEEN SO WHAT THIS
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE DOES IS IT
REMOVES IS IT REMOVES THE CAP.
IT ALLOWS US TO SET UP A SAYS
FEES FOR THE CERTIFICATION OF
TRAILERS.
AND IT DIRECTS THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THESE FEES TO
A NEW FUNDS CALL THE
CERTIFICATION AND COMPLIANCE
FUND.
SO WITH THIS TRAILER BILL IS
APPROVED WE WILL BEGIN THE
PROCESS TO ESTABLISH FEES TO
COVER THE FACE TO GREENHOUSE GAS
PROGRAM.
AS WELL AS UNDER ON ROAD
CERTIFICATION PROGRAMS.
ALL OF THESE RULE MAKINGS WOULD
GO THROUGH OUR NORMAL PUBLIC
STAKEHOLDER PROCESS.
AND WE EXPECT THE TOTAL AMOUNT
OF FEES COLLECTED TO BE
COMMENSURATE WITH WHITE USEPA
COLLECTS FOR CERTIFICATION.
THANK YOU THANK YOU LA --
FINANCE NO COMMENTS QUESTIONS IS
THERE ANY PUBLIC COMMENT ON
ISSUES TWENTY TWO OR TWENTY
THREE THERE IS NONE THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE
PRESENTATION WILL HOLD THESE
ITEMS OPEN.
UP NEXT IS ISSUE TWENTY FOUR
UNDER DEPARTMENT OF PESTICIDE
REGULATION REGULATION AND A
DEPARTMENT OF FOOD AND
AGRICULTURE.
GOOD MORNING GOOD AFTERNOON.
GOOD AFTERNOON.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE -- MY NAME IS
THERESA MARKS ON THE ACTING
DIRECTOR OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
PESTICIDE REGULATION -- WERE
HERE BEFORE YOU TODAY TO TALK
WITH YOU ABOUT A PLAN THAT WE
HAVE MOVING FORWARD AS YOU'RE
MOST LIKELY AWARE -- THE KELLY
K. SECRETARY AND CDFA SECRETARY
ANNOUNCED LAST WEEK THAT WE WILL
BEGIN THE PROCESS OF CANCELING
FOR PEER A FALSE WHICH IS A
PRETTY WIDELY USED -- PESTICIDE
HERE IN CALIFORNIA -- THAT IT
CERTAINLY HAS HEALTH PROBLEMS SO --
AS WE BEGIN THAT PROCESS AND WE
BEGAN LOOKING AT MOVING FORWARD
WITH THAT CERTAINLY WE
UNDERSTAND THAT THERE'S GOING TO
BE THE NEED FOR LESS TOXIC A
MORE SUSTAINABLE -- SAFER
ALTERNATIVES TO THE USE OF THAT
FOR THE GROWERS SO WHAT WE ARE
REQUESTING TODAY IS MONEY TO SET
UP -- DPR SPECIFICALLY IS
REQUESTING TWO POINT TWO TWO
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS -- WITH
THAT MONEY WE WANT TO A HUNDRED
AND TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS
OF THAT MONEY WOULD BE USED TO
BEGIN -- SETTING UP A TASK FORCE
A WORK GROUP IF YOU WILL. TO
LOOK AT WHAT ALTERNATIVES -- ARE
OUT THERE WHAT WE WANT TO DO IS
HAVE A DIVERSE GROUP OF PEOPLE --
THAT HAVE EXPERIENCEIS NOT ONLY
IN RESEARCH BUT ALSO IN THE
APPLICATION OF PESTICIDES IN
PEST MANAGEMENT ALTERNATIVES WE
WANT TO HAVE A VERY DIVERSE
GROUP OF THAT WILL LOOK AT WHAT
THE STATE OF THE ART IS NOW OR
THE STATE OF THE SCIENCE.
WHERE ARE WE ON FLICKR FOSS
ALTERNATIVES WORLDWIDE NOT JUST
IN THE UNITED STATES NOT JUST IN
CALIFORNIA BUT WORLDWIDE AND HOW
CAN WE BUILD ON THAT TO TRY TO
BRING THE SITE FOR LESS TOXIC
ALTERNATIVES? TO THE THE FIELD
AND GET THEM THROUGH THE
REGISTRATION PROCESS QUICKLY --
TO GO AHEAD AND MAKE THOSE
ALTERNATIVES AVAILABLE AND OF
COURSE IN ADDITION TO THOSE
TYPES OF ALTERNATIVES WE BE
LOOKING AT INTEGRATED PEST
MANAGEMENT ALTERNATIVES -- HOW
CAN WE APPLY SAFER HOW CAN WE
REDUCE THE TOXICITY BY --
BRINGING IN CERTAIN.
THE SOIL -- MANIPULATIONS OR
THINGS LIKE THAT THAT WOULD BE
ABLE TO TO CUT DOWN THE TOXICITY
OF THESE ALTERNATIVES.
SO THE OTHER TWO POINT ONE
MILLION DOLLARS WOULD BE FOR
RESEARCH GRANTS AS YOU'RE AWARE
WE HAVE CURRENTLY HAVE IN OUR
BUDGET NINE HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS. FOR RESEARCH GRANTS ON
LESS TOXIC ALTERNATIVES TO
PESTICIDES THIS WOULD BE AN
ADDITIONAL TWO POINT ONE MILLION
DOLLARS THAT WE WOULD BE LOOKING
AT ALTERNATIVES. TO CORPORATE
FOSTER -- WE HOPE THAT IF THIS
IS A VERY SUCCESSFUL PROGRAM WE
CAN MOVE FORWARD WITH ACTUALLY
CONTINUING THAT YEAH IN THE NEXT
BUDGET YEAR. TO BE ABLE TO START
LOOKING AT OTHER OF THE MORE
TOXIC ALTERNATIVES WE ARE MORE
TOXIC PESTICIDES WE HAVE
CURRENTLY IN USE LIKE ORGANIC
PHOSPHATES CORPORATE MATES -- PM
AGAINST SOME OF THOSE ISSUES.
AND ALL TURNED OUT FOR AND HAVE
CDFA EXPLAIN THEIR PORTION.
A GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN BLOOM
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE KEVIN
ALSO HARD DEPUTY SECRETARY
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF FOOD
AND AGRICULTURE.
IN AS ACTING DIRECTOR MARKS
MENTIONED WE HAVE A COMPONENT
HERE WE HAVE ONE AND A HALF
MILLION DOLLARS.
IN THERE WITH ME AS I EXPLAIN
THIS AND THE REASON I DO THIS IS
SO THAT YOU GUYS CAN HAVE A FULL
UNDERSTANDING OF OTHERS MORE
THAN JUST THIS REQUESTED FUNDING
THAT GOES TO THIS ONE PARTICULAR
COMPONENT.
THE MILLION AND A HALF IS.
A TO GO TOWARDS BRINGING MORE OF
WHAT WE CALL AYE OR FOR PROJECTS
INTO THE PIPELINE OTHERS A
SEVERE BACKLOG RIGHT NOW OF
THOSE PROJECTS THEY TAKE THREE
TO FOUR YEARS TO COME TO
FRUITION.
AND FOR THE CURRENT BUDGET YEAR
LAST YEAR YOU APPROVED FIVE
HUNDRED AND TWENTY NINE THOUSAND
DOLLARS IN GENERAL FUND ON GOING
FOR US TO START GETTING SOME OF
THOSE PROJECTS MOVED ALONG OF
WHICH WE'VE DONE -- FOR BUDGET
YEAR AS PART OF THE PREVIOUSLY
HEARD TECHNICAL BUDGET
ADJUSTMENTS YEAH THAT WAS LIKE A
PACKAGE DEAL REMEMBER THOSE FROM
ABOUT A MONTH AGO. ONE OF THOSE
PROPOSALS WAS FOR AG FENDER
FORTY FOR A LITTLE MORE THAN A
MILLION DOLLARS TO CONTINUE
DOING SOME OF THAT EFFORT.
AND SO THIS MILLION AND A HALF
AS PART OF THAT.
AND SO -- WHEN YOU ADD ALL THAT
UP TOGETHER THEN THAT WOULD IN
THIS IS ONE TIME THE MILLION AND
A HALF WOULD RESULT IN US REALLY
BEING ABLE TO BREAK THROUGH THAT
LOG JAM TO GET A LOT OF THOSE
PROJECTS MOVING ALONG?
WITH THOSE PROJECTS TO DO IS IS
THEY PROVIDE THE NECESSARY FIELD
LEVEL DATA WORKING COLLECTIONS
SO THAT YOU CAN GET
REGISTRATIONS.
ON MATERIALS THAT ARE LESS
IMPACTFUL THAN SOMETHING LIKE
CLEAR PER OF US BUT WE'RE NOT
SOLELY FOCUSED IN ON THAT THE I.
R. FOR LOOKS AT A WHOLE WIDE
RANGE OF DIFFERENT MATERIALS FOR
SPECIALLY CROP GROWERS.
IN THERE THE DISADVANTAGE
BECAUSE OF LOW AMOUNTS OF
ACREAGE WHICH TRANSLATES INTO
LOW AMOUNTS OF SELLABLE PRODUCT
MANUFACTURERS TYPICALLY DON'T
WANT TO SPEND THAT MONEY AND
TIME TO REGISTER SOME OF THESE
PROP PRODUCTS EVEN THOUGH THESE
PRODUCTS.
ARE MORE OR LESS IMPACTFUL TO
THE ENVIRONMENT MIGHT EVEN BE
MORE EFFICACIOUS TO THE GROWERS
OF THE SPECIALTY CROPS.
AND SO THAT'S WHAT THAT MONEY'S
GOING TO GO TOWARDS.
AND THEN THERE'S ALSO TWO
MILLION GO TOWARDS BIOLOGICALLY
INTEGRATED FARMING SYSTEMS AND
THAT SORT OF A RESURRECTION OF A
PROGRAM THAT YOU SEE COOPERATIVE
EXTENSION HAD ABOUT THOUGH IT
DOESN'T -- SO MORE YEARS AGO
WHERE THEY DID DEMONSTRATION
PROJECTS WITH GROWERS USING THE
BODY OF KNOWLEDGE OF INTEGRATED
PEST MANAGEMENT IN INTEGRATED
THAT INTO FARMING SYSTEMS AND
METHODOLOGY. TO DEMONSTRATE THAT
LOWER INPUTS AND USING.
INTEGRATED PEST MANAGEMENT
TECHNIQUES LIKE ENHANCED
SCOUTING AND WITHHOLDING
TREATMENT UNTIL CERTAIN
THRESHOLDS ARE MET TO REDUCE
OVERALL PESTICIDE USAGE.
AS WELL AS THE LOWER FERTILIZER
INPUTS AND OTHER THINGS LIKE
THAT THAT WOULD BE CONSIDERED --
MORE BENEFICIAL BUT YET GROWERS
WOULD BE HESITANT BECAUSE THERE
BE THE RISK OF YIELD LOSS OR NOT
MAKING QUALITY CONSIDERATIONS.
AS A DEMONSTRATION PROJECTS ARE
A REALLY GOOD WAY TO DO THAT TO
ROLL THAT OUT CLUB COOPER OF
EXTENSION HAS AN EXTENSIVE
NETWORK OF CROP ADVISORS.
WHO ARE WELL POSITIONED TO FIND
GROWERS WHO COULD HOST THOSE
DEMONSTRATION PROJECTS IN IT'S
MONEY WELL SPENT BECAUSE THAN
OTHER GROWERS SEE THAT?
AND THAT'S REALLY HOW YOU SHIFT
THE PARADIGM IN HOW GROWERS
ADOPT CERTAIN PRACTICES.
OF WHICH ALL THESE PRACTICES IN
THE BIOLOGICAL INTEGRATED
FARMING SYSTEMS ARE CONSIDER
VERY BENEFICIAL AND ALSO JUST
YOU KNOW A LOT LESS HARMFUL TO
THE ENVIRONMENT.
AND THAT'S ALSO ONE TIME MONEY
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THE COMMENTS ALL RIGHT.
THEN THE THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR PRESENTATION ON BOTH OF
THESE ISSUES IS THERE ANY PUBLIC
COMMENTS I OR ANYONE IS FROM
SORRY -- PUBLIC COMMENT ON ISSUE.
TWENTY FOUR GOOD AFTERNOON
MISTER CHAIRMAN RESERVE THE
COMMITTEE LARA KNOWING HE CHECK
ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA CITRUS
MUTUAL CALIFORNIA FRESH FOR
DISSOCIATION WESTERN ART
PROCESSORS ASSOCIATION IN
CALIFORNIA CONGENERS AND GROWERS
ASSOCIATION -- WE JUST WANT TO
EXPRESS OUR APPRECIATION -- FOR
THIS FUNDING TO FIND
ALTERNATIVES AND SPEED UP THE
PROCESS OF GETTING SOME OF THESE
ALTERNATIVES INTO THE MARKET SO
THAT GROWERS CAN BE USING I'M
HERE IN CALIFORNIA -- WE ALSO
APPRECIATE THE GOVERNOR I'M
SPEAKING ABOUT THE INCLUSION OF
GROWERS AND GROWERS GROUPING
REGISTRANTS IN THIS PROCESS TO
ENSURE IT IS A GOOD PROCESS AND
AND SHE WAS THE RESULTS.
THAT EVERYONE WANTS -- SO WE
JUST WANT TO EXPRESS OUR
APPRECIATION FOR THAT AND LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
LEGISLATURE.
AND DEPARTMENT ASIDE REGULATION
AND CDFA ON THIS PROCESS THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- SPEAKING
IS -- SOMEBODY WHO IS -- VERY --
LONG TERM CONCERNED ABOUT -- THE
HARM -- TO WILDLIFE AND TO HUMAN
SO I FROM -- PESTICIDE USE THIS
IS VERY OF WELCOME FUNDING AND
TO ONE OF THE HOPEFULLY WE'LL
SEE A RAPID PROGRESS OF THANK
YOU VERY MUCH -- THAT WILL TAKE
US -- NOW -- TO OUR LAST
APARTMENT APARTMENT FOOD
AGRICULTURE YOU'RE GONNA STICK
AROUND FOR FOUR MORE ISSUES.
TWENTY FIVE THROUGH TWENTY EIGHT
THE FIRST ONE IS -- RELATIVE TO
PROP TWELVE IMPLEMENTATION.
OKAY GOOD AFTERNOON ITEM TWENTY
FIVE OR ISSUE TWENTY FIVE FOR
MENTAL CAN CONFINEMENT.
IN THIS IS OUR PROPOSAL IS A
DIRECT RESPONSE TO THE PASSAGE
OF PROPOSITION TWO LAST NOVEMBER
ON FARM ANIMAL CONFINEMENT.
WELL SORRY TWELVE GOT A MOMENT
TO PROP TWO WAS YEARS AGO.
SOMETIMES IT DOESN'T SEEM LIKE
IT'S BEEN THAT MANY YEARS.
WE'RE REQUESTING FOUR POINT FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS IN GENERAL FUND
FOR NINETEEN TWENTY AND TWO
MILLION DOLLARS AND TWENTY
TWENTY ONE AN ON GOING.
AND FOURTEEN POSITIONS FOR THE
INITIAL IMPLEMENTATION OF
PROPOSITION.
TWELVE IN THIS MEASURE WHAT
REQUIRES -- CERTAIN CONFINEMENT
SPACE CONSIDERATIONS -- FOR
POULTRY SWINE AND FEEL AND AND
ALL OF DOCTOR JONES AND LET ME
INTRODUCE DOCTOR JONES A STATE
THAT MERION AND SHE'LL BE HERE
FOR THE NEXT TWO ITEMS.
AND THIS FALLS UNDER HER AREA OF
RESPONSIBILITY AND CHILLED
DESCRIBE THE SYSTEM BY WHERE WE
ALREADY DO SOMETHING KIND OF
SIMILAR BUT IT'S NOT QUITE THE
SAME IN THIS EXPANDS UPON THE
REQUIREMENTS TO GET BROUGHT INTO
THIS IN THE POULTRY SECTOR.
AS FAR AS VERIFYING CAGE SIZES
AND DIFFERENT THINGS LIKE THAT --
BUT WHAT THE SIMILARITIES WHAT
MAKES THIS KIND OF COMPLEX AND
WE'VE HAD A HARD TIME REALLY
EXPLAINING IT BUT I THINK THAT
WE'VE HAD BREAKTHROUGHS LATELY
IN EXPLAINING IT IN A VERY
SIMPLISTIC MANNER.
THE PROPOSITION WAS WRITTEN IN A
WAY THAT ALL THESE MEAT PRODUCTS.
ARE REQUIRED TO THE ANIMAL SPACE
CONFINEMENTS ARE REQUIRED TO BE
MET FOR THE SUBSEQUENT ME
PRODUCTS TO BE INTRODUCED INTO
TRADE CHANNELS IN CALIFORNIA SO
THAT'S WHAT REALLY DRIVES THIS
AND THAT'S WHAT MAKES IT A
LITTLE MORE COMPLEX WHEN YOU
START LOOKING AT IT.
VERSUS JUST SIMPLY SAYING THAT
IT'S A SIMPLE VERIFICATION OF
WHAT'S HERE IN CALIFORNIA IT'S
WHAT TURNED CALIFORNIA TRACED
BACK THROUGH TRADE CHANNELS
ESPECIALLY WITH SWINE -- SINCE
THE OTHER REQUIREMENTS ARE ON
THE FAILING OPERATIONS WHERE THE
PIGLETS ARE PRODUCED BUT THAT'S
NOT NECESSARILY WHO FEEDS AND
FIISHES THEM OUT IN ALTERNATELY
PUTS HIM IN THE MARKET PLACE.
SO YOU CAN SEE WHERE OUR
RESPONSIBILITIES ARE FAIRLY FAR
REACHING AND THAT'S WHY WE NEED
PEOPLE TO BE ABLE TO DO THESE
VERIFICATIONS.
AND ALSO TO WRITE THE SUBSEQUENT
REGULATIONS AND TO HELL
PROGRAMMATIC LEE OPERATE THIS
AND THEN I'LL TURN IT OVER TO DR
JON STEAD DETAILS.
THANK YOU.
WELCOME SUGGESTED MAYBE.
REITERATE IT USING SOME
DIFFERENT WORSE AT TO WHAT KEVIN
SAID BASICALLY THAT PROPOSITION
ITSELF APPLIES TO COVERED
ANIMALS WHICH IT LISTS WHICH
WERE ALREADY MENTIONED.
IN ON PRODUCTS FROM COVERED
ANIMALS SO JUST TO REITERATE FOR
SWINE FOR EXAMPLE IT COVERS A
WHOLE RAW -- PARTS OF SWINE THAT
ARE INTENDED FOR HUMAN
CONSUMPTION PORK HORA PORQUE
THAT'S INTENDED FOR HUMAN
CONSUMPTION.
AND IN ORDER TO BE.
SOLD IN CALIFORNIA THE TO PUT IT
IN PRETTY SIMPLISTIC TERMS THEM
THE MOTHERS OF THOSE ANIMALS
THAT PRODUCE THAT MEET HAVE TO
BEEN CONFINED IN A CERTAIN WAY
WHICH REQUIRES REGISTRATION
VERIFICATION OUT THE BREEDING
BARNES INTO IT.
WHEREVER THE ANIMALS ARE RAISED
YEAH SAME FOR VEAL SAME FOR
ACHES AND IT ALSO EXPANDS EGGS
TO INCLUDE LIQUITEX [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
HELLO.
ISSUE.
TWENTY SIX ISSUE TWENTY SIX
MISSOURI WHERE WE HAVE A FOREIGN
ANIMAL DISEASE CALLED.
NEW CASTLE DISEASE THAT'S
IMPACTING THE POULTRY INDUSTRY
DOWN A SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
LARGELY THIS IS EXISTING IN
BACKYARD POULTRY AND GAME FELL
BREEDERS -- BUT IT HAS HIT SOME
COMMERCIAL FACILITIES DOWN THERE
THAT POTENTIALLY COULD BE VERY
DEVASTATING FOR CALIFORNIA WE'VE
BEEN INVOLVED IN THIS RESPONSE
FOR A YEAR NOW IT STARTED IN MAY
OF LAST YEAR.
AND NEEDLESS TO SAY TO BE QUITE
FRANK WE LEARNED A LOT IN THE
LAST YEAR AND NOW THAT'S WHAT'S
REALLY GUIDED AND INFORMED US TO
BE VERY SELECTIVE ON HOW WE
CRAFTED THIS PROPOSAL.
TO ASK FOR VERY SPECIFIC
RESOURCES FROM THESE LESSONS
LEARNED AS WE DO THIS AND WE'RE
VERY OPTIMISTIC THAT WE'RE GOING
TO BE SUCCESSFUL IN NEXT FEW
MONTHS OF A RADIC HITTING THIS
DISEASE -- BUT WE ALSO HAVE TO
HAVE A REALITY CHECK THAT WE
NEED THESE RESOURCES THE
SPECIFIC ONES FOR US TO BE MORE
EFFECTIVE AND DOING THE BEST WE
CAN IN PREVENTING FUTURE
DISEASES ARE NOT ONLY OF THIS
ONE BUT OF SIMILAR TYPES OF
DISEASES -- BUT ALSO SO THAT WE
CAN HAVE A RAPID RESPONSE
CAPABILITY TO BE ABLE TO GET IN
THERE MORE QUICKLY THAN WE DID
THIS TIME.
AND EVEN TO SUSTAIN THAT PACING
THAT QUICK PACE FOR A MORE
SUSTAINED PERIOD OF TIME BECAUSE
WE WORE OURSELVES OUT FRANKLY.
AND THEN ALSO WITHIN THIS IS
ANOTHER TEAM TO HELP US BETTER
RESPOND TO ANIMAL EMERGENCY
SITUATIONS WHERE WE'VE HAD
CATASTROPHIC OF IT CATASTROPHIC
EVENTS SUCH AS FIRES OR FLOODS
OR THINGS LIKE THAT.
WHERE THERE'S A LOT OF ANIMAL
MOVEMENT DUE TO EVACUATION FOR
JUST IMPACTS WITH PEOPLE BEING
SEPARATED FROM ANIMALS
REUNIFICATION IN CARE OF THEM
DURING THE INTERIM TIME?
AND WE ALSO.
DID THE SENATE CERTAIN -- VERY
DELIBERATE WAY BECAUSE WE FEEL
THAT THIS IS AN EFFICIENT USE OF
RESOURCES AND SPECIFIC TYPES OF
RESOURCES TO HELP US BE
EFFECTIVE IN ALL OF THESE
DIFFERENT VENUES AND ALL A
DOCTOR JONES AT SOME COMMENTS
HERE.
TO RIGHT SO THIS -- THIS
PROPOSAL REFLECTS THAT GOT
CONCEPT THAT WE SHARE WITH CAL
FIRE ANOTHER FIRST RESPONDERS
AND THAT WE DO TRY AND WELL WE
TRAIN WE HAVE SPECIFIC
INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE HIGHLY
SKILLED IN SPECIFIC AREAS WE
ALSO TRYING TO MAINTAIN A ALL
HAZARDS APPROACH SO IT'S ALL
HAZARDS AS WITH REGARD.
ANIMAL DISEASE AS WELL AS OTHER
TO THE DISASTERS THAT CAN INFECT
ANIMALS SO -- WE HAVE CLEAR NEED
FOR THESE SPECIFIC SKILL SETS
THE INTENTION AS WHEN WE SCALE
UP TO RESPOND THESE WOULD BE THE
LEADER SEIZE WOULD BE THE PEOPLE
THAT INSURED ARE TEMPORARY HIRES
ARE FOLLOWING.
A BEST PRACTICES IT ALSO HELPS
MAINTAIN BUT ALSO THEY COULD BE
RE PURPOSED -- AS NEEDED TO ANY
RESPONSE THAT'S REQUIRED FOR THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU ANY ADDITIONAL
COMMENTS.
LET'S MOVE ON TO ISSUE.
TWENTY SEVEN ISSUE TWENTY SEVEN
HAVE TO DEAL WITH TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE TO BE PROVIDED -- TO
FARMERS THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA TO HELP THEM BETTER
COMPLY WITH THE PRODUCE SAFETY
RULE WHICH IS ADMINISTERED BY
THE FOOD AND DRUG ADMINISTRATION
AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL -- BUT THIS
IS A HIGHLY INTEGRATED APPROACH
HERE IN CALIFORNIA WHERE OUR
DEPARTMENT IN CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH --
WORKS IN UNISON WITH FTA TO
IMPLEMENT THE FARMER THE PRODUCE
SAFETY RULE ON THE FARMS AND WE
MOST RECENTLY STARED INSPECTING
SOME OF THESE FARMS.
AND ONE THING WE'VE LEARNED NOT
JUST VERY RECENTLY BUT AS WE'VE --
ON WROTE AND FOR ALL THIS
PROCESS.
IS IT THERE'S A LOT OF DIFFERENT
TYPES OF FARMS VERY DIVERSE BASE
OF FARM SIZES COMPLEXITY
DIFFERENT TYPES OF CROPS GROWN --
THERE'S EVEN REGIONALLY SPECIFIC
THINGS TO CREATE CERTAIN
CONDITIONS THAT HAVE TO BE
ADDRESSED FROM A FOOD SAFETY
PERSPECTIVE.
AND TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE IS JUST
THIS COMMON THREAD WOVEN
THROUGHOUT ALL OF THAT THAT'S
NEEDED OUT THERE TO HELP GET
BETTER COMPLIANCE.
BUT IF THE END OF THE DAY IT
REALLY ISN'T ABOUT THE
COMPLIANCE BECAUSE A COMPLIANCE
LEADS TO THE FOOD SAFETY
EXPECTATIONS THAT -- THE PUBLIC
EXPECTS OUT OF BEING ABLE TO GO
IN AND BUY A THESE PRODUCE ITEMS.
AND SO THAT'S THE BASIS FOR THIS
REQUEST IS TO PROVIDE THE
RESOURCES TO GET TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE OUT TO THE FIELD
LEVEL.
IN ALL INTRODUCED NATALIE CROP
GREENBERGER'S DIRECTOR
INSPECTION SERVICES AND SHE'S
DIRECTLY INVOLVED WITH SOME OF
THE RECENT OUTBREAKS AND
ADMINISTERS THIS AND SHE CAN ADD
A FEW COMMENTS.
LINK GOOD MORNING THAT'LL CUT
GREENBERGER Và SAYS SO ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT WE'VE BEEN
FOCUSED ON IS IN TWENTY SIXTEEN
WE TOOK ON THE ROLE IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA ON BEHALF OF THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. TO PERFORM
THE INSPECTIONS FOR THE FOOD
SAFETY MODERNIZATION ACT AND AS
A RESULT OF THAT AND ONE OF OUR
LARGE TASKS WERE TO READY
FARMERS FOR THE RULE AND THAT
INCLUDED A TWO PHASE APPROACH TO
FIRST WAS EDUCATIONAL.
AND THEN THE SECOND IS
INSPECTIONS AND SO THIS YEAR
WE'VE STARTED OUR INSPECTIONS
BUT FOR THE FIRST TWO YEARS WE
FOCUSED ON EDUCATION.
AND LOOKING AT SURVEYS AND THE
RESULTS THAT WE RECEIVED FROM
OUR FARMERS WHAT WE ARE HEARING
IS LAW VIRTUALLY THERE IN NEED
OF TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE AND IT'S
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE.
SET CENTRIC TO THE RULE BECAUSE
IT'S A PREVNTIVE RULES YOU HAVE
TO UNDERSTAND YOUR FARM AND BE
ABLE TO IMPLEMENT THOSE
PRACTICES THAT -- ADDRESSING
CONTROL RISK BUT THEN IT
SECONDARY WHEN WE SEE THINGS
LIKE OUTBREAKS AND REALLY BEING
ABLE TO FOCUS ON WHAT MEASURES
CAN WE PUT IN PLACE THAT PREVENT
THOSE THINGS FROM HAPPENING
AGAIN SO THAT WE CAN PROTECT
PUBLIC HEALTH.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR ADDITIONAL
COMMENTS AND LOOKS LIKE THAT
WILL CONCLUDE -- HI THIS ITEM
UNLESS THERE'S QUESTIONS FOR THE
DICE.
RIGHT OUR LAST ITEM IS ISSUE
TWENTY EIGHT UNCLAIMED GAS TAX.
HI THIS IS TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE
FOR A TECHNICAL ADJUSTMENT TO A
FOOD NAG CODE SECTION. TO GIVE
THE DEPARTMENT -- LITTLE MORE
FLEXIBILITY ON HOW UNCLAIMED GAS
TAXES APPROPRIATED FOR USE FOR
AGRICULTURAL PROGRAMS.
AND I KNOW THAT IT'S GETTING
LATE AND I KNOW YOU GUYS HAVE
BEEN UP FOR AN AWFUL LONG TIME
SO.
UNLESS YOU SPECIFICALLY REQUEST
THAT I CAN SAVE YOU THE WHOLE
EXPLANATION IN THE HISTORY OF
UNCLAIMED GAS TAX OR I CAN GIVE
YOU THE THIRTY SECOND ELEVATOR --
THANK YOU ARE READ THE STAFF
REPORT COLLEAGUES OKAY THE
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION SO REALLY
IT IS JUST A TECHNICAL
ADJUSTMENT.
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR THAT AND
THE LA -- HAS NOTHING ELSE TO
ADD.
IS THERE ANY PUBLIC COMMENT ON
ISSUES TWENTY FIVE TWENTY SIX
TWENTY SEVEN OR TWENTY EIGHT
HELLO HI GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER
CHAIRMAN OF THE COMMITTEE
LEARNED ON HE TOOK ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA CITRUS MUTUAL ON
VARIOUS OTHER AG TRADE
ASSOCIATIONS IN SUPPORT OF THE
LAST ITEM.
I'M SORRY FOR UP NUMBER ISSUE
TWENTY EIGHT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THOSE FOUR
ITEMS WILL BE HELD OPEN AND THAT
BRINGS US TO THE CONCLUSION OF
OUR MEETING THERE.
HAVE BEEN NO VOTE SO THERE WILL
BE NO ADD ONS TO DO ONE AT YOUR
GOOD.
OF YOU WERE LOOKING AT ME LIKE
YOU MIGHT HAVE TO TAKE THE
MATTER THAT WE ADDRESSED ALL
THAT YOU GUYS NEEDED IT OKAY
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH --
AND SO -- OUR MEETING IS
ADJOURNED THANK YOU